Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Ich sehe dich, aber frage mich, sitzt du noch oder stehst du schon?
Gerade sitze ich, aber ich stehe jetzt viel.
Okay, lass mich raten. Du hast dir einen Stehpult gesehen, nachdem du es bei mir gesehen hast.
Ganz richtig. Ich war bei dir und dachte, ich brauche ein solches Stehpult. Da kann man den Laptop draufstehen und dann kann man stehend schreiben. Ich hatte schon mal mit dem Gedanken gespielt, habe aber dann noch nicht so richtig was gefunden. Und das war jetzt aber für mich ein Anlass zu sagen, schick mir den Link. Ich will das auch haben. Gestern gekommen, gleich aufgebaut. Es steht jetzt da. Es ist wunderbar. Ich habe gestern vier Stunden schon daran gestanden. Ich habe gestern 16.000 Zeichen getippt. Ich bin so begeistert. Also ich habe jetzt einen Run. Es ist hervorragend. Das ist ein ganz neues Gefühl. Zum Lesen würde ich nach wie vor sagen, möchte ich lieber sitzen. Das ist nicht so meine Haltung. Vor allem ist man dann auch eher in so einer Buckelhaltung. Das glaube ich ist dann noch nicht so toll. Dann kann man es lieber am Schreibtisch machen. Aber tippen auf dem Computer, dort stehen. Es ist ganz, ganz wunderbar.
Siehst du, du bist immer eine Etage über mir. Ich lese im Liegen, schreibe dann im Sitzen. Aber wenn ich meine, und da bin ich ganz Sklave meiner Technik, wenn mir meine Uhr darauf hinweist, Stefan, stell dich hin, dann stelle ich mich hin. Und das kann man vielleicht allgemein empfehlen. Viele erzählen irgendwas von hochfahrbaren Schreibtischen und so. Ja, das geht, nur wenn du auf den Knopf drückst und da ist ein kleiner Motor und der pumpt irgendwo rum und dann fährt der Schreibtisch hoch, dann dauert das eine Minute, bis der oben ist. Und einfach sich hinzustellen und sofort weiterzumachen, sodass der Computer fast gar nicht merkt, dass man sich zwischendurch kurz woanders hinbewegt hat, weil der Satz einfach in der gleichen Geschwindigkeit fortgeführt wird. Das ist genau richtig. Keine Ablenkung, deswegen keine 1000 Euro teuren hochfahrbaren Schreibtische kaufen, sondern 100 Euro teure Stehpulte, an die man einfach sofort wechseln kann. Du mit dem Laptop kannst du auch hin und her wechseln, nimmst einen in die Hand, zack, zack. Ja, also das ist vielleicht ein Tipp jetzt zum Jahresstart 2022. Wir müssen zurück zur Produktivität, bevor wir von Friedrich Merz ausgepeitscht werden. Und da lohnt es sich doch, wenn ich schon Homeoffice, dann auch mit Stehoptionen. Sehr gut, freue ich mich, dass wir dich da upgraden konnten an der Stelle.
Peter Thiel würde wahrscheinlich auch stehen. Er lebt ja sehr gesund, rührte schon in jungen Jahren immer Vitamine sich laufend zu. Es gibt ja dieses Gerücht, das auch nicht so ganz aufgeklärt wird in diesem Buch. Wie das dann ist, lässt er sich wirklich Blut von jungen Männern transpirieren.
Du willst gleich mit der Hardkorporate anfangen?
Ja, wir wollen noch nicht damit anfangen, aber wir wollen sie zumindest schon mal teasern. Parabiose, also um sich jung zu halten, Blut von jungen Männern, es ist obskur, aber es ist nicht das einzige Obskure im Leben von Peter Thiel.
Pass auf, jetzt wollen wir die Parabiose schon, ich hätte sie mir ja aufgeoben, aber jetzt hast du die Katze schon aus dem Sack gelassen. Sie steht doch erst im Epilog, oder wie das am Ende heißt. Also im Upside sozusagen. Aber ich habe auch während dieses Buchs die ganze Zeit gedacht, was für eine verdrehte Welt. Peter Thiel gehört mit zu den Anführern und heute ist 6. Januar. Also heute vor einem Jahr stürmten die das Parlament dort. Und Peter Thiel gehört nun mit zur Führungsriege, informalen Führungsriege einer Gruppe von Menschen, die in zig Millionen gemessen wird, die den anderen unterstellen, sich mit Kinderblut zu verjüngen. Während wir in einem ganz ernsthaft geschriebenen und mit großem Fleiß und auch großer juristischer Vorsicht recherchierten Buch davon lesen, dass Peter Thiel wohl Parabiose, also die Verknüpfung von zwei Organismen, um den Nervenkreislauf des einen aufrecht zu halten, obwohl er schon alt ist, mit dem Herz-Lungen-Kreislauf eines Jüngeren zu verschmelzen, um sich dadurch länger Leben zu machen. Wo das sich getraut wird, drin zu schreiben, wo wir also irgendwie dann doch denken, das kann nicht völlig aus der Luft gegriffen sein. So und das ist aber nur die Pointe in einem Buch, bei dem wir, wenn wir es lesen, über hunderte Seiten uns die ganze Zeit fragen und diejenigen, über die hier gerade geschrieben wird, unterstellen anderen einen Deep State. Deep State Ideologie, während sie selber so vorgehen. Also das ist ja wirklich absolut verdreht. Und damit können wir wieder zum Anfang zurückspringen. Ganz genau.
Lass mich einen ganz kurzen Abschnitt vorlesen und dann kannst du sofort weitermachen, worum es eigentlich dem Autor hier geht. Und zwar sagt er ganz klar, wir haben Thiel unterschätzt. Und wenn ich sage wir, dann meint das auch New York Times. Dann meint das, dass Karras Fischer mal so ein Porträt schreibt und sagt, ja, das ist der intelligenteste Investor oder so etwas, aber überhaupt nicht die Dimension erkennt. Also mehrmals kommt er auch gerade auf New York Times und so zu sprechen, dass man das nicht erkennen wollte, nicht oder vielleicht einfach billigend in Kauf genommen hat. Wir können ja auch hinzufügen, Peter Thiel hat den Frank-Schirmacher-Preis bekommen. Auch das ist etwas, was man überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kann. Laudatio, hattest du mir dann erzählt, hat Sebastian Kurz gehalten.
Auf Wunsch von Thiel, ja. Wir können das aber nachher gleich einordnen. Ich kann es mir jetzt erklären. Es steckt eine Erklärung im Buch.
Ich bin sehr gespannt. Und nun heißt es hier ziemlich am Anfang, Thiel wird manchmal als Vorzeigekonservativer der Tech-Branche porträtiert. Eine naive Ansicht, die seinen Einfluss stark unterschätzt. Mehr als jeder andere Investor oder Unternehmer des Silicon Valley. Sogar mehr noch als Jeff Bezos oder die Google-Kunder Larry Page und Sergey Prin oder Zuckerberg selbst ist er für die Entstehung der Ideologie verantwortlich, die das Silicon Valley inzwischen prägt. Das technischer Fortschritt unerbittlich realisiert werden muss, gänzlich oder zumindest weitgehend ungeachtet, der potenziellen Kosten oder Gefahren für die Gesellschaft.
Ja, und das ist eine sehr gruselige, aber wohl zutreffende Prämisse, denn sie wird die ganze Zeit bestätigt. Vielleicht will klar diese Bücher an Amerika, die gehen immer los mit Ich habe 100 Gespräche geführt und das ist dann so und so weiter. Der Chafkin macht es ein bisschen ausführlicher, aber nicht zu explizit und fängt ja an erst mal zu schreiben. 2016 war Peak Silicon Valley. Das scheint ja auch so der Zeitpunkt zu sein, also heute vor fünf Jahren, wo er sich so dachte, eigentlich müsste man darüber mal schreiben. Und wir haben ja auch von Adrian Daub, wir haben sein Buch gelesen. Mir ist ja Adrian Daub als Autor auch damals aufgefallen, weil er in einer Neuen Zürcher oder so so ein Peter Thiel, die Ideologien des Peter Thiel oder so aufschrieb. Und ich so dachte, was schreiben die da? Ja, was ist denn da los? Wo man so ein tiefes Bedürfnis der Autoren merkt, darüber muss jetzt mal geschrieben werden, auch wenn wir noch nicht den Leser mit dem ersten Text überzeugen, sehr viele Fragezeichen zurücklassen oder sonst irgendwie. Aber das gehört jetzt mal irgendwie so in den roten Faden gebunden. Und das haben wir ja hier auch wieder. Also es ist ein ganz spektakulärer Text, so insgesamt als Text einfach, der uns hier so Angebote gemacht, mal etwas zu beobachten, was wir bisher nicht sehen, auch weil Peter Thiel sich selbst so versteckt hält. Und auch der Mut dazugehört zu sagen, ja, wir bauen jetzt hier mal ein Bild zusammen aus einzelnen Puzzleteilen. Das wird aber nicht vollständig, aber es wird uns trotzdem einiges sagen. Und klar, ein paar Sachen bleiben einfach blank. Und da fand ich es ganz gut, dass man das mal beschreibt, so 2016, ohne gleich mit der Tür ins Haus zu fallen, als Trump gewählt wurde und der Brexit passierte und so weiter. Das wissen wir alles, das haben wir im Hinterkopf. Aber ja, 2016 war Peek Silicon Valley. Da hat sich irgendwie die Idiotie durchgesetzt. Da ist sie Mehrheit geworden, irgendwie so. Das können wir ja soweit abbilden. Und in deren Sicht ein ganz guter Start ins Buch. Thiel schaut also auf die Welt und er hilft Zuckerberg aus der Patsche, als es plötzlich hieß, im Wahlkampf noch. Facebook ist ja viel zu links, hier kommen ja die Rechten gar nicht zur Geltung. Wir werden ja hier aussortiert. Diese kleine Posse mit den Trending-Topics und so weiter. Hab ich ja damals auch bei Übermedien drüber geschrieben. Aber so, ja gut, die haben halt manipuliert. Statt irgendwelche Algos gewähren zu lassen, da saß er einfach in der Redaktion, hat halt ausgewählt. Wir lassen ja nur New York Times, Washington Post und so Texte durch. Und das hat halt so einen linkslastigen Anstrich, von dem man sich fragen muss, wer linkslastig und so. Naja, aber jetzt so im großen Bild macht das irgendwie alles Sinn. Wir haben auf der einen Seite so diese Ideologen wie Zuckerberg, der ja gar nicht so viel liest, anders als Thiel. Also nicht so eine Leserat, aber trotzdem begegnen sie sich da in dieser Art der Ideologie und müssen sich dann schon gegenseitig aus der Patsche helfen gegen eine Gesellschaft, die glaubt, dass sie diesen Chefs, die nun wirklich mit sagenhafter Macht regieren, böses will oder so. Also man weiß gar nicht, ist man hier so richtig in der Ideologiearbeit oder ist das Marketing, was da abläuft? Naja, also in deren Sicht ist das Buch da von Anfang an sehr gut aufgestellt und sagt auch ganz ehrlich, Zitat, Thiels Ideologie oder die Thiel Ideologie ist komplex und zum Teil widersprüchlich, aber damit kann man ja trotzdem arbeiten. Macht man dann also auch und dann fängt er so mit Schlagworten an. Monopole sind gut, Monarchien sind effizient und die Tech-Gründer sind natürlich gottgleich. Also alles, was wir eigentlich nicht so unterstützend finden als Sicht, das muss man hier erstmal als, also das ist erstmal Ausgangslage, auf der Basis beobachten wir das jetzt und dann kommt ja gleich mit Eric Schmidt, der ganz beeindruckt ist von Thiel und dann mit dem Zitat auffällt, wir brauchen Menschen, die die Lehrmeinungen in Frage stellen und wir haben schon mit Eric Schmidt einen, der sich vor zehn Jahren vor die Weltpresse stellte und sagte, also wir können Bösenkurse voraussagen, aber wir machen das nicht, weil wir es so für unethisch halten. Und alle haben sich damals gefragt, meint er das gerade ernst oder ist das wieder nur Marketing? Also können sie wirklich Bösenkurse voraussagen oder sagt er das nur, damit alle Investoren denken, die können Bösenkurse voraussagen, dann investiere ich mal. Mal gucken, da kommt bestimmt noch Großes. Ja, also diese Art von sind wir schon in der Realität oder ist das schon Matrix? Ja, so lesen wir das eigentlich die ganze Zeit und sind dann doch super gefesselt. Vor allem, das ist ja erstaunlich, dieser junge Thiel, dieser Überflieger, der jede Prüfung einfach mit besten Noten ablegt, damit auch immer angeben will, aber immer merkt, nee, das ist das falsche Milieu, ich bin hier im falschen Milieu, ich werde verlacht, ich werde ignoriert, aber eigentlich bin ich doch jetzt schon euer König, ich bin doch jetzt schon euer Chef eigentlich.
Ja, das ist die Haltung, die er eigentlich als Kind schon hat und ich verstehen kann, dass sich die anderen Kinder ihm nicht unterwerfen. Er ist da fast soziopathisch unterwegs, ist also nicht in der Lage, Empathie zu zeigen, lässt Leute sofort fallen, wenn es ihn nicht interessiert. Und er ist jemand, der sehr früh glaubt, eigentlich so eine Paranoia entwickelt, dass die Welt ihm Böses will und dass er nur, wenn er die Welt beherrscht und entsprechenden Reichtum sammelt, sich davor schützen kann. Später wird das dann dazu führen, dass er versucht, sich irgendwo Staatsbürgerschaften zu beschaffen, Bunker zu bauen und was es noch so alles dann gibt. Oder auch das Weltall ist natürlich eine gute Exit-Strategie für all das. In jungen Jahren geht das noch nicht so gut, aber er ist ein genialer Schachspieler, und er ist jemand, der sehr früh erkennt, dass man es doch eigentlich mal ganz gut aushalten kann, wenn man vollkommen gegen den Strom schwimmt. Und es ist erstaunlich, wie er sich also in den 80er Jahren, er ist ja ein Kind eines Einwanderers, also mit einem Jahr sind die Eltern von Deutschland nach Amerika gezogen, wie er dann sagt, die liberalen Eliten, und das schon gleich verbindet mit postmoderne Linke, Kultur, Marxismus und so weiter. Also der ganze Jordan Peterson Diskurs, den finden wir da schon komplett. Ja, also das ist so erstaunlich, dass das in den 80er Jahren schon ist. Das ist etwas, was ihn früh antreibt, am Ende seiner schulischen Laufbahn, dann aber vor allem in der Universität, wo er wirklich dann Radikalpositionen vertritt, die so weit gehen, dass er sagt, und er hat eine Zeit lang in dem Apartheitsregime gelebt, weil sein Vater dort auch für eine Firma mehr oder weniger saubere Geschäfte gemacht hat, das Apartheitsregime rechtfertigt und sagt, nö, an sich ist das aber doch auch keine schlechte Sache, wo er dann Artikel schreibt, die im höchsten Maße rassistisch homophob frauenfeindlich sind. Und das zieht sich durch die Jahrzehnte hindurch, obwohl, und das ist dann einer von vielen Widersprüchen, Peter Thiel spul ist, sich sehr spät erst öffentlich dazu bekennt, interessant ist, wo er das tut, nämlich bei den Republikanern dann, wirklich ganz öffentlich, 2016, als er Trump unterstützt, aber zuvor durchaus in der Lage ist, eine Zeitschrift mit herauszugeben und zu betreuen, in der Artikel erscheinen, dass die Homosexuellen das Unglück für die Gesellschaft sind, dass sie Aids bringen werden, dass sie moralische Verlotterung bringen werden und und und. All das wird in dieser Zeitschrift stattfinden. Er wird homophobe Äußerungen von Kommilitonen verteidigen, bis aufs Messer. Und das wird immer das sein, dieses gegen den Strom schwimmen und dieses Free-Speed-Ding, das in eine Richtung getrieben wird, bei der es eigentlich immer nur darum geht, den anderen zu schockieren und dann im rechten Moment an Macht zu gewinnen. Und das ist auch die Geschichte einer großen Machtakkumulation, die wir hier lesen.
Und es bietet sich auch an, relativ früh so küchenpsychologisch sich so einen Reim drauf zu machen. Peter Thiels Familie zieht also 68 nach Amerika und die Eltern werden sofort fanatische Republikaner. Das Phänomen kennt man ja immer wieder häufiger. Das ist dann fast so eine Dankbarkeit. Danke, dass ihr uns hier so aufnehmt. Wir zeigen euch jetzt mal, wie angepasst wir hier sind. Nixon macht das Angebot. Ihr müsst nur mir folgen, sozusagen und das richtig auf die Spitze treiben. Und dann funktioniert das schon. Und dann hat er und das wurde ihm ja hier so vom vom Autor dann unterstellt. Er schwamm immer gegen den Strom, aber wendete das Blatt dann immer. Also er hat ganz Stanford und seinen Schulen unterstellt, dass sie ihm eigentlich nur böses wollen. Gleichzeitig sagen aber seine Freunde über ihn Jahrzehnte später. Also von dem hatten wir immer Angst. Der wollte uns eigentlich immer irgendwas böses. Er hat es immer so verdreht. Oder eben dieser Review. Sehr erstaunlich. 1988 die Kondominitiative in San Francisco, weil vier Prozent der Stadtbevölkerung damals mit AIDS infiziert waren. 50 Prozent der schwulen Männer. Also eine richtige Epidemie, ohne dass da eine Maske hilft oder eine Impfung oder sonst irgendwas. Man musste also wirklich politisch was tun mit den sogenannten nicht pharmazeutischen Interventionen. Und dann sitzt dieser Review da, diese quasi Schülertsständenzeitung und agitiert dagegen an wie sonst nichts, während gleichzeitig die Vermutung läuft, ja in der Redaktion sind alle schwul. Ja, also wieder diese komplette Verdrehung von innen und außen.
Also es ist wirklich, das ist zum Teil aus radikal katholischen Kreisen kennen. Also da gibt es ja auch diese Phänomene dann, dass dann irgendwann später auf, ja gut, die haben doch immer Orgien gehabt, aber die haben dann jederzeit publiziert, dass die Homosexuellen unser Verderben sind.
Genau, aber wir sehen hier in der Soziologie gibt es so eine Idee von, wie soll man sagen, Invertierung. Also eine der ganz berühmten Ideen ist, wenn man eine Demokratie, wenn man eine Gesellschaft wie eine Demokratie führen will, dann muss man die Parteien aufstellen wie Armeen. Also dann braucht man genau in den Parteien, die für die Demokratie antreten, eine Hierarchie, einen klaren Chef, eine klare Struktur, Aufgabenverteilung. Also die SPD kämpft gegen die Nazis sozusagen. Nur so funktioniert es. Und so sehen wir das bei ihm hier auch wieder. Das ist die totale Invertierung. Wir sehen so eine Gesellschaft, wie sie ist und dann dieses gegen den Strom schwimmen. Also wir sonnen uns von ihr ab, indem wir das, was wir ablehnen, eigentlich komplett übertreiben, in der Hoffnung, dass es am Ende schon gut ausgeht. Ja, also dieses Bild steckt da immer wieder drin. Insbesondere, wenn Peter Thiel ganz auf sich selbst zurückgeworfen wird. Also seine Klassenkameraden verachten ihn, machen sich lustig über ihn, was auch auf seine Familie abstrahlt. Also auch sein Elternhaus und so bleibt da nicht ungeschont. Gleichzeitig weiß er aber, die werden mir ihr Geld schon geben, wenn ich ihnen ihre Prüfungsleistung erbringe. Und genau so ein Business, das ist ein erstes Business, macht er dann auch. Er entwickelt dann diese Art der Bezahlung, die das nicht zurückführbar macht auf ihn, sodass er da fein raus ist. Und er macht sich sozusagen vom Opfer zum Täter. Und damit gleichzeitig auch die Täter zu Opfern. Klar, sie können jetzt gut durch diese Studienzeit kommen mit meinen Leistungen, die ich für sie erbringe, aber im Leben danach werden sie scheitern. Also das ist da immer schon so drin. Und relativ zügig kommt ja dann das Buch auch auf die Interessanten zu sprechen wie PayPal, diese ganze Gründungsgeschichte. Ich hatte ja nicht wirklich viel Ahnung. Wir lesen hier häufiger Bücher, aber man liest häufiger Texte, wo man noch mal die Facebook-Geschichte. Irgendwann denkt man so, ja gut, aus der Richtung, diese Perspektive, da hat man noch mal diese kleine Nuance. Das war vorher nicht klar. Okay, speichert man vielleicht ab, wenn es einen interessiert. Aus dieser Gründungszeit von PayPal wusste ich fast nichts. Dass uns hier eine PayPal-Mafia vorgestellt wird, finde ich.
Durchgehend so genannt wird in dem gesamten Buch. Lass mich noch einen Schritt noch mal ganz kurz zurück machen zu Stanford zurück. Denn Peter Thiel ist natürlich nicht ein Solitär, insofern als er vollkommen selbst diese Gedanken entwickelt, sondern er liest relativ viel und er liest diese typischen libertären Autoren, allen voran natürlich ein Rent. Er wird später auf René Girard stoßen, was ihn sehr, sehr interessieren wird. Also diese Idee der Sündenbock Theorie, dass eine Gesellschaft sich immer wieder einen Sündenbock aussucht. Das könnte man ja auch jetzt als ganz humanistische Theorie lesen und rezipieren und könnte sagen Ja, wie schlimm wir müssen irgendwie was tun, dass diese Sündenböcke nicht, dass eine Gesellschaft nicht diese Sündenböcke kreiert. Für Thiel folgt daraus, aber sich selbst erst mal als der Sündenbock zu identifizieren, als Opfer zu identifizieren. Etwas, was wir im rechten Diskurs ja sehr häufig finden. Das sind immer Opfer, die dann sagen, seht doch her, wir dürfen nirgends mehr vertreten sein. Wir werden nicht in Fernsehtalkshows eingeladen, etc. Und dann dreht man das aber um und will selbst zum Täter werden und produziert wirkliche Sündenböcke dann in einer Weise, dass man kopfschüttelnd dasitzt. Also die muslimen sind eine große Gefahr. Thiel ist eigentlich in seiner Forderung, wie Migration geregelt werden soll, noch radikaler als ein Donald Trump. Also Thiel würde eigentlich die Mauer noch nicht mal reichen. Und das aber alles entsteht natürlich auch auf einem geistigen Nährboden, der da in Stanford populär ist. Da wird ja zitiert der Präsident von Stanford, David Starr Jordan, der sagt ganz klar, wir sind hier in Stanford die Aristokratie der Intelligenz. Und er fordert dann auch die Abschlussjahrgänge auf, sich zu verstehen als Wächter der Staatskasse. Ja, also als Hüter der Rechte des kalifornischen Steuerzahlers. Also die Idee, die hier von Anfang an da ist, ist der Staat ist der Feind. Und wir sind jetzt dazu ausgebildet, gegen diesen Feind zu kämpfen. Und das kann man mitunter auch tun, indem man mit der Politik paktiert. Insofern sie eine rechte Politik ist. Das ist also der Nährboden, auf dem das alles entsteht. Diese extreme Staatsfeindlichkeit, die in Stanford selbstverständlich dazu gehört zum Geist des Silicon Valley.
Genau. Also gerade weil wir heute am 6. Januar sind, das wird ja hier im Buch genannt als die Verselbstständigung des Thielismus. Und es gibt eine sehr gute Art der Reportage, die ich jetzt auch im Fernsehpodcast mal schauen werde, wo so dargestellt wird, wie sich die ganzen Milizen und Gruppen, die sich immer gebildet haben, um für die Verfassung, wie man sie halt dann da deutet, gegen die Regierung zu kämpfen. Und plötzlich hatte man in der Regierung selbst seine Führung. Da sah man sie plötzlich. Und dann gibt es diese Art der Verselbstständigung, dass Trump nur noch sagen muss, ja, diese Gretchen Widmore, die nervt einen ja wirklich. Und zack, am 30. April wird das Kapitol da von Gouverneurin Widmer einfach gestürmt. So wie wir es dann dreiviertel Jahre später in Washington gesehen haben. Und dann macht es erst, ah ja, stimmt, es gab ja am 30. April schon mal so einen Sturm auf so ein Kapitol in Amerika. Und dieser René Girard, den du schon genannt hast, der ist ja ganz wichtig, weil Thiel den nicht nur als Autor begegnet, sondern als Lehrer selbst. Also er ist bei ihm in den Veranstaltungen, macht später mit ihm Seminare und lernt das mimetische Begehren kennen. Wir wollen immer nur was andere schon haben und nur sozusagen im Wettkampf entstehen unsere Bedürfnisse gar nicht, weil wir echte Bedürfnisse haben. Und da zieht er ja vieles draus. Und es ist ganz interessant, wie man auf der einen Seite sagen kann, ich verabscheue Neid, denn das heißt ja nur, es ist ja nicht mein Bedürfnis, sondern ein anderer zwingt mir durch sein Verhalten, also weckt bei mir Begehren, das ich eigentlich gar nicht habe. Ich brauche eigenes Begehren und dann das hohe Lied auf die Gier. Kein Neid, aber Gier, also Gier darf die Welt antreiben. Während wir dann in der Auseinandersetzung mit Elon Musk, als ihr Businesspartner sind, schon sieht, ne, also das ist Neid, was da stattfindet. Wenn Peter Thiel nur vier Prozent des Unternehmens besitzt und Elon Musk aber 13, und deswegen werden da die ganzen Intrigen gesponnen, dann ist das nicht Gier, sondern das ist diese Neid, dieser Neid, gegen den er sich da eigentlich vorher fast mit so einem religiösen Eifer in sein Weltbild eingebaut hat. Diese Zeit da mit PayPal ist ja auch für ihn ganz interessant. Also er gründet, wie hießen sie alle? Die Konfinity ist einer dieser Vorläufer, von Seiten Elon Musk kommt X als Zahlungsdienstleister mit rein. Zusammen dann PayPal X, PayPal, PayPal X, wie auch immer. Sie sehen sich ja nie einig, wie sie es nennen wollen, weil sie beide den Anspruch haben, da eigentlich die Treiber zu sein. Und hier, um schon mal Schömerer zu nennen, kam ja auch wieder dieser Gedanke, den Schömerer damals im Schweizer Fernsehen geäußert hat. Ideen kommen immer über zwei Arten auf die Welt, entweder in einem Buch oder in einer Technologie. Und Peter Thiel hat es in seiner Uni-Zeit mit Büchern versucht. Er hat geschrieben wie ein Blöder, hat gelesen wie ein Blöder, wollte darüber Ideen aussondern.
Er wollte Bestseller schreiben, ist ihm erst sehr viel später dann mit Zero to One gelungen. Aber er hat schon relativ viel publiziert und nicht ganz unerfolgreich. Also er hat ein Buch gegen Political Correctness. Wenn ich das jetzt so sage, dann klingt das so, als ginge es jetzt nur darum, dass einem manche Richtlinien zu weit gehen oder man die Irrsinn nicht findet. Also das ist jetzt nicht damit gemeint. Ich schüttel ja bei manchen Geschichten auch den Kopf, wenn man da so manche woken bei Twitter erlebt, die sich dann da zappeln wegen Unsinnigkeiten. Also hier geht es jetzt wirklich um eine Free Speech, die auch noch Holocaust-Leugnung mit einbezieht und sagt, können wir auch noch alles machen. Also das ist ein Radikalprogramm, auf dessen Grundlage eigentlich ein demokratisches Verständnis nicht mehr realisierbar ist. Und das soll auch gar nicht realisierbar sein. Thiel deutet an einer Stelle mal an, vielleicht könnte eigentlich das US-Militär uns viel besser führen als eine US-Regierung. Also das muss man sich wirklich ganz klar machen. Also es geht hier nicht darum zu sagen, wer kann dann jetzt mal noch mitreden und sollte man noch eine zweite Meinung einholen, sondern es geht hier um eine radikale Disruption oder Destruktion des Diskurses. Und das ist in einer Weise radikalisiert, dass es einen erschreckt. Und wäre er nur Sachbuchautor geworden, dann wäre er jetzt wahrscheinlich wie Tucker Carlson oder so einer dieser, mit dem er ja auch zu tun hat. Also die gehen ja alle ein und aus, das ist alles gar kein Problem. Dann wäre er einer von diesen. Aber er hat, und damit müssen wir jetzt wirklich zu Paper kommen, er hat eine eine viel mächtigere Instanz geschaffen, um diese Ideologie des Free Speech eigentlich auf die Finanzialisierung zu übertragen.
Genau. Wir wussten wenig über die Gründungszeit von PayPal und heute sehr viele Legenden über Bitcoin. Aber der Autor sagt ja ganz klar, das doppelt sich. Also alle diese libertären Ideen, die heute im Bitcoin drin stecken, stecken da in PayPal drin. Man nimmt sich eine Technologie, die vorhanden ist, dieser Palm Computer der Kleine. Wir sind ja 10, 20 Jahre vor dem iPhone und so weiter. Und sagen, darüber wickeln wir jetzt Zahnung ab, die nicht zurückführbar ist. Das ist die eigentliche Idee. Und wir wollen ganz viele Kunden, ein eigenes Netzwerk, das den Dollar Konkurrenz macht. Und dann ist es ja wirklich atemberaubend zu lesen. Und da würde ich auch sagen, warten wir wirklich mal auf den Film. Warum gibt es den eigentlich noch nicht, wie das damals war mit der PayPal-Mafia. Also man hat PayPal, sucht Kunden, schenkt den Kunden einfach das Geld. Hauptsache, sie sind da. Man weiß gar nicht, ach so, zurückgezogene Zahlungen, die dann trotzdem von Seiten der Bank abgeleitet werden müssen, können auch in drei Monaten kommen. Egal, erst mal Kunden, Kunden, Kunden. Wir kümmern uns hier um gar kein Reglement. Also während auf der anderen Seite Amerikas, man in der Wall Street schon da ist und so überlegt, was könnte man jetzt machen mit dem Internet und so weiter, traut sich da keiner, weil alle das Reglement kennen, das sind ja alles Banker, drüben im Silicon Valley die Technik-Fuzees, interessieren sich null für die Gesetze und gehen dann einfach die Wette ein. Ja, also am Ende, wenn wir groß genug sind und alle bei uns Kunden sind, dann reguliert sich das auch wieder, dass wir nicht nur Betrüger haben und nicht nur illegales Wett-Spiel, sondern dann regieren wir die ganze Welt, dann werden ja alle Zahlungsdinger über uns abgleitet. Bis dahin ist es aber ein Anstrengter.
Und wir können dann schon nicht mehr reguliert werden. Das ist ja das, was er dann allen rät, die irgendeine Unternehmensidee haben. Move fast, die Regulierungen kommen immer viel zu spät. Und je schneller du dich bewegst, einfach recht schaffst. Wir haben das bei vielen Silicon Valley Konzernen gesehen. Einfach recht schaffst. Dann wird das ganz schwer sein, das noch mal zurückzudrehen. Das können wir bei dem Krypto-Hype jetzt in ganz ähnlicher Weise erleben.
Genau, der Chafkin nennt das, die bei Papel hatten damals die Idee des Blitz Scaling, also des superschnellen Wachstums. Und er sieht da drin die Verwirklichung von Thiels Aktivismus, den er vorher mit Review über die publizistische Schiene gemacht hat, jetzt eben mit Technik. Also es ist ganz erstaunlich, wie wir hier so eine Zweigleisigkeit bei Thiel haben, ganz eng an dieser Idee, ich will die Welt übernehmen, publizistisch, das dauert mir zu lange und so weiter. Und dann macht das einfach über die Technik. Desruption zum Selbstzweck. Dann allerdings mit den Verwerfungen, das fand ich auch interessant, die teilen sich ein Bürogebäude, also Konfinity und X, Elon Musk, haben aber nichts miteinander zu tun. Dann stehen sie unten vor der Tür und rauchen, weil sie sich ein Mülleimer teilen und dort gerade der Businessplan des jeweils anderen Unternehmens drin liegt und das dann gelesen wird. Denken sie, mit denen könnten wir eigentlich zusammenarbeiten. Und dazu kam es dann, also X und PayPal schließen sich zusammen. Thiel besitzt nur 3% von allem Musk, weil er eben als Techie und so weiter einfach mehr Skin in the Game hatte. 14% Thiel ist wahnsinnig neidisch und er kommt dann nie wieder raus aus diesem Ding. Selbst als sie dann viel später 2002 an die Börse gehen, ist das schon Drama. Dann wollen sie sich an eBay verkaufen. Das geht aber auch nicht ohne Drama ab. Das muss immer erst Weltkrieg und Mega-Drama sein, bevor es dann dazu kommt. Und dann werden sie von eBay gekauft. Alle sind plötzlich steinreich. Also 1,4 Milliarden. Damals war der Deal. 2002. Also als man noch längst nicht von Milliarden gesprochen hat. Thiel, am selben Tag verabschiedet er sich, wettet gegen eBay, kämpft wieder gegen alles, was er davor aufgebaut hat, weil es jetzt nicht mehr seins ist und so weiter. Und das ist wirklich auch brutal, das so zu lesen. Das Gleiche ist, was dann der Autor aufmacht, ist ja, George Storrs hat damals mit dem Pfund gegen die britische Regierung gewettet und gewonnen und Peter Thiel hat sich ja auch mit der ganzen Welt angelegt.
Ja, und immer ist er der Revolutionär. Es heißt dann hier, Thiel hielt mit seinen revolutionären Ambitionen nicht hinter dem Berg. Er kommunizierte sie ganz offen an Mitarbeitende und Investoren, die drei Millionen US-Dollar in das Unternehmen steckten, die sie Thiel auf einer Pressekonferenz im Juli 1999 mithilfe des Palm Palette überwiesen. Papiergeld ist eine vorsintflutliche Technologie, erklärte Thiel im selben Jahr auf einer Sitzung. Er sprach von PayPal als dem potenziellen Microsoft des Zahlungsverkehrs. Doch das war erst der Anfang, denn Papiergeld war auch ein Mittel zur Ausübung staatlicher Kontrolle. Was wir als praktisch für den amerikanischen Verbraucher bezeichnen, wird für die Schwellenländer natürlich revolutionär sein, setzte Thiel hinzu. Regierungen setzen Inflation und machen auch groß angelegte Währungsabwertungen, um ihren Bürgern Vermögen zu entziehen. Das wäre mit PayPal unmöglich. Also dieses Gespenst der Inflation, das wir ja in der Krypto-Place auch laufend sehen, das ist also etwas, was hier Thiel auch schon ganz deutlich bedient. Er sagt bei den Entwicklungsländern, aber es geht auch generell darum, der Staat ist ein Räuberstaat, der will alle Sparer, der will überhaupt alle Bürger enteignen und davor muss man sich in irgendeiner Weise schützen. Lasst uns gemeinsam eine Struktur aufbauen, die dem staatlichen Zugriff entzogen ist.
Genau so. Und damit kommt Peter Thiel zu Geld, indem er das Geld revolutioniert und ist plötzlich Millionär. Er kann also auch seine große Idee endlich mal angehen, so ein Fonds zu gründen und als Investor tätig zu werden. Und das zweite Mal in seinem Leben begegnet ihm Atombombe. Denn er ist ja damals schon nach Südafrika gegangen, weil sein Vater in so einer Uranmine da irgendwie mitgearbeitet hat. Da ging es natürlich auch um Atombombenmaterial. Dann als Investor, als er 2002 plötzlich Geld hat und seinen Confinity Investment Fonds da irgendwie aufzieht, kommt ihm die Idee des Frackings unter. Also Erdgas im Erdreich und wie lockert man Erdboden auf, wenn man mal ganz viel Erdboden auflockern will. Man zündet Atombomben. Also das war einfach so eine Idee, die man da so durchgepeitscht hat. Das kam dann natürlich nicht dazu und so. Aber das ist einfach immer eine Nummer zu groß. Bei jedem biografischen Schritt, den er tut, da sieht man es immer eine Nummer zu groß. Und 2002 sind wir natürlich ein Jahr nach 2001, dem 11. September. Und 2004 nimmt er sich René Girard veranstaltet eine Konferenz mit der Frage, wie können wir eigentlich Terrorismus bekämpfen? Und dann die erste Antwort, technische Überwachung.
Ja, denn die US-Regierung, also die Bush-Regierung, die wir ja als Hardliner-Regierung jetzt sofort uns wieder in Erinnerung rufen, die ist ihm viel zu lasch.
Genau, die kommt nicht vorwärts. Die große Kritik, die kennen wir alle noch. Damals haben ganz viele unterschiedliche Geheimdienste irgendwas gemacht und keiner hat mal die Fäden zusammengeführt. Da hat er sich gesagt, die kann man doch zusammenführen, die Fäden. Das sind da alles Daten, die vorliegen, die muss man doch immer ordentlich verrechnen. Und dann erinnert er sich, wir haben doch damals, 1998, 99, Igor gegründet. Als man nämlich bei PayPal festgestellt hat, da findet doch ganz schön viel Betrug statt auf unserer Plattform, ist man dem mal nachgegangen und hat festgestellt, ein einziger Typ, Igor hat man ihn genannt, in Russland, hat so viele Paypal-Konten aufgemacht und miteinander verschachtelt, damit man sich immer, komm, hol doch auch deine Freundin hierher, dann schreiben wir dir 10 Dollar gut, dass er mehrere zig Millionen Dollar, 25 Millionen Dollar oder so aus PayPal abgezogen hat. Und die Software, die man damals geschrieben hatte, um Igor zu finden, hat man sich gedacht, aus der können wir doch jetzt einfach mal Terrorismus-Such-Algos schreiben. Also hat man das gedacht und das Software-Projekt hatte dann den Namen Palantier. Der Name von den Palantiri aus Tolkins, Mittel Erde, diese Steine. Genau, diese komischen Steine, von denen man, also ich kenne das ja alles nicht, ich habe es jetzt nur hier so gelesen, die auch so ein bisschen zwielichtig sein sollen.
Herr der Ringe ist ganz wichtig für ihn, ja ja. Und Herr der Ringe ist eine ganz wichtige Referenz, wenngleich er eher Sauron gut findet. Also den Super-Bösewicht.
Genau. So und damit ist Palantier im Grunde aus der, also geschöpft einfach so als Idee. Es ist am Anfang so eine Software-Idee. Weil im amerikanischen Militär die Suche nach genau so einer Art von Software groß ist, entsteht das natürlich auch ziemlich schnell als handfeste Unternehmung. Die erste Software, die man dann aus dem Palantier-Projekt rausentwickelt und für so marktreif hält, dass man die den Militärs anbietet, heißt Inception. Also wir sind hier wirklich ganz tief drin.
Nach dem Nolan-Film auch benannt, natürlich, ja.
Ja, also es muss alles zusammenfassen und dieses Marketing war wieder mafiamäßig organisiert. Man ist nämlich einfach direkt ins Militär. Man hat sich die mittlere Führungsebene dort angeschaut, hat die einzelnen Soldaten angequatscht und gesagt, hier, kauft doch mal. Und einer der großen Führsprecher, der damals sagte, auch gerade frisch befördert von Obama und so, ja, das sieht alles ziemlich gut aus, war Michael Flynn. Michael Flynn war daran gelegen, dass das Pentagon so viele Palantier-Lizenzen wie nur irgendwie geht, kauft, damit Palantier steinreich macht und gleichzeitig dieses Unternehmen ganz eng an den Staat, insbesondere ans Militär anbindet.
Wir sehen hier wieder einen schönen Widerspruch. Also der Staatsfeind Thiel ist darauf angewiesen, dass er möglichst viele Staatsaufträge bekommt, sonst hätte Palantier nie funktioniert. Man hat es dann erst sehr viel später geschafft, auch an Private zu verkaufen, an Unternehmen zu verkaufen, die damit was anfangen konnten. Aber nach wie vor stützt sich der Erfolg von Palantier nur darauf, dass man Staaten hat, die hinter einem stehen. Und das ist ja nicht nur dann das US-Militär und US-Geheimdienste, die darauf zurückgreifen. Und die Erfolge sind in den ersten Jahren ja einfach gar nicht vorhanden. Also das ist interessant, da wird doch einfach gefaked. Und irgendwie hätte auch Thiel noch gerne dieses Narrativ gehabt. Wir haben mit Palantier Osama bin Laden geschnappt. Aber nichts deutet eigentlich darauf hin, dass das da überhaupt vorgekommen ist. Man kann sagen, ja, irgendwo war auch mal Palantier vielleicht da drin. Aber es gibt keinen direkten Zusammenhang. Also man hätte aber gerne dieses Narrativ. Und man versucht damit selbstverständlich dann auch im Ausland erfolgreich zu sein. Und es ist ja, glaube ich, nach wie vor so. Du musstest als Hesse wissen, dass Hessen auch investiert hat und Aufträge an Palantier vergeben hat.
Die hessische Polizei hat hier Palantier-Software im Einsatz. Das geht auch schon so in Richtung Pre-Chime und so weiter. Das ist, erfährt man natürlich immer nie, was und so. Das sind ja alles irgendwelche Staatssachen. Wenn sie sichern sie und die Stelle, die ihnen dann auch keine Antwort gibt. Also es ist, ja, die Software ist einfach in der Welt. Wird allerdings nicht wie typische Silicon-Valley-Software, Consumer Electronics mäßig. Also fällt uns nicht auf, dagegen wir keine Twitter-Anzeigen oder so. Aber das Zeug ist in der Welt. Und du hast schon gesagt, das funktioniert alles gar nicht. Sollte aber trotzdem funktionieren. Und die Entwicklungsidee kann man, glaube ich, sehr gut abschätzen, wenn man dieses Thiel-Zitat hier kennt. Ich bin lieber böse als inkompetent. Und dann weiß man schon, ja, also damit es am Ende funktioniert, biegen wir lieber zweimal falsch ab, bevor wir noch gelten, es funktioniert gar nicht. Diese Idee, dass Osama bin Laden auch mit Palantier geschnappt wurde, das ist auch amüsant zu lesen, wie sie das auswälzen, wie sie dann das nie explizit sagen, aber immer darauf hinweisen, also sie können ja mal Google Palantier und Osama bin Laden. Lesen sie im Internet nach, was irgendwelche Verschwörungs-Hainis schreiben. Und dann, das ist so dieses Eric Schmidt-Ding, also wir können Börsenkurse voraussagen, wir machen es nur nicht.
Er hat ja schon ganz gute Karten unter der Busche-Administration, denn da sind quasi Lektüre-Partner, also Leute, die auch das gelesen haben, was Thiel gelesen hat, ein Rant sowieso. Aber Leo Strauss hat er sehr stark rezipiert, wie auch die Busche-Administration unter Wolfowitz und Co. Karl Schmidt wurde rezipiert. Also wir können das wirklich immer sehr gut sehen, wie also die Idee, also das, was Schirmacher da skizziert hat, Idee aus Büchern oder Technologie, wie das immer wieder so zusammengeht und dass man sagt, ach ja, hier, wir haben doch eigentlich dasselbe Weltbild, eine Freund und Feind-Unterscheidung, auch eine moralische Unterscheidung, die ja Strauss dann auch deutlich macht mit Gut und Böse. Das ist etwas, was bei der Busche-Administration großen Anklang findet, weshalb es dann Thiel auch nicht schwer hat, da immer mehr reinzustoßen. Und es ist ja so erstaunlich eigentlich, dass Thiel aufgrund dieser Verbortheit, du hast ja Elon Musk schon angesprochen, aufgrund dieser ideologischen Verbortheit dann auch Investitionschancen nicht nutzt. Und zwar sagt ja Elon Musk hier, ich habe da so eine Idee mit E-Mobilität Tesla. Das war dann in den Nullerjahren. Und dann ist Thiel erst mal kurz am Stutzen und sagt dann aber, naja, also, ehrlich gesagt, so richtig glaube ich ja nicht an den menschengemachten Klimawandel. Also das wird alles so hochgehangen. Das ist das ist eigentlich gar nicht so. Und deswegen investiert er nicht. Also weil er nicht an den Klimawandel glaubt.
Genau. Er investiert in soziale Netzwerke, sucht sich Facebook so früh raus, dass er mit 500.000 Dollar da schon einen echten Anteil erwirbt, bereut aber später viel zurückhaltend gewesen zu sein. Dann zweite Phase der Reue, er marginalisiert Facebook. Das ist ja gar keine große Innovation. Das ist einfach nur krass gewachsen. Und am Ende gab es dann doch wieder große Seelenverwandtschaft mit Mark Zuckerberg. Also immer diese Hin- und Herverdrehung. Du hast ja eben noch mal dieses, das schreibt der Chafkin auch ganz explizit, mit den Büchern im Eigenverlag und diesen Konferenzen, die Thiel gemacht hat, hat er sich Renommee erkauft. Aber mit Palantier ist er wirklich mächtig geworden. Also politisch mächtig, das, was er immer wollte. Weshalb er auch dann bei Trump gleich mit quasi mit am Kabinettstisch saß. Er hat ja 150 Namen genannt. Die müssen alle in die Regierung. Und wurde gleich ins Transition Team aufgenommen.
Diese ist absurd, also man muss sich das jetzt, wenn man es noch nicht gelesen hat, folgendermaßen vorstellen. Trump wird Präsident. Und hat dann natürlich Leute, die ihn beraten, wen soll er für welche Position besetzen. Thiel darf dann in den Trump Tower ziehen. Mit seinen jungen Mitarbeitern und dann also alles Männer. Also grundsätzlich Frauen spielen in dieser gesamten Team Welt eigentlich fast gar keine Rolle. Es gibt so eine, die immer so als rettende Anker da ist, die ihn dann mal irgendwie da aus der Padoje nimmt. Dann, wenn er mal eine Frau braucht, dann wird die hergezogen und dann wird die auch der Öffentlichkeit präsentiert oder so. Aber in der Regel Frauen spielen keine Rolle. Er zieht also mit diesen jungen Männer dann in diesen Trump Tower. Alle sehen aus wie Models, sagt dann einer. Und die erstellen dann Listen, welche Leute Trump auf irgendwelche Positionen setzen soll. Und die Liste, die die da aufstellen, ist erschreckend. Also es sind nur radikal Libertäre, die dort Platz finden und ganz viele Geschäftspartner natürlich von Thiel. Also das wirtschaftliche Interesse ist natürlich extrem hoch. Aber es ist erschreckend zu sehen, wie da eigentlich Politik gemacht wird und wie diese Politik sich anti-elitär gibt. Und das ist in gewisser Weise auch, weil sie natürlich gegen Hillary Clinton Elite schießt. Der habe ich ja natürlich auch keine Sympathie, aber das ist ganz interessant. Also diese Elite, die wird beschossen die ganze Zeit mit den schlimmsten Manövern, die man sich vorstellen kann. Und zugleich baut man sich einfach eine neue Elite auf, die aber noch viel schlimmer als die alte ist.
Ja, also Trump zieht ins Weise aus. Rechts von ihm läuft Steve Bannon, links von ihm läuft Peter Thiel. Der eine will alles abschaffen und zerstören und der andere sagt, naja, bis es soweit ist, übernehmen wir das mal noch und installieren hier unseren Deep State. Also wirklich ganz gruselig zu lesen. Bevor Trump, also als er da mit Palantier seine ersten politischen Erfolge hat, kommt ja Venture Capital 2.0 in Anschlag mit Clarium Capital. Sebastian Kurz wird ja jetzt auch für eine dieser Geldfirmen von ihm arbeiten. Und warum er sich dafür einen Politiker sucht, wird hier, glaube ich, klar, wenn man dieses eine Zitat, was auch der Autor da breitwalzt, das muss man unbedingt vorlesen, glaube ich. Also Thiel ist da so unterwegs und macht das ein oder andere. Tesla will er nicht unterstützen, dann kommt Musk später wieder und sagt, wie wäre es mit Raketen? Thiel so, na, dafür habe ich 20 Millionen übrig. Und wir nähern uns so langsam 2007, 2008, also eine Wirtschaftskrise. Retrospectiv wissen wir, das sind die Jahre der Wirtschaftskrise. Vorher konnte man das natürlich nicht so richtig wissen. Peter Thiel hat da wieder Andeutung gemacht. Und er schreibt selber ein Investorenbrief, also ein Brief an die Investoren, die sozusagen sein Unternehmen tragen. Sonst macht das immer der Finanzchef des Unternehmens. Diesmal schreibt Thiel selbst, dieses Ding ist 10.000 Worte lang, unter anderem schreibt er, die komplette menschliche Ordnung könnte sich in einer unaufhörlichen Eskalation der Gewalt auflösen. Hunger, Krankheit, Krieg und Tod. Angesichts dieser Zukunft ist es weit besser, seine unsterbliche Seele zu retten und Schätze im Himmel anzuhäufen, in der ewigen Stadt Gottes, als in der vergänglichen, irrdischen Stadt der Menschen vergängliches Vermögen anzuhäufen. Das ist der Brief an die Investoren. Also da hält er nicht mal hinter den Berg. Da ist einfach...
Und hier kommt alles jetzt zusammen. Also hier kommt der Technologiewahn, vermischt sich mit dem religiösen Fundamentalismus. Seine Familie war streng religiös. Es gibt diese Idee, dass wenige nur gerettet werden. Also das ist auch sowas Sektenartiges natürlich. Mit die können dann irgendwie ins ewige Leben kommen. Etwas, was ja in gewisser Weise Don't Look Up auch wieder aufgreift dann am Ende. Also es ist ganz erstaunlich, dass es geht. Also dass man das sagen kann, also dass man das schreiben kann als Investor, ohne dass es einen größeren Diskurs darüber gibt. Denn wir haben ja, das ist ja das Erstaunliche, tatsächlich eine sehr sprachsensible und überhaupt sensible Gesellschaft, ohne jetzt so ganz auf diese Flasspölerthese zu gehen. Haben wir doch eine, die bei gewissen Äußerungen aufschreckt und sagt, Moment mal, ist das so gemeint? Es kann doch eigentlich nicht sein. Oder ich muss da nochmal nachfragen. Aber hier rutschen solche Dinge durch, beziehungsweise etablieren sich dann und werden als in Ordnung angesehen. Und das können wir auch daran sehen, dass er ja weiterhin publizistisch auch über diesen Brief hinaustätig ist. Da gibt es dann so einen Magazin von diesem Carto-Institut. Also er ist auch mit Klimawandel, Leugner, Lobby, mit allem hat er zu tun. Und da schreibt dann Thiel ein Essay, der hat den Titel Die Ausbildung eines Libertären. Und da sagt er, ich halte Freiheit und Demokratie nicht mehr für vereinbar. Und dann behauptet er, dass in den Vereinigten Staaten im vergangenen Jahrhundert es eigentlich nur bergab ging. Also das 20. Jahrhundert ist eigentlich ein Niedergangsgeschichte. Bisschen in den 20er Jahren war es noch in Ordnung, aber dann ging es wirklich nur noch schlimm zu. Und da schreibt er, die 1920er waren die letzte Dekade in der amerikanischen Geschichte, in der man politisch noch ehrlich optimistisch sein konnte. Seit 1920 haben die enorm gestiegene Zahl von Sozialhilfeempfängern und die Ausweitung des Wahlrechts auf Frauen, zwei Wählergruppen, die für Libertäre notorisch schwer erreichbar sind, die Vorstellung von einer kapitalistischen Demokratie zum Oxymoron werden lassen. Also das muss man sich vorstellen. Das ist also ein Text aus den Nuller Jahren, wo Thiel schreibt, ja, doof, dass wir dieses Frauenwahlrecht haben.
Ja, na ja, ich meine, das gipfelt dann eben. Zuerst ist er publizistisch tätig, heute kennen wir diese Review-Texte gar nicht mehr, weil auch die Stanford-Uni diese ja unter Verschluss hält. Selbst wenn man ins Archiv darf, darf man da nicht fotografieren und stellt fest, hm, hier fehlt aber auch einiges. Also da wurde wahrscheinlich ein bisschen aufgeräumt. Diese späteren Texte wie auch dieses große Zitat aus diesem Brief eben, das ist eben aus dieser Position der Macht herausgeschrieben. Also da ist er der Milliardär, zu dem man sein Geld bringt und der ist natürlich dann in der Lage, sowas zu schreiben. Da steht dann nicht ein Speakers Corner und so und links rein, rechts raus, sondern das sind dann halt die Texte, die so ein bisschen funktionieren. Und tatsächlich, es kommt ja dann zur Finanzkrise, die Thiel aber wieder nicht nutzen kann. Also er zieht daraus wieder keinen Gewinn, während irgendwelche Wall Street Typen, weil sie es ahnen, was passiert und sich vorbereiten, 5 Milliarden Dollar am Tag als persönlichen Gewinn einstreichen. Also das ist ja wirklich erstaunlich, woran man hier noch mal so erinnert wird, was damals passierte. Thiel ist, hat Geld, bleibt bei Geld, investiert es wild. Zum Beispiel kriegt die Singularity Institute eine Million Dollar ab. Da weiß man auch schon wieder. Wo ist denn das? Sie arbeiten alle an dieser Idee der Online Städte, also dass man irgendwo draußen auf dem Meer Gebiete hat im unpolitischen Bereich.
Und Patrick Friedman, das ist ein Enkel von Milton Friedman. Der taucht jetzt auch wieder auf, wenn es um diese freien Städte geht, diese neuen Libertären-Projekte jetzt in Honduras und sonst wo. Und Patrick Friedman ist jemand, der sagt, es wäre doch eigentlich schön, wenn wir Inseln im Meer hätten, die von jeglichem staatlichen Zugriff abgeschnitten sind. Und dort könnte man dann sehr frei leben, beziehungsweise könnte sich auch immer wieder an Staaten andocken, wo es einem gerade gefällt. Dann schwimmt man mit diesem riesigen Kreuzfahrtschiff quasi mal an die, mal an jene Küste. Und das ist etwas, was Thiel von Anfang an begeistert und wo er bereit ist, zu investieren. Und das ist eigentlich auch sein Menschheitstraum. Beziehungsweise es ist auch hier wieder verrückt. Also zum einen möchte er eine radikale, migrationsfeindliche Politik durchsetzen. Am besten gar keine Muslime mehr ins Land lassen. Grundsätzlich auch die Einwanderer, die illegal in den USA sind, möglichst wieder zurückschicken und, und, und. Also eine Abschottungspolitik. Man könnte fast denken, ja, aber das ist ja ein Zurück zu einer Nationalstaatlichkeit. Vielleicht 19. Jahrhundert oder so. Aber zugleich und das ist wahrscheinlich dann auch diese Sache, die mehr Strategie ist als Ideologie, ist er ja persönlich jemand, der mehrere Staatsbürgerschaften hat, bemüht sich dann um die Staatsbürgerschaften. Neuseeland bekommt die auch dann durch entsprechendes Geld. Lobbyarbeit. Genau und versucht dann ja eigentlich eine Existenz zu führen, die genau das nicht ist. Also ein staatliches verwurzelt sein oder so. Also wenn er irgendetwas ist, dann nicht verwurzelt in dem Sinne, was er dann so weit getrieben wird, dass er dann heiratet. Sehr spät heiratet er da seinen Lebensgefährten. Über Leihmutterschaft wird dann noch ein Kind ausgetragen. Also das sind ja alles keine konservativen Konzepte eigentlich. Aber das kann sich sehr gut mit diesem Rechtslibertären-Denken vermischen, weil man einfach davon ausgeht, naja, eine Elite darf es geben und die kann auch alles machen. Die kann transgressiv unterwegs sein. Die kann alles leben, ausleben, wie sie möchte und wo sie möchte. Und kann auch noch per Leihmutter sich ein paar Kinder austragen lassen. Sofern es einen Reichtum im Hintergrund gibt, der quasi der Beweis dafür ist, dass man zu dieser Elite gehört. Und dann ist man eine andere Sorte Mensch, muss man fast sagen, wie das dann hier etabliert wird. Und die dürfen auch oder sollten ewig leben.
Genau, da kommen wir gleich noch mal drauf. Auch wie die Altersversicherung Vorsorge für den Superreichen aussieht. Der Text lässt ja immer wieder auch explizit offen. Haben wir es hier mit Libertären oder eigentlich mit autokratischen Denken zu tun? Also es ist nicht immer nur, weil wir so von Anfang an, ja gut, das waren die Libertären Ideen und Paypal und so. Das spielt dann sehr damit, gerade auch, weil die Machtgrundlage über Palantier ist eben der Staat. Also da braucht man einfach Typen wie Michael Flynn fest in der Hierarchie verankert. Deswegen auch diese Deep-State-Ideen die ganze Zeit. Auf dessen Basis das dann alles steht. Diesen ganzen Ideenhaushalt prügelt er da mit seinem Quasi-Stipendien-Programm irgendwie durch, dass er junge Menschen aus den Unis abwirbt und sagt, kommt zu mir, ich zahle euch 50.000 Dollar im Jahr für eine gewisse Zeit dafür, dass ihr keinen Uni-Abschluss macht. Ihr seid aber dann Thiel-Follower. Also wenn ihr euch irgendwo anmeldet für ein Praktikum, dann schreibt einfach dazu, ihr kommt ihr aus der Thiel-Familie, aus der Neuen. Und dann klappt das schon irgendwie. Es ist natürlich ein Projekt, das für die einzelnen Biografien, also einfach zum Scheitern verurteilt ist. Es geht nicht auf. Er kümmert sich auch wenig darum, aber ganz interessant, wie der Text damit arbeitet, dass nämlich am Anfang von der PayPal-Mafia gesprochen wird und hier dann von, und das ist eine noch viel größere Mafia, die da gegründet wird als Thiel, anfängt sich die jungen Leute ranzuziehen. Und ehrlicherweise gewinnt natürlich auch erst dadurch, so ein bisschen, wie soll man sagen, Gravitation, dass wir gerade sehen, was auf den Schulhöfen mit der FDP-Ideologie stattfindet. Da muss man sagen, oh, das ist wirklich, also diese Kapitel sollte man dann doch noch mal genau lesen, wie weit man es treiben kann mit der Verherrlichung von Christian Lindner oder so. Also das ist auch ein bisschen gruselig.
Ganz richtig. Und wir hatten das im Föjeton ja auch schon hin und wieder, dass dann so Leute wie Sepp Gumbrecht in der NZZ oder auch in der FAZ immer wieder so Logen auf das Silicon Valley verfasst haben und dann auch sagen Ja, das sind ganz tolle Studenten dort in Stanford. Die studieren oft nur zwei Semester und dann haben die eine geniale Idee. Soll ich sie jetzt als Professor aufhalten? Natürlich nicht. Das ist ja auch das, was mich begeistert und so. Also er ist ja auch ganz in dieser Ideologie gefangen, der Gumbrecht. Und das ist so gefährlich, weil es tatsächlich, also da gibt es glaube ich einen Trickle-down-Effekt. Und der kommt jetzt hier so langsam in Deutschland richtig an.
Gumbrecht übrigens, Schirmachers Dr. Father.
Ja.
Für alle, die es nicht wissen. Und ja, also dieses Protegieren spielt hier eine große Rolle. In diesem Kapitel, wo über die viel größere Mafia gesprochen wird, nämlich diese Thiel-Follower, die da herangezogen werden, die lesen dann so Bücher wie Harry Potter und die Methoden des rationalen Denkens oder der letzte Ringträger. Und Fanfiction. Und da spielt auch eine Rolle, dass Thiel in diesen Zeiten damals ein Super-Pack für Ron Paul, also wie heißt sein Sohn? Rand Paul, der jetzt auch antrat gegen Trump. Und da kommt diese Frage auf, ist das noch libertäres Denken oder autokratisches? Denn Ron Paul, der hat damals auch mit so einem Revolution-Buch und so weiter aufgezogen, ist dreimal angetreten, kam nie sehr weit und dann ist ja Rand Paul für die republikanische Partei angetreten. Und da war Thiel aber schon nicht mehr daran interessiert, denn Thiel hatte seinen eigenen Ideenhaushalt. Und da gibt es ja hier eine Sache, bei der ich dann, also wo man auch wieder diese Verschränkungen, Verklammerungen, Thiel hasst Google. Google so als ganz illegitimer, ich würde sagen, da kommt sein Neid einfach durch, denn er wäre gerne der Google-Chef, aber nee, den anderen gönne ich das überhaupt nicht, dass die das machen. Und trotzdem teilt er sich eine Idee mit Google, indem er nämlich sagt, wir brauchen diese freien Städte draußen aus dem Meer, im, wie nennt man das, nichtpolitischen Bereich, also diese offenen Zonen, wo keine Jurisdiktion außer die des Herkunftlandes so ein bisschen gilt. Und da könnten wir ja medizinische Studien machen. Und das gibt es ja auch von Sergey Brin, dem einen Google-Chef, der auch zwischendurch seine Stimme verlor. Der ist ja auch medizinisch angeschlagen und hat ja damals auch so gesagt, ja, wir werden so zurückgehalten von diesen ganzen, also auf einer Bühne von den ganzen Regulationen. Wir könnten ja viel bessere Fortschritte machen, wenn wir einfach in Eigenverantwortung die Testpersonen, die wir hier so brauchen als Patienten, die sterben halt und sagen dann, ich opfere mich noch der Medizin, macht ruhig die eine oder andere Studie mit mir. Und da gehört ja zu Thiels Ideen zu sagen, ja, das stimmt, wir müssen in der Pharmazie viel schneller vorwärts kommen. Und dann sagt er diesen Satz Facebook wird ja auch nicht gezwungen, die Unbedenklichkeit von Farmville vorher zu bestätigen. Und da müssen wir heute ein Jahrzehnt später sagen, nee, hätte man mal lieber Facebook auch eine ordentlichen medizinischen Phase 1, 2, 3, was macht das mit jungen Frauen? Instagram und so weiter, Studie unterzogen. Also wir haben auf der einen Seite zu wenig reguliert. Und weil man dem Silicon Valley das hat durchgehen lassen, will man das jetzt auf die ganze Welt. Und wir stehen eigentlich aus der vernünftigen progressiven Seite genau dagegen und sagen, ne, wir haben gesehen, was es bedeutet, Facebook und so weiter da einfach im luftleeren Raum operieren zu lassen. Dieser Fehler muss jetzt revidiert werden.
Brin möchte auch Orte schaffen, wo mal alles möglich ist, wo wir einfach mal machen können, was wir wollen. Das ist etwas, was er einfach so auf der Bühne gesagt hat oder auch nochmal in einem Interview, glaube ich, dann wiederholt hat. Und noch vielleicht ein Wort zu Ron Paul. Das ist ja auch ein ganz irrer Politiker, der gerne zurück zum Goldstandard möchte, der irgendwie auch Pornografie in besonderer Weise unterstützt, aber zugleich eine große Prünerie hat. Also es ist, da geht wirklich alles durcheinander. Und man fragt sich natürlich zurecht, das ist ja selbst für den Thiel so ein bisschen sagen wir unter aller Würde, dass er da jetzt mit diesem Ron Paul was, was soll das eigentlich? Und Thiel wird auch darauf angesprochen. Und in einem Interview, und dann sagt er erst mal, ich bezweifle im Grunde, ob Urnengänge wirklich viel bringen. Also erst mal sind demokratische Wahlen noch sinnvoll. Und weiter heißt es dann, was mir an der Technologie gefällt, ist sie unreguliert, kann man damit die Welt verändern, ohne sich dafür erst Genehmigung von anderen Leuten einzuholen. Im besten Fall unterliegt sie keiner demokratischen Kontrolle und keiner Mehrheit, die Veränderung meiner Ansicht nach oft ablehnend gegenübersteht. Und dann wird dann noch mal gefragt, naja, wie ist denn das jetzt mit diesem Ron Paul? Warum unterstützen sie den? Und er muss dann wohl gesagt haben, wir wollen einfach für den nächsten Zyklus eine libertäre Basis aufbauen. Im Grunde machen wir, also 2012, machen wir Wahlkampf für 2016. Und das ist ja aufgegangen.
Genau, das ist aufgegangen, aber eben nicht mit Rand Paul. Also dem Sohn von Ron Paul, der damals schon bereit stand. Und hier kommt dann auch dieser sozusagen kleine Dreh in der Entwicklung, dass nämlich Ron Paul damals so eine Jugendbewegung gegründet hat. Oder sie geschah einfach, so wie wir das auch bei Bernie Sanders kennen, nur auf der anderen Seite. Und Rand Paul nicht geschafft hat, diese Jugendbewegung zu übernehmen von seinem Vater und auch Thiels Unterstützung nicht länger genoss. Und dann wird im Buch Thiel unterstellt, erkannt zu haben, diese Jugendbewegung ist nicht libertär, sondern sie ist reaktionär. Und dann ist der Klammer-Schlag sozusagen, also der Wurf nicht weit zu Trump, der nämlich genau das aufnehmen konnte, der sich sozusagen in dieses gemachte Nest setzen konnte. Und dann ja auch dieses Tape. Also Donald Trump macht Wahlkampf. Und dann kommt dieses Grapper by the Pussy. Also ich kann mich, ich kann alles mit Frauen machen, wenn ich nur genug Geld habe. Und wo dann die Berater hintenrum gesagt haben, ja, das Tape ist gar nicht so gut, weil das ist ein Anmachversuch, der nicht gelangt. Also gar nicht so sehr, weil er sexistisch ist oder so.
Die rezipieren das vollkommen anders. Also wir rezipieren das, oh Gott, wie sexistisch. Und die sagen, ja, irgendwie steht er nicht so gut da. Also wenn er so unerfolgreich bei Frauen ist und das irgendwie nicht geklappt hat, dann ist er dann dann ist er kein Alpha.
Ja, genau, das war das Problem.
Das sieht ja wie ein Verlierer aus. Das wollen wir jetzt nicht. Es ist ja auch nochmal ganz kurz um diese diese deutsche Connection zu sehen. Wir haben ja tatsächlich so eine Glorifizierung solcher Figuren wie Thiel in der deutschen Mädchenlandschaft ganz stark. Also wir haben jetzt schon darüber gesprochen, dass er den Schirmacher Preis bekommen hat. Thiel, wir haben das beim Springer Award, dass der immer an solche Silicon Valley Größen geht, wie dann Elon Musk. Oder wir hatten jetzt auch kürzlich, dass Ulf Poschert bei Twitter schrieb, er könnte das überhaupt nicht verstehen. Also ein solches Nachwuchstalent wie Kurz, dass sich die Leute darüber so ereifern. Und er sprach dann von Peter Thiel als einem Genie. Also das ist so erstaunlich, inwieweit diese Leute auch sich dann so wähnen als mutige Akteure der Gegenkultur. Dabei stehen sie absolut auf der Seite des Kapitals. Und zwar des richtig großen Kapitals.
Ja, na wir kommen ja nachher nochmal explizit auf den Schirmerabweis zu sprechen, aber bei Ulf Poschert, diese publizistischen Männer sind fasziniert von der Macht. Und die blenden die Grundlage dieser Macht aus. Die sind einfach nur fasziniert von den Effekten, die ihnen selbst versagt bleiben. Gerade aus diesem publizistischen Feld.
Gerade bei Poschert ist das ja ganz klar, das ist ja amüsant. Der hat ja ein Großprojekt wirklich gehabt, wo man dachte, oh, da passiert was Neues im Journalismus. Das war die deutsche Ausgabe der Vanity Fair. Dieses Projekt ist vollkommen gescheitert. Das war aber inhaltlich ganz gut.
Ich habe es gern gelesen.
Also ich habe nur die erste Ausgabe damals gekauft und die sah so aus, dass es eine lange Fotostrecke mit einem oberkörperfreien Thiel Schweiger gab. Danke, ich hatte genug.
Die haben mehr gezerrt an dem amerikanischen Vorbild.
Okay, aber das ist total gescheitert und seitdem ist er halt einfach bei der Welt. Und wir müssen jetzt einfach mal so sagen, er ist da angestellt und muss sich da auch benehmen und sonst klopft Friede Springer ihm auf die Finger. Er ist nicht der libertäre Freigeist, der hinaus rennt und einfach alles einreißt und wieder was Neues entstehen lässt. Das ist er einfach nicht. Nee, er ist da angestellt und muss aufpassen, dass Friede Springer ihn auch weiter haben will.
Und damit sind wir bei den Publizisten mit Macht, Gorka. Ein Gorka-Film wird es, glaube ich, geben. Es ist, glaube ich, einer in der Mache.
Ich habe hier etwas liegen, dass mich das noch gerade sagen. Und zwar ein Buch, das heißt Conspiracy von Ryan Holiday. Das handelt von diesem Gorka-Fall. Und es hat mir unser Hörer Niklas überreicht, als ich in Köln eine Veranstaltung gemacht habe. Und damals nahm ich das Buch und hatte aber jetzt das noch gar nicht so alles auf dem Schirm, worum es da geht. Aber ich habe jetzt angefangen zu lesen. Das ist hochinteressant, denn das verhandelt noch mal jetzt in Detail das, was hier im Buch aber auch sehr gut abgebildet ist. Nämlich, wie Peter Thiel dann kämpft gegen die Presse. Genau.
Gorka hat publizistische Macht, aber nicht im politischen Sinne, sondern über einzelne Biografien. Und das hat Peter Thiel ganz negativ zu spüren bekommen, denn er wurde dort geoutet. Also sein schwuler Lebensstil, der gar nicht so raumgreifend war wahrscheinlich. Denn es spielt wirklich gar keine große Rolle irgendwie. Sehr viel unterdrückt wahrscheinlich, aber diese Kirchenpsychologie kann man sich auch sparen. Sondern aber halt trotzdem schwul und er wurde da geoutet gegen sein Willen. Und das ist natürlich immer ein Problem, wenn sowas passiert. Selbst ich kann man da auch ein bisschen sympathisieren, um wenn man Gorka von damals, es gibt ja jetzt wieder Gorka, aber wenn man das erste Gorka da kannte, muss man sagen, ja also warum nicht erstmal die hinwegfegen? Die Frage, was bedeutet das allgemein auch für andere publikatistische Formen und so kann man dann immer noch klären. Ja, erstmal Gorka vom Markt. Also deswegen finde ich bricht das Buch da ein bisschen auch, also mit dem roten Faden. Man denkt dann so ein bisschen, ah, es ist doch noch ein normaler Mensch, der dann halt mal viel Geld hat. Und diese Motivation verstehen wir zumindest, die da dahinter steckt. Wir erfahren in diesem Abschnitt, dass er mit Matt Denseisen zusammen ist aus New York. Selber Black Rock Chef in irgendeinem Teilbereich da auch. So ein Vice President, also gar nicht so unter. Aber ich würde sagen, Gorka wird sowieso noch mal ein Thema, wenn wir da wirklich mal einen Film dazu bekommen, weil sich das auch so als Drama abspielt.
Wollen wir über seine Seite, das müssen wir ganz kurz sagen. Es ist eine Seite, die eigentlich Boulevard macht, aber nicht nur die üblichen Promis und Politiker, sondern auch die Gurus und Stars der Tech-Szene. Ins Visier nimmt und richtig schmutzigen Boulevard macht. So schmutzig, wie wir das hier in Deutschland nicht kennen, wie wir das aus Großbritannien kennen, aus den USA, dann ja auch von anderen Bloggern. Und das sieht so aus, dass sie sich Informationen beschaffen und dann unglaublich viel aus dem Privatleben tratschen. Und dazu gehörte dann auch zu sagen, na ja, mit Peter Thiel ist das folgendermaßen, er ist da zwar hin und wieder mit einer Frau über den roten Teppich gegangen, aber eigentlich ist er schwul. Und dann haben sie ja immer wieder neue Informationen sich beschafft und haben aber zugleich, und das ist vielleicht auch nochmal interessant, wenn es um Neid und Kränkungen und all das geht, sie haben das immer damit verknüpft zu sagen, ja, Palantier ist gescheitert, das funktioniert alles nicht richtig. Sie haben auch immer den beruflichen Erfolg in ein anderes Licht gestellt. Man könnte auch sagen, sie haben, auch wenn das natürlich eine sehr schmutzige Kampagne ist, mitunter Dinge ans Tageslicht gebracht über die Unternehmen, die Silicon Valley unternehmen, die man eigentlich ganz gerne in der New York Times gelesen hätte, aber da war man dann noch zu vorsichtig oder zu eng mitverbandelt. Die sind also eigentlich auch mit so einer Peter Thiel Methode da rein, denn es kann richtig schmutzig sein. Also Gorka ist eigentlich auch wie Peter Thiel. Peter Thiel wird ja auch alles tun, um gegen WikiLeaks vorzugehen. Also ist ja auch so eine Sache, dass man dann überlegt, wie könnten wir den Green World, wie könnten wir den irgendwie davon abbringen, dass er weiter sich für WikiLeaks engagiert? Und da ist man auch wirklich zu allen Methoden bereit. Und da wühlt man genauso im Dreck, wie das Gorka macht. Und nun ist es so, dass sie ihn da geoutet haben. Thiel ist empört über Hauptsilicon Valley, hasst Gorka, weil da immer so viele Informationen drinstehen, die man eigentlich nicht veröffentlichen will. Diese Leute, die die ganze Zeit unsere Daten abzapfen, sorgen ja sehr dafür, dass ihre Daten nirgendshin geraten und dass wir nichts von ihnen erfahren. Und dann gibt es eine Möglichkeit für Peter Thiel, sich an Gorka zu rächen. Nämlich ist es so, dass dieser Westler, Hulk Hogan, auch ins Visier von Gorka gerät. Und zwar gibt es irgendein Sexvideo von Hulk Hogan, das an Gorka irgendwie geht und die veröffentlichen das oder veröffentlichen Ausschnitte daraus. Und daraufhin klagt Hulk Hogan dagegen. Jetzt ist meistens bei solchen Sachen dann klar, man bekommt vielleicht etwas Schadensersatz und dann ist gut. Und dann wundert man sich, er könnte eigentlich Schadensersatz haben, dieser Hulk Hogan, aber der klagt immer weiter. Und wenn er so weiterklagt, dann ist das ganze Unternehmen schon aufgrund der Rechtskosten pleite, kann ihm also folglich auch gar keinen Schadensersatz mehr zahlen. Warum sollte er das machen? Der will doch einfach nur 10 Millionen Dollar oder so haben, bis sich herausstellt, naja, wer bezahlt eigentlich die Anwälte von Hulk Hogan? Peter Thiel, der sich jetzt über Hulk Hogan rächen will. Und man ist sich natürlich auch politisch sehr nahe.
Ja, also für das Drehbuch gibt es da einiges, an dem man sich abarbeiten kann. Denn, also Gorka als die Publikation, die aufschreibt, was alle wissen, aber sich niemand zu publizieren traut. Damit ist man ja relativ nah, du hast ja auch schon gesagt, eigentlich Sachen, die man gerne in der New York Times lesen wollte. Es ist halt wie mit der Wall Street. Man sitzt in New York und denkt, nee, da gibt es Regeln und auch ein bisschen Etikette. Das publizieren wir mal nicht. Gorka operiert aber wie Paypal. Wir machen irgendwas mit Geld. Ach, da gibt es eigentlich Regeln. Das ist uns egal. Wir machen erst mal irgendwas mit Geld. Und so macht das dann Gorka eben auch. Also in deren Sicht ist das auch wieder so ein... Peter, die machen das nur so, wie du das mit Paypal und dem Geld gemacht hast. Machen die das mit Information und der publizistischen Kraft, die du ja kennst. Naja, dann outen sie ihn. Er findet das nicht so gut. Auch durch diese raffinierte Verknüpfung mit... Ihr liest diesen Text nur, um das Persönliche zu erfahren. Aber wir sagen euch auch, der ist auch ökonomisch ein Loser. Der Typ hat es nicht drauf und so weiter. Also diese Verknüpfung, die ihn da so auf die Palme bringt. Und dann gibt es dieses Einfallstor, HAL Kogan klagt und er hört einfach nicht auf zu klagen. Und es geht immer weiter. Und plötzlich geht es um hunderte Millionen und die ganze Existenz des Unternehmens steht auf dem Spiel. Und die finden aber nie raus, was da passiert. Während Palantier eine Software hat, um einfach zu sagen, ihr wollt alle Engen oder Bekannten von WikiLeaks, um die dann unter Druck zu setzen. Wir drücken mal schnell auf den Knopf und dann haben wir euch die soziale Landkarte von WikiLeaks aufgeschlüsselt und dann könnt ihr die alle unter Druck setzen. Also das war das Angebot, das Palantier ans Militär gemacht hat. Die bei Gorka wollten das auch. Bei Gorka haben sie angefangen, rückwärts zu recherchieren. Die Anwälte, die uns da immer befragen nach irgendwelchen Sachen. Wer sind die eigentlich? Für wen arbeiten die eigentlich noch? Und sie finden es aber nicht raus. Ihr Unternehmen wird zerstört und zerstört. Und es kommt eine Vorladung nach der anderen und ein teures Urteil nach dem anderen. Und sie finden einfach nicht raus, was mit ihnen passiert. Sie kriegen es nicht re-ingeniert, diese Meisterleistung, die da stattfindet. Sie sehen nur, da ist irgendwas. Also da ist so ein riesiges schwarzes Loch, das frisst uns auf. Und nur weil Peter Thiel nach den ganzen Verfahren nicht an sich halten kann, sondern weil er das für die größte philanthropische Leistung seines Lebens hält, Gorka zerstört zu haben, fällt irgendwann der Groschen bei den Leuten, der hat uns zerstört. Dessen Geld war das. Es war ja nicht nur der Hulk Hogan, es waren ja noch ganz viele andere. Am Ende vor Gericht waren es immer ganz raffinierte Argumente, wie zum Beispiel die Leute interessieren sich für Hulk Hogan. Dafür gibt es ein öffentliches Interesse, aber doch nicht für die Person, die Hulk Hogan spielt. Also hat man das illegitim veröffentlicht. So, und darüber war das dann eigentlich ganz banale Argumente und so, aber sie müssen halt mal richtig durchgepeitscht werden. Und das schaffen sie dann. Und erst nachdem das Ganze, also als der Rauch schon verzogen ist eigentlich, stellen sie fest, Peter Thiel war es krass. Also wir wollten hier mal richtig Schachmatt gesetzt. Ja, der alte Schachspieler hat sich da wieder gezeigt. Also da bin ich sehr gespannt, wenn es die Bücherchen gibt. Ich glaube, es ist ein Film in der Mache. So, das ist auch nicht uninteressant, das dann mal wirklich in diesem in diesem Ding zu sehen. So wie wie schützt sich Peter Thiel vor dem Alter? Das war ja hoch interessant zu lesen. Diese ganzen Silicon Valley Milliardäre, die wollen in ihrem Alter Geld haben. Den reichen nicht irgendwelche Pensionsfonds oder so, sondern die wollen richtig viel Geld. Peter Thiel hat 3,5 Milliarden auf der hohen Kante, die ihm aus seinen jetzigen Investitionen zur Verfügung stehen ab seinem 65 Lebensjahr und zwar steuerfrei. Er hat dann einfach so einen Geldtopf, Tischlein deckt, ich wird niemals leer, 3,5 Milliarden für, was weiß ich, 30 Lebensjahre oder je nachdem, wie lange er da noch lebt. Wie schafft man das? Und da fand ich der Text, an einen Punkt hätte er so ein bisschen mehr Analyse noch bekommen können, denn dieses Geld steht nur steuerfrei zur Verfügung, wenn Peter Thiel es allein für seine Altersvorsorge investiert. Wenn er es investiert, um über die Eigentumsrechte auch am Unternehmenserfolg zu partizipieren oder an ihn zu steuern, also ich besitze 20 Prozent von dem und dem Unternehmen und mische mich jetzt ins Management ein, weil ich das ja darf, dann steht es ihm nicht steuerfrei zur Verfügung. Er muss sich also raushalten. Also war Peter Thiel, und das interpretiere ich jetzt ein bisschen über, das steht im Text so nicht drin, Peter Thiel war immer daran gelegen, ein riesiges soziales Netzwerk mit seinen Investitionen aufzuspannen, überall irgendwie beteiligt zu sein, also wirklich so ein Netz in der Spinne im Netz. Gleichzeitig musste er aber immer wahnsinnig aufpassen, dass er sich nicht zu sehr emotional oder persönlich investiert. Deswegen auch immer so eine gewisse Distanz zu irgendwelchen Freunden, weil er konnte sich immer erst sicher sein, dass Menschen ihm loyal gegenüber sind, wenn es irgendwie eine finanzielle Abhängigkeit gab. Gleichzeitig hat die finanzielle Abhängigkeit dazu geführt, dass die Loyalität nicht als Freundschaft ausgelegt werden durfte, weil dann hätte man ihm nachher sagen können, ja, aber da hast du doch mit dem Mittag gegessen und ihm irgendwelche Business-Tipps gegeben und damit hast du auch das Management beeinflusst. Also können wir dir das Geld jetzt leider nicht steuerfrei zur Verfügung stellen, denn es war eine reguläre Investition und nicht nur eine, die auf Rendite ab dem 65. Lebensjahr einspielt. Also da scheint es noch so ein paar irre Sachen im amerikanischen Recht zu geben, das sich wirklich niederschlägt auf persönliche Beziehungen, die man da so hat. Ja, es ist ganz verrückt. Und dann in diesem Abschnitt kommt natürlich auch die Frage auf, ja, wo war denn überall investiert? Cambridge Analytica wird genannt, Clearview, dieses Unternehmen, das wir ja auch schon Gesichtserkennung und so weiter. Wir scrapen einfach mal das ganze Internet leer. Google liest doch auch das ganze Internet. Wieso dürfen wir nicht einfach alle Bilder benutzen, die wir so finden? Alles hoch illegitimer, bis hin zu illegaler Scheiß. Aber wenn 100 Polizeibehörden Amerika das Zeug kaufen, als Elektronik, die sie benutzen, dann hat man das schon wieder so nachträglich legitimisiert. Also das ist auch wieder total verrückt, wie das da alles drin hängt.
Sollen wir noch auf den Wahlkampf Trump zu sprechen kommen?
Das müssen wir, glaube ich.
Wer ist der größte Feind erst mal von Peter Thiel? Also der größte Feind, der da dreut. Wer könnte Trump Konkurrenz machen? Also Bernie Sanders wäre schon blöd, wenn der das werden würde. Aber eine ist noch schlimmer für Thiel persönlich, also für seine Lebensweise, nämlich Elizabeth Warren. Das muss auf jeden Fall verhindert werden, dass diese Frau Präsidentin wird. Thiel ist aber von Anfang an nicht Trump-Unterstützer. Er unterschätzt wohl offenbar erst dieses Entertainment-Talent von Trump, unterschätzt seine Wirkung. Er eiert da also sehr lange rum, hält Trump auch nicht gerade für einen genialen Unternehmer, ist da auch mit ein paar abfälligen Bemerkungen aufgetreten. Aber er schafft es dann noch gerade so rechtzeitig auf den fahrenden Zug aufzuspringen, um dann auch mit in der Lok zu setzen, wenn es ein Ziel geht.
Also Elizabeth Warren, Hillary Clinton, alles Frauen, die Demokratische Partei, Michelle Obama, irgendwie so im Hintergrund. Es ist ja super interessant zu lesen, dass diese ganze Idee von ich suche mir mal ein Anwesen in Neuseeland, sich im Nachhinein herausstellt, komm mal für den Fall, dass die Demokraten, also Hillary Clinton und Elizabeth Warren oder wer auch immer, da gewinnen.
Und das ist wirklich verrückt.
Er hat sich für Neuseeland überhaupt nicht interessiert. Es war ihm eigentlich zu langweilig. Er war dann irgendwie zehn Tage mal da, müsste aber eigentlich 190 Tage oder so was vor Ort sein, um das überhaupt zu legitimieren. Dort Staatsbürger zu sein, großer Lobby-Erfolg, es dann doch hingekriegt zu haben, aber am Ende, puh, Trump wurde gewählt. Hillary Clinton abgewehrt, dann große Verbrüderung mit Mark Zuckerberg. Wir lassen hier Elizabeth Warren nicht gewähren. Er arbeitet dann wirklich auch mit Zuckerberg so weit zusammen, dass sie zusammen Abendessen mit Donald Trump haben, bei denen dann auch Zuckerberg Trump zusichert. Ne, wir machen auf unserer Seite kein Fact-Checking für Anzeigen von Politikern. Wir sind ja keine Zeitung. Und das ist sozusagen das Zugeständnis. Wenn du Trump Präsident bleibst, weil Mark Zuckerberg kein Fact-Checking für Dings macht, dann verhindern wir damit Elizabeth Warren. Was bedeutet, du bekommst dann die Anti-Warren-Politik. Wir lassen das Silicon Valley in Ruhe. Trump gesteht Zuckerberg zu, wenn du mich, das habe ich so ehrlich gesagt in der Tiefe noch nicht, nirgendwo anders gelesen. Aber wenn das stimmt, bedeutet das, Trump und Zuckerberg sind in den Deal eingegangen. Du lässt mich bei Facebook Wahlkampf machen, wie ich das will und dafür bekommst du nicht Elizabeth Warns Politik. Und diese Losung, wissen wir jetzt, ging nicht so ganz auf. Elizabeth Warren ist an wichtiger Stelle und Amy Klobuchar ist auch nicht weit weg. Es gibt keine große Mehrheit für diese Art von Politik jetzt im Kongress, aber das mal hinten angestellt. Dass es über Trump wieder so eine Verbrüderung von Zuckerberg und Thiel gab, die sich irgendwie gut verstehen, aber doch aus unterschiedlichen Welten kamen. Zuckerberg hat nie ein Buch gelesen, Thiel hat an vielen gearbeitet und 10.000 Worte lange Investorsbriefe geschrieben und so weiter. Also diese Verknüpfung, die ist jetzt so aktuell und so wichtig. Und man müsste sich so genau angucken, was jetzt gerade in Amerika passiert.
Man muss doch sehen, wie sehr die Konzerne mitgemacht haben. Das ist ja auch sehr erstaunlich. Die ganzen Silicon Valley Konzerne, die Obama noch nicht alle zusammen bekamen, haben sich eingefunden bei Donald Trump, um mit ihm zusammen am Tisch zu sitzen. Wer war da der Wortführer? Natürlich Peter Thiel. Und dann war natürlich für Unternehmen, die diesem liberalen Zeitgeist entsprechen, also Apple und Co., dass mit diesem Bann von Migranten keine gute Sache. Die brauchen ja dringend Kräfte aus dem Ausland und sahen das als ein Problem an. Und das wollte man dann auch hin und wieder mal zur Sprache bringen. Grundsätzlich aber zeigt sich doch sehr schön, wie das Kapital sich dann mit einer solchen Regierung verbündet, wenn sie merken, okay, der wird uns ja in keiner Weise regulieren. Der wird uns ja nicht gefährlich werden. Steve Bannon hat das Ganze natürlich durchschaut und sagt dann, die Typen hatten Begriffen. Und damit meint er jetzt also alle, die wir aus den großen Silicon Valley Unternehmen kennen, die da bei Trump sitzen. Das Problem war China. China sollte Staatsfeind Nummer eins sein. Und sie argumentierten im Grunde nationalistisch. Also dieser Kampf gegen China. Also da muss man sich ja noch mal selbst ein bisschen kritisch betrachten, wenn wir China kritisieren, müssen wir aufpassen, dass wir jetzt nicht in dieses selbe Horn blasen wie die, damit wir dann irgendwann sagen, genau wie das ja auch der Microsoft-Anwalt mal ausgeführt hat in Tools and Weapons. Wir stehen jetzt alle zusammen als Nationen, als Konzerne gegen den gemeinsamen Fall in China. Nee, nee, ihr seid auch dran, ihr Konzerne, wenn wir unsere progressive Politik durchwitzen. Also damit hat man es aber wirklich geschafft, dass zu einen, hier steht es dann auch nochmal sehr schön aufgeschrieben von Chafkin, darin sahen Bannon und andere Thiels maßgeblichsten Beitrag zu Trump-Präsidentschaft. Nicht in der Besetzung von zehn oder zwölf Regierungsposten, sondern darin, daß es ihm gelang, die mächtigsten und angesehensten Unternehmensvertreter Amerikas in Trumps Orbit zu bringen, selbst wenn sie insgeheim nichts für ihn übrig hatten. Auch bei Obamas Dinner im Silicon Valley im Jahr 2011 waren Schwergewichte anwesend gewesen. Aber nicht alle. Und im Unterschied zu damals, als es zu einer Meinungsverschiedenheit zwischen Obama und Steve Jobs kam, gab es diesmal kaum merklichen Dissens.
Ja. Also, es gibt ganz viele Fäden, wo man sagen muss, das Buch hört da auf, aber die Geschichte natürlich nicht.
Die geht vielleicht weiter mit Josh Hawley? Du hast uns ja schon mal sehr ausführlich vorgestellt.
Wir haben ihn hier im Juni 2020 schon besprochen, als Trump noch im Amt war, aber der Supreme Court schon die eine oder andere Entscheidung getroffen hat, nachdem Trump ihn besetzt hatte. Hinsichtlich einer gewissen Liberalisierung von Umgang mit Homosexualität am Arbeitsplatz und so weiter, wo Josh Hawley im Kongress stand und sagte, oder wir ihm unterstellt haben, ich schnapp mir jetzt mal die Base, die Trump gerade enttäuscht. Wir haben gerade wieder so einen Moment, dass Trump auf der Bühne steht bei Bill O'Reilly und sagt, natürlich bin ich geimpft, ich empfehle es euch auch, und dann also wirklich großer Hass entsteht. Oder damals, als Trump ein paar Raketen auf Syrien geschickt hat und alle durchtreten aus seiner Base und sagen, ey, wir wollen keinen Krieg und so. Also es gibt dann mal wieder die Momente, wo es so aufbricht. Und Peter Thiel war eigentlich Fan von Ted Cruz. Nur Ted Cruz ist übergewichtig und hat eine Stimme, die überhaupt nicht funktioniert. Das ist natürlich bei Josh Hawley ganz anders. Absolut religiös verankert, selber am Supreme Court ausgebildet, jetzt Senator, richtige Stimme, richtiger Körper. Wir kennen alle sein Foto mit der Faust am 6. Januar vor einem Jahr, als er da noch mit anstachelt.
Und könnte ja ein Bruder von Peter Thiel sein.
Genau, und der Typ steht jetzt parat. Könnte einer dieser Models sein, mit dem sich Peter Thiel gerne umgibt. Also, den sollte man sich jetzt ganz genauer angucken die nächste Zeit. Was da so passiert an Verknüpfungen. Leider wenig drin im Buch, aus Gründen einfach.
Kann auch noch nicht, aber man kann schon mal ganz klar das Programm benennen, dass sie haben, nämlich, das lautet für Thiel, zurück in die Zukunft. Ja, also das Reaktionäre und das Libertär technisch Visionäre miteinander verknüpft. Und das kann dann so ein Josh Hawley vielleicht zur politischen Wirklichkeit machen.
Genau. Und dann mal schauen, wenn Facebook seinen nächsten Versuch macht, eine eigene Währung zu bringen. Libra, das war ein Treffen von Zuckerberg und Trump, weil das Thiel vermittelt hat, wo auch mit am Tisch saß, um einfach mal über Libra, können wir mal den Dollar abschaffen und so, zu sprechen. Bildungssektor, ganz groß. Wir kennen alle diese Mega-Blase. Mehr Bildungsschulden als Kreditkartenschulden. Eine junge Generation, die das niemals zurückzahlen kann. Biografisch aber gefesselt ist, weil selbst der eidesstattliche Pleitererklärung nicht von diesen Schulden befreit. Und man sich jetzt echt überlegen muss, was machen wir da eigentlich? Die Diskussion hat beiden einfach vom Tisch gewischt. Sehr viele Kräfte wollten, dass es da zu wirklich substanziellen Entlastungen kam, vor allem Elizabeth Warren, die wollte einfach 50.000 Dollar einfach mal weg als Last. Da bleibt immer noch genug übrig. Biden ist mit mir nicht vereinbar. Obwohl, und das könnte so ein Kniff sein, es vor allem der Staat ist, der diese Schulden hält. Also diese Menschen sind beim Staat verschuldet. Also dieser Bildungssektor kann aber hier Chafkin auch nur andeuten. Scheint einer zu sein, gerade auch weil Peter Thiel den schon so viele Jahre einfach verachtet. Medizin. Es kam irgendwann zu diesem Moment, dass Trumps Regierung dies, also zum einen Palantier beauftragt hat, Software zu entwickeln und dann die Krankenhäuser angewiesen wurden, den eigenen Datenbestand nicht mehr an eine CDC zu melden, sondern an Palantier. Es wurde ihnen regelrecht verboten, die Behörden zu informieren über die eigenen Sachen, die im Krankenhaus gerade vor sich gehen, sondern Palantier sollten diese Daten zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Also es ist wirklich crazy, so was zu lesen. Und naja, Thiel hat sich jetzt über sein Stimmrechtestand, so wie Mark Zuckerberg auch, die ökonomische Macht über seine Unternehmen gesichert. Das alles seins. Auch wenn Palantier jetzt an der Börse ist, aber da kann man halt nur am Unternehmenserfolg partizipieren und nicht am Management teilnehmen. Dass der 6. Januar vor einem Jahr die Verselbstständigung des Thielismus ist, ist ein ganz krasses Urteil in diesem Buch. Gerade wenn wir und heute ist der 6. Januar sehen, was heute wieder aktualisiert wird in Amerika in den Nachrichten, was dieser Tag bedeutet. Also der Daily hat jetzt schon ein bisschen vorgelegt. Arte hat große Reportagen. Das wird jetzt noch mal alles richtig aufgearbeitet. Man kann sich jetzt wirklich dieser Tage die Nachrichtenlage anschauen und dann über dieses Urteil im Buch nachdenken. Es ist ja aufgeladen genug. Es sind viele 100 Seiten, die das vorher beschreiben, was das bedeutet. Also hier haben wir es echt mit einem richtig krassen Buch zu tun, das uns ganz schön viel erklärt hat. Und jetzt Epilog, die Parabiose. Was soll man davon halten? Ich weiß auch nicht.
Naja, wir haben ja diese transhumanistische Strömung auch schon eine ganze Weile. Im Übrigen könnte Thiel da auch wieder gut andocken an die Postmoderne. Auch da gibt es ja einige Theoretiker, die solche Gedanken hervorgebracht haben. Dieser Transhumanismus läuft natürlich am Ende auf so eine Idee einer neuen Menschenrasse. Und ich sage hier ganz bewusst mal Rasse hinaus, dass man sagt, man schafft so eine Elite, die unsterblich ist. Und die wird auch dann immer weiter optimiert. Die wird vielleicht auch noch mit dem Computer verbunden. Und diese dann herrscht über all die anderen, die Sterblichen. Es gibt ein ganz gutes Buch von Francis Fukuyama. Er mag geirrt haben bei seinem Ende der Geschichte, aber er hat ein besseres Buch geschrieben, das Ende des Menschen. Und da sagt er, was ist eigentlich?
Also Fukuyama ist ein ganz Kluger. Da sollte man sich gar nicht so sehr festhalten an diesem Ende der Geschichte.
Und der hat ein Buch geschrieben, das Ende des Menschen. Und da fragt er sich, was ist eigentlich, wenn wir eines Tages in der Lage sind, Menschen mit Sporen auf die Welt zu bringen und Menschen mit einem Sattel auf dem Rücken. Also wenn wir von Anfang an die Ungleichheit genetisch manifestieren, sodass sie nicht mehr überwindbar ist, dass es nicht mehr irgendeinen Fahrstuhl nach oben oder irgendetwas gibt, dass damit sich die ganze demokratische Idee des Westens, besonders Amerikas, auflöst. Das ist etwas, was er da durchspielt und eine Gefahr vor, der er erheblich warnt. Wenn wir jetzt Thiel gelesen haben, dann wissen wir, das ist genau das, was Thiel eigentlich vorschwebt. Er will auf dem Sattel sitzen und da unten sitzen unter ihm, die Sterblichen. Und diese transhumanistische Idee ist etwas, womit man, glaube ich, nicht nur viele Investorengelder bekommt, sondern das ist auch tatsächlich diese Vision auch. Und da empfehle ich das Buch von dem Physiker Kaku, der mal beschreibt, wie wäre das eigentlich, wenn wir im Weltall leben würden. Ganz sicher ist da, wenn wir in irgendeiner Weise eine Mars Kolonie oder so wollen, brauchen wir natürlich gänzlich andere Körper. Also mit unseren Körpern können wir da nicht lange leben. Da können wir mal paar Wochen sein. Wir wissen ja, was Astronauten für Trainings absolvieren müssen und wie die dann auch zurückkommen, wie die wieder dann auf Vordermann gebracht werden müssen, dass das alles wieder stimmt mit Muskulatur. Da braucht man eigentlich dann einen Transhumanismus. Also auch hier wird Transhumanismus und Exit-Strategie zusammen gedacht. All das, was jetzt gerade so Leute wie Peter Thiel umtreibt.
Ja, Covid hat die Zukunft schon freigesetzt, laut Thiel. Mal gucken, es wird ja auch Backlashes geben.
Ein Interview, das der Roger Köppel gibt. Also mit dieser wirklich sehr, sehr rechten Wochenzeitung, oder wie die heißt in der, nee nicht Wochenzeitung, das ist die linke. Da hat dieses Roger Köppel in Schweizer Platz halt.
Also der Chafkin hat viele Interviewpartner angefragt, selbst mit Mark Zucker, mit Elon Musk konnte er direkt sprechen, mit Peter Thiel, nicht nur über Bande und so. Man weiß nicht genau, was das bedeutet. Und ja, dann sagt er kurz, ja, ich habe da mit diesem Schweizer Publizisten, der hat ja dieses Gespräch da mit Peter Thiel geführt. Und ja, die Zukunft ist jetzt freigesetzt. Wir wissen nicht genau, wie die Backlashes aussehen. Wir sehen heute schon medizinische Aufarbeitung, Kurzsichtigkeit bei Kindern, weil sie nicht mehr, wenn man zu viel drin vor dem Bildschirm hängt, draußen das Fußball fällt und so weiter, ihre Augen trainieren. All solche Sachen. Eine Vervierfachung, auch wenn die Zahlen unklar sind, Vervierfachung von stationär aufgenommenen Selbstmordversuchskandidaten, in dem Falle noch. Also Covid wird nicht einfach so ein Abfeiern des Silicon Valleys, weil zum Glück hatten wir Internet und so weiter. Bleiben die nächsten Jahre, was Covid angeht. In der Ansicht mal gucken, was da passiert. Ich fand das Final am Ende ganz gut, weil wir haben hier ein Buch, das heißt Peter Thiel. Und eigentlich erfahren wir aber ganz viel über Silicon Valley. Was heißt eben nicht das Silicon Valley oder die Musk, PayPal, Peter Thiel Story oder sonst irgendwie, sondern Personen, ihre Ideen und so weiter. Und am Ende wird ja Steve Jobs noch mal aufgeführt, als der eigentliche Oberguru, der nicht die Gier, sondern den Tod als den Treiber seines Lebens sah. Er hatte natürlich die Krebsdiagnose schon relativ früh. Das war ja dann die, also die ihn getötet hat, die der Rückkehr des Krebs ist. Er hat also immer unter diesem Damoklesschert gelebt und wollte deswegen noch so viel wie möglich verwirklichen und so weiter. Also diese Ideen, die man da so, die sich fast von selbst ergeben, wenn man darüber liest. Und das fand ich noch mal einen guten Gegensatz, das aufzumachen. Insbesondere, weil das Buch sich traut, mit der Spekulation zu schließen. Vielleicht hat die Familiengründung und eigene Kinder. Peter Thiel etwas beruhigt. Weiß man nicht. Kann natürlich.
Ja, das ist eine Idee, die man aus Hollywood kennt. Ich bin da sehr skeptisch. Also ich glaube, dass das alles in einem großen Nebeneinander geht. Aber sag doch bitte noch ein Wort zum Schirmachabweis für Peter Thiel. Wie können wir das einordnen?
Also in Berlin gibt es mehrere publizistische Einrichtungen. Zum Beispiel dieses ganz große Hochhaus an der ehemaligen Mauer, wo oben was weiß ich Springer oder so dransteht. Also das Springer Hochhaus. Und dann gibt es die kleine Einrichtung des Berliner Büro, der FAZ, die aber so ein Atrium haben mit Lichtdach und so weiter, wo man auch immer eine Veranstaltung macht. Und dieser Schirmachabweis ist ja relativ neu. Auch relativ neu ist der Axel-Springer-Preis. Den Axel-Springer-Preis haben wir jetzt bekommen. Irgendwie, das ist wie der Aachener Friedenspreis, den bekommt der Chef der EU-Kommission, dann der EZB-Chef, dann der Papst, und dann geht es wieder von vorne los. Und so ist auch dieser Axel-Springer-Preis organisiert. Den kriegt der Chef von Google, dann der Chef von Twitter, dann der Chef von Facebook, dann der Chef von Amazon, und dann geht es wieder von vorne los. Und warum? Naja, weil Matthias Döpfner gerne einen Fototermin hätte mit diesen Leuten. Und da muss man aber schon eine große Show veranstalten und ihnen diese Preise verleihen. Meine Vermutung ist, nachdem irgendwie Max Zuckerberg den Springer-Preis bekommen hat und so weiter, dass man ihn eigentlich, um mal das Gespräch mit ihm zu führen, so eine Stunde mit Peter Thiel, dass man ihm den Axel-Springer-Preis geben wollte. Aber wie gesagt, ich spekuliere hier nur, das ist das, was für mich am meisten Sinn ergibt. Und dann dachte sich Peter Thiel, Momentchen mal, den Axel-Springer-Preis? Was soll das? Also das ist ja total Banane, sinnlos. Nee, ich habe eine bessere Idee. Wer hatte doch mal in Deutschland diesen Publizisten, der sich die ganze Zeit so wie ich die Frage nach der Macht gestellt hat? Wer hat eigentlich die Fäden meines Lebens in der Hand? Und wir kennen die Publikationsgeschichte von Schörmacher Minimum, die Abarbeitung am Silicon Valley bis hin zu Ego und so weiter. Und dann hatte ich gedacht, nee, ich will die maximale Demütigung von jemanden, der mich eigentlich durchschaut hat. Ich will jetzt noch mal auf dem Grab von Schörmacher tanzen. Ich möchte den Schörmacher-Preis, also so zu döpfen. Naja, ich will den Schörmacher-Preis. Und als Laudator will ich Sebastian Kurz.
Ja.
So im Sinne von...
Denn wir kennen uns aus San Francisco, sage ich jetzt mal.
Also es ist so ein, wie soll man sagen, es geht los mit Paypal. Paypal und Elon Musk. Elon Musk muss sich demütigen. Ebay kauft uns, Ebay muss sich demütigen. Das amerikanische Militär, ich zeige dir erstmal, wo der Hammer hängt und demütige sie im Sinne von baut keine eigene Technik auf, ich beliefe euch und so. Also dieses Demütigungs, die Studenten haben mich damals gehänselt, ich muss sie zurück demütigen. Und ich vermute einfach hier so dieses, auch dieses Peter Thiel hat sich selber, Sebastian Kurz aus Laudator ausgesucht, dass er einfach im Vorfeld dieses Döpfner, wenn du mit mir trocken willst, gib mir einen Schirmmacherpreis. Ja, und dass es einfach so dazu kam, ist natürlich...
Also Döpfner ist beim Schirmmacherpreis im Gremium oder kann da einfach auch mal über... Es ist Döpfners Ding, da sitzt da ein Telefonat, mal sagen, hallo, ich hab jetzt schon mir überlegt, wer wird diesmal auszeichnen. Und dann sagen die, die da in irgendeiner Jury oder in einem Gremium sitzen, ja ja, tolle Idee.
Döpfner dreht dieses große Rad mit, wenn er irgendwie zu Kaube geht und sagt, ich hab mir, also wollen wir nicht dem Thiel den Preis geben. Kaube hat null Ahnung von irgendwas von dem. Null. Der interessiert sich für sein, was hat Liegel damals nochmal gesagt, wie können wir das heute deuten und so. Und hier hat sich einfach Döpfner durchgesetzt. Man kann sich die Videos hier angucken, wie Thiel da den Preis entgegennimmt und Döpfner so in der ersten Reihe sitzt und man genau sieht, geil, gleich habe ich ein Mittagessen mit ihm und so. Das sind ja die Sachen, an denen Döpfner sich so aufgeilt. Wenn du deine Milliarde hast, dann willst du halt eine Stunde mit Peter Thiel.
Ja.
Und dann ergibt sich das halt so. Also es ist aber nur Spekulation von mir. Ich will es ausdrücklich sagen. So stelle ich mir das ungefähr vor. Es ist natürlich. Das ist für sehr schlüssig, ja.
Nach dem, was man hier gelesen hat, kann man das gut verstehen, ja.
Es ist wirklich sehr dramatisch, dass dieser Tage Christian Wulf, unser ehemaliger Bundespräsident, bei Gregor Gysi auf der Bühne sitzt und sagt, ich wurde von Mächten, die ich nicht durchschaut habe, aus dem Amt geworfen. Jetzt ergibt sich aber so langsam bei mir ein Bild. Es waren Schirmacher, Döpfner. Und man kann ja jetzt an diesem Reis für Peter Thiel sehen, dass das alles so eine Gang ist. Ah, Peter Thiel event? Jaja, in dieser Art von Verschwörungsdenker steckt ja jetzt auch Christian Wulf. Wenn er darüber nachdenkt, ich stehe auf der Bühne und sage als Bundespräsident, der Islam gehört auch zu Deutschland. Und das ist die Lektion, die mir deswegen erteilt wurde.
Bei Peter Thiel, den Islam hasst.
Bei Peter Thiel, den Islam hasst er.
Es ist interessant und wie gesagt, wir haben viel über Verschwörungstheorien gesprochen. Diese sind gefährlich und so weiter. Aber wir dürfen auch nicht vergessen, es gibt auch Verschwörungen. Wir haben ja diesen Titel, ich habe ihn genannt, Conspiracy von Ryan Holiday über Gorka und Peter Thiel. Und auch hier geht es viel um reale existierende Verschwörungen. Also auch insofern ein hochinteressantes Buch. Und nochmal ganz deutliche Lese- empfehlung von uns.
Ja, müsst ihr euch unbedingt holen.
Max Chafkin hat eine herausragende Biografie über Peter Thiel verfasst, die viel mehr ist als nur eine Biografie einer Person. Es ist auch eine Studie zum Silicon Valley, die man gelesen haben muss, um für die Zukunft gerüstet zu sein. Und um zu sehen, einige Verschwörungen sind real, sind brandgefährlich, vor allem für die Zukunft der Demokratie.
Ja, und wenn ihr enttäuscht vom Kino seid, weil euch Matrix nicht das liefert, was ihr gerne über die Welt wissen wollt, dann lest doch solche Bücher wie das von Chafkin, dass sich an einem kleinen elementaren Punkt, nämlich einer Biografie, der von Peter Thiel aufhängt, und darüber hinaus nicht nur versucht, alles zu erklären, sondern das Puzzle auf eine Art und Weise bis fast hin zur Vervollständigung zusammensetzt, dass einem wirklich manchmal der Atem stockt. Also lest dieses Buch.
Kommen wir nicht zu etwas Erfreulichem, aber kommen wir immerhin zu etwas mehr Kultur. Es gab auf der Seite Nachtkritik eine Kolumne von Michael Wolf, eine Kolumne, die ich recht häufig lese. Und diesmal setzt sich Michael Wolf mit der freien Szene auseinander. Also wir haben ja in Deutschland diese wunderbare Institution Stadttheater. Diese Stadttheater Struktur ist einmalig. Man überlegt ja auch, sollte das Weltkulturerbe werden. Dort am Stadttheater gibt es selbstverständlich auch Neu-Aufführungen, neue Regisseure, aber auch sehr viel Kanonpflege. Und abseits dieser Stadttheater und Staatstheater Struktur gibt es noch die freie Theater Szene. Die ist nicht ganz frei, also irgendwie muss die sich ja auch finanzieren. Das geht auch nicht rein über Eintrittsgelder. Selbstverständlich kann man eigentlich kaum was machen über Eintrittsgelder, nur es sei denn, sie sei nur renthoch. Und deswegen gibt es da verschiedene Förderungen oder Festivals. Irgendwie wird versucht, also diese freie Szene zu unterstützen. Das ist sehr häufig sehr prekär. Aber mitunter kann man da Interessantes sehen, aber immer weniger. Und was jetzt hier diagnostiziert wird für die freie Szene, das kann man, glaube ich, auch ganz gut auf vieles im Stadttheater übertragen oder generell über das, was heute von Kunst erwartet wird. Du wirst es vielleicht bestätigen können. Du hast ja, glaube ich, einen guten Überblick, weil du alle Kulturzeitsendungen und Aspekte und all das, die ja für den Fernsehpodcast immer wieder ansiehst, um einmal im Monat dich damit auseinanderzusetzen. Ich bewundere das, dass du das aushältst, denn wir finden da doch sehr wenig Kunst inzwischen, sondern ganz viel Politik. Und das ist auch eine Diagnose von Michael Wolff. Er sagt, der freien Szene fiel es an Format. So ist die Kolumne überschrieben und beginnt dann so. Letzte Woche las ich den Bericht meines Kollegen Falk Schreiber über das Hamburger Nordwind Festival. Zur Eröffnung erzählte ein nackter Andreas Constitant Niau davon, wie sein verstorbener Vater unter der Homosexualität des Sohns gelitten habe. Später feierte Mabel Preach mit und mit Freunde und für Freunde eine Art intersektionale Dragparty. Vom einstigen Skandinavien Schwerpunkt ist das Festival inzwischen abgerückt. Mittlerweile habe es die klassischen Kampnagel-Themen, also Kampnagel ist ein weiterer wichtiger Hotspot für Freiszenen, die klassischen Kampnagel-Themen verinnerlicht. Postmigration, Postkolonialismus, Queerness. Die Genese des Festivals scheint mir exemplarisch für eine Tendenz in der freien Szene. Früher stand der Begriff für das formale Experiment. Also man stellte da erstmal das Theater an sich in Frage in der freien Szene. Was repräsentieren wir bzw. was ist überhaupt Theater? Wann beginnt Theater? Beginnt das wirklich erst dann, wenn der Vorhang sich öffnet, Schauspieler die Bühne betreten? Beginnt das nicht schon viel früher? Inwieweit spielt das Publikum auch Theater? All das war etwas, wogegen man polemisierte, man versuchte, sich mit ästhetischen Mitteln abzugrenzen vom Stadttheater. Es heißt dann hier in der Kolumne, was eine Bühne, was ein Stück und was Spiel war, schien den sich selbst stolz als frei bezeichnenden Künstlern noch gar nicht ausgemacht. Und in eben dieser Verhandlung fanden sie ihre dringlichste Aufgabe. Das heißt, man verhandelte mit formalen Mitteln Formthemen und wurde so, sagten Wolf auch zum Innovations-Treiber. Das heißt, viele Leute aus der freien Szene sind dann später zum Stadttheater gegangen oder die Stadttheaterintendanten guckten, was passierte eigentlich? Oh, wir können auch nicht mehr so spielen wie vor zehn Jahren. Man denkt ja heute über Bühne und all das nochmal völlig neu nach. Aber diese formalen Experimente, sagt Wolf, die verschwinden mehr und mehr. Und jetzt stehen nur noch Themen da. Neuerdings kommt dann noch zu den genannten, die Ökologie hinzu. Er schreibt die neuen Rebellen, ich würde sagen, das sind eher Konformisten, weil sie gerade sehen, ach, diese Themen funktionieren gut, macht sich auch gut auf Anträgen. Diese neuen Rebellen wollen die Bühne nicht immer wieder einreißen und neu bauen. Sie nehmen sie stattdessen selbstverständlich als gegeben, wollen lediglich andere Themen und Identitäten ins Scheinwerferlicht rücken. Avanciert zu sein, bedeutet also in erster Linie politisches und soziales Engagement zu zeigen. Und ich glaube, das sehen wir auch sehr deutlich an der Kulturberichterstattung dann bei Kulturzeit, dass es immer geht, dieser Film ist ein flammendes Plädoyer für die Befreiung der Frau. Dieser Film verhandelt Homophobie in einer Weise, die uns zu denken geben sollte. Also es sind ja dann auch immer so eine phrasenhafte Berichterstattung, womit dann mitunter auch das eine oder andere große Kunstwerk, das dann da entsteht, so klein gemacht wird. Also als ich dann zum Beispiel diesen Beitrag über Jane Campion gesehen habe, über diesen Film The Power of the Dog, dachte ich, ja, natürlich kann ich jetzt einfach sagen, dies ist ein wichtiger Film über unterdrückte Homosexualität. Aber das ist so, als würde ich sagen, Kafka liefert mit seinem Werk eine beeindruckende Krankenakte über sein Verhältnis zu sich und seinem Vater.
Ja, aber wenn man Cumberbatch noch nie so gesehen hat, muss man das doch sagen, dass man ihn noch nie so gesehen hat.
Genau, also das, das ist, es muss, es muss über das Ästhetische gehen. Es muss wirklich auch das in den Mittelpunkt gestellt werden, beziehungsweise muss man schauen, ja, aber wovon handelt das eigentlich noch, außer jetzt das immer so auf diese drei, vier Nenner zu bringen, die jetzt, wie so Basswords die ganze Zeit in Förderanträgen vorkommen oder die jetzt gerade Vogue sind. Also das ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut und ich glaube, dass es total richtig ist, dass wir es eigentlich mit einem Diskurs über Kunst zu tun haben, der nicht mehr die Kunst primär an den Mittelpunkt stellt, sondern nur noch fragt, welche Themen werden dann da verhandelt und das Wie, das ist dann nicht mehr so wichtig. Das ist etwas, was Wolf hier in der Kolumne zu Recht anklagt und er sagt auch, dass das etwas ganz wichtiges für die gesamte Theaterlandschaft ist, dass in der freien Szene diese frischen Impulse in formaler Hinsicht kamen und dass es nicht nur um die Verhandlung von Themen geht oder marginalen Identitäten. Das hat ja alles seine Berechtigung, aber wenn es dann auf Kosten der Form geht und das passiert immer häufiger, ist und so schreibt er es dann auch, dass ein großer Verlust und gäbe die freie Szene diese Agenda auf, würde sie nur noch Themen abarbeiten, statt neue Formen zu erarbeiten. Und das ist eine große Gefahr, die ich sehe und die auch glaube ich jetzt sehr en vogue ist bei den jungen Absolventen. Also mir erzählte ein Regisseur, der tatsächlich sehr stark auch postmigrantisches Theater macht und so. Also der jetzt keineswegs, also ich zitiere jetzt hier nicht einen Menschen, der 80 Jahre alt ist und sagt, wir hätten gerne wieder Theater, wie Klaus Maria Brandauer das immer gemacht hat, sondern wir haben hier also einen jungen Menschen, der mir sagte, ja, es ist mitunter komisch, wenn man dann mal ein Stück aus dem 19. Jahrhundert machen will, dann gibt es dann Schauspieler, die sagen, nee, also das spiele ich nicht in dem Stück, da in diesem russischen Stück, da kommen ja Lakaien vor. Ich repräsentiere jetzt nicht eine Ständegesellschaft auf der Bühne und ich dachte, wie, wie das sagen wir, aber es sind doch Schauspieler und das ist doch eine Bühne. Und da muss gerade das doch verhandelt werden und so. Dann sagt er, nee, das sind Irrsinn, Diskussionen, die man da führen muss, gerade weil alle nur noch auf diese Themen dann sind. Und natürlich wird man bei Tschechow nicht allzu viele LGBT Themen verhandelt finden, es sei denn, man deent das Stück sehr. Aber deswegen hat das Stück ja trotzdem seine Berechtigung, beziehungsweise kann man ja über die Form mal fragen, was da eigentlich für eine innovative Kraft immer noch drin liegt oder so. Aber das findet ganz wenig statt. Also ein kleiner Text, der vielleicht mal so einen kleinen Piksadersetz, ganz gut, dass er bei Nachtkritik erschienen ist, weil da doch tatsächlich das, was hier beschrieben wird, auch sehr dominant ist. Und ich hoffe, dass wir nochmal wieder eine andere Debatte über Kunst bekommen, die nicht nur darauf aus ist zu suchen, ob alle Diversity-Regeln oder so erfüllt werden. Das ist nicht das, woran man Kunst allein messen kann.
Ich lese dir jetzt einen Tweet vor, der an diesem 6. Januar, wo wir miteinander zusammensitzen, drei Minuten alt ist, 12.24 Uhr vom Tagesspiegel. Schauspielerin Emma Watson erregt mit einem Post auf Instagram Aufsehen und wird als Antisemitin bezeichnet. Eine Diskussion über Solidarität entbrennt im Netz. Dann sehe ich ein Bild von Emma Watson, also Hermine, und unten drunter noch mal angeteasert. tagesspiegel.de, Emma Watson wird Antisemitismus vorgeworfen. Jetzt können wir uns natürlich alle fragen, ist Emma Watson eine Antisemitin? Wenn ja, kann man das von einem, was weiß ich, auch immer, was ihr da misslungen ist, oder was auch immer Gegenstand dieser Berichterstattung ist, die wir nicht kennen. Wir kennen nur diesen Tweet. Müssen wir uns jetzt damit beschäftigen. Dein Text zeigt ja schon, nee, also vom Müssen sind wir hier ganz weit weg. Aber man macht es trotzdem irgendwie. Und es zieht seine Kreise und schlägt wieder zurück auf den Kunstgegenstand und das Kunstmachen selbst. Und dann passiert, was ebenso passiert in dieser rezeptionssüchtigen Welt.
Und alle sind ja glücklich, wenn man sowas hat. Also die Gegner von Emma Watson wie die Befürworter. Denn man hat endlich wieder einen Anlass, um sich nicht mit einem Werk auseinanderzusetzen. Also man müsste ja sonst tatsächlich die Kunst rezipieren, müsste zum Beispiel mal nachdenken, ist sie wirklich eine gute Schauspielerin? Ich zum Beispiel hätte da jetzt gewisse Zweifel. Also ich finde sie nicht so genial. Da gibt es einige andere in ihrer Generation, die mich wesentlich mehr beeindrucken. Aber da müsste man sich ja jetzt mit schauspielerischen Leistungen auseinandersetzen. Man müsste sich mit Werken auseinandersetzen. Und so kann man natürlich immer wieder nur auf die Personen gehen, auf irgendwelche politischen Meinungen und muss sich nicht mit der Kunst auseinandersetzen. Also es ist so was fast entlastendes, das in diesem Diskurs steckt. Und das beobachte ich auch bei vielen Kulturberichterstattungen. Insofern ja, vielleicht mal wieder ein bisschen das Formale schärfen und auch dafür ein Auge bekommen. Dazu müssen natürlich auch die Zugänge da sein zu Theater und Co. Das heißt, wir dürfen da auf keinen Fall wieder einen Lockdown haben.
Das dramatischste Ereignis dieses laufenden Jahrtausends für den Journalismus, das reingeschlagen hat, wie man vorher nicht vermutete, dass es so krasse negative Wirkungen hat für die ganze Branche, ökonomisch und intellektuell, war die Abwahl von Donald Trump. Ja, darunter leidet das Mediengemache seitdem und wird auch noch lange darunter leiden. Aber es steht ja zu vermuten, dass er wieder gewählt wird. Und das wäre dann ein noch größerer Triumph für den Journalismus als die erste Wahl von Donald Trump. Um es mal ganz gemein auf den Punkt zu bringen.
Du gehst also davon aus oder du siehst eine?
Siehst du uns schon immer wieder in dieser Diskussion.
In deiner kurzen? Ja, ich will das mal so sagen. Ich erinnere mich ja noch ganz gut, ich vergesse ja leider nichts. Und ich erinnere mich noch ganz gut, als wir im November oder Dezember hier, glaube ich sogar im Salon über Trump ganz kurz sprachen, also nur einfach festgestellt haben, okay, es wird jetzt Biden und wir ein bisschen spekulierten, was wird jetzt mit Trump? Und ich habe gesagt, na ja, vielleicht macht er noch mal eine Fernsehsendung oder irgendwie sowas. Und du hast gesagt, ich hoffe, verschwindet einfach, wir werden nichts mehr sehen. Jetzt sagst du aber nein, es könnte sein, dass.
Ich habe hier gerade nur rezipiert und verbal aufgegriffen, was der Journalismus so diskutiert. Okay, wenn du mich nach meiner Meinung fragst, sage ich dir 2024 wird keiner von beiden die amerikanische Präsidentschaft gewinnen, selbst wenn sie antreten. Der erste Name ist Michelle Obama, der zweite Name ist Donald Trump. Wird nicht passieren.
Also diese beiden werden nicht?
Nein. Und ich vermute nicht mal, dass Donald Trump antritt. Auch wenn ich schon wieder spüre in meinem Nacken und nachher werden Kommentare kommen, wie mir alle Texte zeigen, Donald Trump nimmt Anlauf. Der hat Iowa ist der erste Bundesstaat, wo man sozusagen den medialen Aufschlag machen muss. Alles schon vorbereitet, da arbeiten schon 100 Leute. Die bereiten das Feld vor. Donald Trump nimmt Anlauf. Das ist nicht umsonst jetzt mit Bill O'Reilly auf der Bühne und so weiter und so fort. Ich will lieber noch eine andere Geschichte erzählen. Die Freie Theater Szene war mir auch sehr gewogen, denn ich war früher ein großer Theaterfan, war in jedem Theaterstück, das in Jena von der Reinhold Greber Gang und so weiter gespielt wurde. Aha, ja. Und dann wurde ich Student und dann berufstätig und dann Vater und jetzt gehe ich nicht mal mehr ins Kino. Außer wenn Batman kommt und ich habe damals versucht, in der FAZ eine Rezension über ein Theaterstück aus der Freien Szene zu schreiben. Ich habe im Vorfeld hunderte Texte in der Zeitung völlig problemlos einfach platziert, indem ich gesagt habe, ist fertig. Lag dann manchmal noch ein bisschen, aber wurde dann trotzdem gedruckt. In der Wirtschaftsredaktion klappte das immer, rein mein, klappte immer, für Tor sowieso. Durfte ich ja sogar Seite eins mitschreiben. Dann gehe ich zu Stadelmeier und sage, ich habe hier einen Text übers Theater.
Oh Gott.
Ungelesen, sagte er mir, freie Szene machen wir nicht. Ja, ja, ja. Damit war das erledigt. Ja. Und ja, man kann das, also den mangelt es nicht nur an Geld, sondern auch an Aufmerksamkeit. Und leider nichts geworden. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, klar, Stadelmayr war nicht mal drangelegen, an den ökonomischen Zusammenhängen des regulären Theaters irgendwas darüber auch nur ein Wort zu verlieren. Für ihn stand nur das Stück im Mittelpunkt. Zugestandenerweise richtig so, aber es sind halt nicht mehr die 60er, 70er, 80er Jahre, sondern es war schon diesseits der Jahrtausendwende, wo das einfach zwingend auch dazugehört. In der Zeitung, wo damals schon klar war, Literatur schön und gut, aber das literarische Leben, darüber müsst ihr schreiben. Und das war beim Theater nicht möglich.
Interessant, ja.
Na ja, gute alte Zeit. Kommen wir zur neuen Zeit. Die ist natürlich gruselig und wir blicken wieder nach China. Zwei Texte aus der New York Times, die mich da auch sehr beschäftigt haben. In diesem großen Strom der New York Times Texte natürlich einfach so untergehen. Aber zum einen ein digitaler Manhunt, also eine digitale Menschenjagd, wie die chinesische Polizei Kritiker auch außerhalb Chinas trackt, und zwar Twitter und Facebook. Jennifer Chen ist die Protagonistin dieses Stücks von Mui Xiaow und Paul Moussour. Paul Moussour schreibt wohl häufiger über China, der nächste Text ist auch von ihm. Und die schreiben über Jennifer Chen, die nämlich im Ausland arbeitet in Amerika und dort auch Twitter benutzt, hat so 100 Follower, spielt eigentlich kaum eine Rolle. Plötzlich kriegt sie einen Anruf von ihren Eltern. Hör mal zu, die Polizei war hier und ihre Eltern leben noch in China. Die haben gesagt, lösch mal deinen Account und dann kannst du es für uns machen. Also löscht sie ihren Account. Sie studiert im Ausland. Und die New York Times nimmt das zum Anlass, um zu sagen, Jennifer Chen ist hier nur Schiff. Das chinesische Internet Dragnet wird mittlerweile global ausgeworfen. Die ganze Welt ist davon betroffen. Und es geht nicht mehr nur um chinesische Dienste. Und es sind auch nicht mehr nur Chinesen in China, die hier Ziel sind, sondern schon ausländische Dienste sowieso. Wird alles mitbeobachtet. Und dann Chinesen im Ausland. Also Chinesen, die im Ausland Twitter benutzen, jenseits der Firewall, die der da in China haben, sind jetzt trotzdem dran. Die chinesische Regierung guckt genau zu. Und das ist dann auch entweder einreiserelevant, wenn man mal zurückkommen will, oder für die Familie, die einfach zurückgeblieben ist. Die New York Times wertet hier Dokumente aus und hat mit sechs Betroffenen gesprochen. In einem Fall besucht die chinesische Polizei eine Familie und sagt zu dem Herren des Hauses, ruf mal deinen Sohn in Australien an, jetzt, und gib mir dann das Telefon. Der Sohnemann in Australien geht also ans Telefon, denkt, er ist in so einem normalen Videocall mit seinem Vater, wie jeden Freitag. Plötzlich sagt der Vater, ich geb dich mal weiter, und dann blickt er, und da gibt es ein Video von, auf der Seite kann man das sehen, blickt er einfach in das Gesicht eines Polizisten, der ihm einfach sagt, also das sind jetzt die Maßregelungen, und bitte halte dich dran. Das sind natürlich irgendwie dann doch gruselige Vorstellungen. Wenn man sich vorstellt, und das gilt auch hier schon in Deutschland so, dass sich chinesische Studenten in deutschen Hörsaalen nicht sicher sein können, wenn sie eine Frage stellen an den Professor, wer diese Frage noch hört in diesem Moment und davon eine Notiz an die chinesischen Behörden weitergibt. Also mittlerweile große globale Verstrickung. Die US-Regierung war immer dran gelegen, das Software einer gewissen Exportkontrolle zu unterlegen, damit sie nicht in China missbraucht wird. Das hat natürlich in den Händen der falschen Regierung, es hat schon in den Händen der richtigen Regierung schlechte Folgen, aber in den Händen der bösen Regierungen natürlich umso mehr. Nun braucht die chinesische Regierung diese Software nicht mehr. Sie haben da eigene, aber sie brauchen die vor allem westlichen amerikanischen Netzwerke, die natürlich auch amerikanische sind, auch missbraucht werden, aber nicht im gleichen Maße reglementiert werden können, wie einfach ein Software-Export. Da kann man die Unternehmen einfach verbieten, darf da nicht verkauft werden. Und wenn die das da benutzen, dann sehen wir das hier schon und dann werdet ihr bestraft. Sondern es gibt halt einfach Twitter in China, solange die Chinesen das nicht vor der Regierung, vor den Bevölkerungen verbergen. Aber es gibt da einfach Twitter, kann man da nutzen, einsehen und so weiter. Sie haben dann hier noch einen Aktivisten, den sie vorstellen, Yaxue Zhao, der mit seiner Organisation chinachange.org, das so ein bisschen beobachtet, was da vor sich geht. Und mittlerweile ist es wohl so, dass die amerikanischen Behörden nicht mehr hinterherkommen, zu tracken, wie die chinesischen Behörden in Amerika tätig sind, weil irgendwelche kleinen Softwarebooten, die eigentlich nur so Marketing-Auswertungssoftware für irgendwie, was weiß ich, wie funktioniert dein Brand auf Facebook oder so, die bekommen mittlerweile einfach so mal so ein Angebot. Also da ruft so ein chinesischer Polizist an und sagt, 1500 Dollar, wenn ihr uns den und den Account mal kurz nachverfolgt lasst, wie läuft er so in den Trends und so weiter und so fort. Und ja, diese Softwarebooten gehen das natürlich ein. Es wird ihnen sogar verschleiert, was da eigentlich dahinter steckt. Aber dass die chinesische Regierung mittlerweile 1500 Dollar pro Fall an irgendwelche Behörden oder Marketing-Agenturen in Amerika bezahlt, damit die irgendwelche 100-Follower-Accounts für die mal durchanalysieren und die soziale Landkarte da aufschlüsseln, das sind natürlich, man hat sich ja immer gedacht, die chinesische Regierung, irgendwann wird das zu komplex. Das Internet wird einfach zu groß. So viel Männer haben die da gar nicht und Frauen, um das alles aufzuarbeiten und dem hinterher zu gehen. Aber nee, stellt sich raus, die chinesische Regierung geht mittlerweile jedem einzelnen Account hinterher. Es sind nicht mehr nur die Superspitzen, die man da abgreift im Sinne von, wenn wir den Fisch aus dem Wasser ziehen, dann gehen auch die Beischwimmer weg. Nee, man sucht sich jetzt jeden einzelnen, zieht den da aus dem Verkehr. Und es ist vor allem eine große Angsttaktik. Die Chinesen im Ausland sollen wissen, deine Familie ist noch hier und wir wissen, wo sie wohnt. Also das sind natürlich Entwicklungen, von denen die New York Times sagt, das ist jetzt neu. Das sind die letzten ein, zwei Jahre, in denen selbst mit Pandemiebewältigung und so weiter, die chinesischen Behörden immer noch genug Kapazität hatten, solche Stunts hier vorzuführen.
Das ist ja erstaunlich, welche Manpower man dafür braucht, um das durchzusetzen. Und die Idee kann natürlich sein, wir machen das jetzt eine Weile, um so abschreckend zu wirken, dass wir das irgendwann nicht mehr brauchen, sondern dass ein jeder, der im Ausland sich befindet, es so internalisiert hat, dass er die ganze Zeit in so einer Big Brother Blase lebt, dass er immer weiß, der Staat sieht mich, wo immer ich bin. Und dann braucht man irgendwann auch niemanden mehr. Also dann hat man so ein Panoptikum errichtet, das dann gar keinen Aufseher mehr am Ende hat, weil jeder denkt, naja, ich werde jetzt aber wirklich doch gerade beschattet, oder?
Also die Panoptikumsidee, gerade auch, da wir wissen, wie die Amerikaner mit dem Internet umgehen, nämlich erst mal alles wegspeichern und es im Nachhinein als Zeitmaschine dann aufschlüsseln zu können. Also man muss gar nicht jetzt live erfahren, was passiert. Der Hauptsache, man kann später noch mal nachschauen. Das ist auf jeden Fall gegeben in China, da wird ja alles wegspeichern. Also die Gefahren sind hier riesig. Und im zweiten Text, auch wieder von Paul Massour, diesmal mit Raymond Zong und Aaron Krolik, gehen sie den Influencer nach. Li and oil Barrett machen eine Reise durch China. Und die sieht ungewöhnlich gut aus auf Instagram. Diese Reise, die sehen nur diese Hotspots, beste Lagen und so. Und die fragen sich, was ist denn da los? Also diese Videos, die mit dieser YouTube-artigen, typischen Leichtigkeit daherkommen, würde man die Kamera mal umdrehen, würde man sehen dahinter stehen ein ganz schön großer Regierungsapparat. Und vor allem kontrollierte Medienhäuser, die das mit organisieren. Wo geht die Reise hin? Mit welcher Technik wird aufgenommen? Und so weiter und so fort. Es gibt also pro Beijing Influencers, die von den staatlichen Medienhäusern finanziert und organisiert werden. Das zum einen im Ausland. Also man sucht sich gezielt westliche Influencer, die dann mal eine schöne China-Reise machen können. Oder natürlich nimmt man die Chinesen selbst im Ausland oder auch Chinesen in China. Denn und hier schlägt die chinesische Regierung einfach alles mit den eigenen Mitteln. Man muss es ja nicht nur für Geld machen. Man kann es ja auch mit Reichweite machen. Und wenn eine Regierung in der Lage ist, dir anzubieten, also wenn du jetzt diese zwei Videos machst für uns, dann senden wir den nächsten zehn Videos, die du machst, einfach mal zwei Millionen Klicks pro Version. Dann kann man das Angebot durchaus annehmen. Denn die chinesische Regierung kann ja, da sie Zugriff hat auf Newsfeeds der eigenen Social Media Kanäle, die man da so betreibt oder zumindest mit organisiert, einfach mal diese Art von Publikums Bewegung steuern. Also wer in China das Reichweiten Spiel besonders erfolgreich absolvieren möchte, weiß, er muss besonders explizit regierungsfreundlichen Ton anschlagen und dann ergibt sich das von ganz alleine. Und so passiert es dann, dass der eine oder andere Influencer, der sich da besonders hervortut, dann auch mal machen darf, was normale Journalisten nicht können. So ist zum Beispiel Rass Galore einfach mal nach Jingjiang gefahren. Also diese Region, die wir kennen. Da werden die Uiguren hunderttausendfach und so weiter interniert. Er fährt dann da so durch und hält das alles fest mit seiner kleinen Kamera und zeigt zum Beispiel. Also hier auf den Feldern ist gar nichts los. Hier wird ganz normal gearbeitet. Das sind, Zitat, nette Leute, die ihre Arbeit machen und ihr Leben leben. Zitat Ende. Das ist dann so Inhalt. Und gibt es da eine strukturelle Dimension? Joshua Lam und Libby Lang sind Forscher an der Yale-Universität, die sich das mal genau angeschaut haben. Die 390.000 Tweets, die Jingyang thematisieren, also diese Region. Von denen sind, wenn man sich die sechs der zehn am häufigsten geteilten YouTube Videos anschaut, die über diese Tweets geteilt werden. Also die erfolgreichsten Tweets, die YouTube Videos verteilen mit entsprechender Thematisierung. Sie kommen von Pro-China-Influencers. Also die Spitze der Thematisierungen der kritischen Weltregionen wird mittlerweile von der chinesischen Regierung inhaltlich entweder gesteuert oder in einem gewissen Rahmen mitbetreut. Und dann hat man natürlich auch mal bei Google angefragt. Also ihr betreibt ja YouTube und so. Kann man da irgendwas machen? Und YouTube hat das Problem erst mal runter gespielt. Man wollte es noch nicht, nicht in diesem ersten Aufschlag, als man sich hier konfrontiert sah mit dem Problem, es irgendwie thematisieren. Der Text ist interessant. Den könnt ihr ruhig mal anklicken, denn da wird in Bewegt Bild werden da Beispiele gezeigt, wie Leute, von denen man nun wirklich nicht denkt, hey, was hast denn du mit China zu tun? Plötzlich so ein Loblied auf China singen. Also, anstimmen, dass es ist.
Länder machen Werbung und machen das über die Influencer. Wir können das auch sehen in dieser Arte-Doku, die man bei YouTube sich ansehen kann, über Marmor. Da geht es über die Marmor-Importe von China. Die importieren also Marmor aus Griechenland. Und da spielen auch Influencer eine wichtige Rolle, die dann sagen, hier das griechische Ideal, wir bringen es nach Hause und so weiter und so fort. Und wir können es auch in anderen Ländern erleben, dass zum Beispiel Indien, Pakistan und so weiter westliche Influencer einlädt, um dann in das Land zu reisen, um dort mit dem Militär zu posen und so weiter und so fort. Und dann denkt man auch dann so ein Parfüm-Influencer, wie dieser Fragrance oder wie der heißt, der macht dann auch plötzlich mit dem Militär da Fotos und findet das irgendwie auch alles ganz cool. Und der sitzt dann auch noch mal irgendwie am nächsten Abend bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen. Das untermalt ja dann auch noch mal die Seriosität. Und das ist also jetzt ein Trip, auf dem sehr viele Länder sind. Die arabischen Emirate und so haben es eigentlich schon vorgemacht. Die haben das sehr früh begriffen. Und jetzt sieht man, wie all diese anderen Länder nachziehen. Und ich würde mal sagen, gerade diese autoritären Staaten sind dann auch bereit, tief in die Tasche zu greifen. Und die Influencer sagen sich wiederum, Geld stinkt nicht. Und plötzlich bekommt man da politische Inhalte angezeigt, die aber immer so als Lifestyle verkauft werden. Und überall doch nette Leute. Und man muss es einfach mal selbst erleben. Also das ist, glaube ich, auch ein ganz wichtiges Narrativ, dass man auch hier noch mal so tut. Und naja, also klar, man hört ja auch viel Schlimmes so über China und den Umgang mit den Uiguren. Aber ich war jetzt mal da und waren doch eigentlich ganz nette Leute.
Keine gesehen.
Ja, keine. Das war alles in Ordnung.
Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, wie die finale Abrechnung mit Dubai in einem Jahr, also die ökonomische, abläuft. Die könnten sich da auch ein bisschen geschadet haben, glaube ich. Denn die Welle, die jetzt so gegen Dubai läuft, ist dann doch erstaunlich groß, muss ich sagen. Und wenn jetzt diese Katar-Berichterstattung usw. noch ein bisschen intensiviert wird durch die Fußball-WM, mal gucken, wie so Bilanzen dann über mittelfristige Zeit aussehen.
Es ist sehr gut, dass du diese Texte da gebracht hast, denn ich will zumindest den ersten jetzt in den Dialog bringen mit einem anderen Text, der in Foreign Affairs erschienen ist, verfasst von Perak Kenner, den wir schon kennen von dem Buch Move, und einem Co-Autor, der nennt sich Balai S. Srinivasan. Er ist Investor in Sachen Krypto. Und die haben einen Essay veröffentlicht mit dem Titel Great Protocol Politics. Und die sagen, naja, es gibt ja hier auch bei der Financial Times und so weiter, gibt es ja überall jetzt verschiedene Beiträge zu dem Thema Metaverse und und und. Und wie ist es denn jetzt eigentlich wirklich? Also wir müssen uns jetzt doch nochmal anders damit befassen. Und sie kommen erst mal zu dem Schluss. Das 21. Jahrhundert gehört nicht China oder den Vereinigten Staaten und auch nicht den Technologieunternehmen im herkömmlichen Sinne. Es gehört dem Internet. So jetzt wollen wir uns mal anschauen, was das bedeuten kann. Sie haben dann zehn Thesen, die ich jetzt mal in Kürze durchgehen will. Aber ich glaube, es ist schon wichtig, denn was du jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, ist ein starker Staat. China greift sogar in andere starke Staaten ein, wo sich gerade chinesische Bürger aufhalten. Also zum Beispiel Studenten in den USA. Die erste These der beiden lautet nun, Netznähe ist gleichwertig mit physischer Geografie. Es gibt ja in der geopolitischen Theorie verschiedene Schulen, zum Beispiel die McKinder Schule, die von dieser Heartland-Theorie ausgeht. Dass es also die Geografie ist, die wir als unser Schicksal annehmen müssen. Und dann denkt man danach, also welche Länder sind miteinander verbunden? Wie ist das mit Eurasien? Diese ganze Debatte bis hin zu Brzezinski, der das dann in 90er Jahren nochmal ausbuchstabiert. So, also das waren die geopolitischen Ideen, die eigentlich das 20. Jahrhundert prägten und auch noch im 21. Jahrhundert selbstverständlich präsent sind. Aber, sagen jetzt die Autoren, das Internet fügt dem eine neue Dimension hinzu. Jeder Bürger der alten Welt kann, sofern er über einen Internetzugang verfügt, ganz einfach ein Bürger der neuen Welt werden, indem er über seinen Bildschirm ein paar Stunden pro Tag in der Cloud verbringt, wie es Milliarden von Menschen routinemäßig tun. Eine physische Einwanderung ist nicht erforderlich. Das meinen sie würde durch Blockchain, Technologie und so weiter Metaverse noch sich verstärken, wodurch also das keine Rolle mehr spielt, wo wir eigentlich sind, wo ich immer schon mal sagen würde, na ja, wir müssen ja uns in irgendeiner Weise reproduzieren. Und damit meine ich jetzt, wir müssen zum Beispiel Nahrung kaufen, Verzehren, Kleidung kaufen, etc. Das tun wir schon an dem Ort, an dem wir wohnen. Und wir sind auch auf das Gesundheitssystem vor Ort angewiesen. Klar kann ich jetzt irgendwelche Medikamente aus dem Ausland kommen, aber wenn ich jetzt die Diagnose brauche, wenn ich eine Untersuchung, CT, was auch immer brauche, muss ich das vor Ort haben. Das heißt, wir haben hier einen Vorteil gegenüber Menschen, die in, sagen wir, Indonesien leben. Also das einfach so zu schreiben, als sei man da einfach in der Cloud und dann woanders, das stimmt nur zum Teil. Aber das ist erst mal so eine Prämisse, die hier gemacht wird. Und dann leiten sie über zum Thema Geld. Zweite These, nationale Währungen werden mit digitalem Geld konkurrieren. So, was heißt das jetzt? Also denken sie daran, was mit den Zeitungen passiert ist. Zuerst gingen sie alle online. Dann wurden sie alle von Google News indiziert. Schließlich stellten die Lokalzeitungen fest, dass ihre geografischen Monopole verschwunden waren, da es nicht mehr notwendig war, die Zeitungen per Lkw zu verteilen. Ein ähnliches Schicksal wird die nationalen Währungen ereilen. Schon jetzt konkurrieren nationale Währungen mit Kryptowährungen, weil Einzelpersonen und Institutionen digitale Geldbürsen mit verschiedenen Vermögenswerten besitzen, die gegeneinander gehandelt werden können. Und sie prognostizieren ein Zeitalter des globalen Währungswettbewerbs. Was sagst du dazu? Glaubst du, dass wir es tatsächlich mit einem Wettbewerb zu tun haben? Denn es ist ja nach wie vor so, auch wenn der Bitcoin da und dort mal eingeführt wird, auch in entsprechenden Ländern nicht hier. Und wenn auch damit hin und wieder Bezahlungen stattfinden, bleibt ja die Leitwährung der Dollar. Und der Dollar wird ja nicht abgelöst, sondern man hat so eine Komplementärwährung, in meinen Augen mehr für Spielereien. Aber es ist ja keineswegs so, dass wir da einen Wettbewerb haben. Das ist im Übrigen ein Konzept, das hier vorgestellt wird, das hier Hayek aufmacht. Er will ja so einen Währungswettbewerb haben und natürlich das Geld dem Staat entziehen. Wir sehen hier schon, wie nah wir wieder bei Peter Thiel sind.
Also, Peter Thiel ist klug, hat was mit Paypal gemacht, das heute wie Bitcoin aussieht und so weiter. Ihm war daran gelegen, das muss irgendwie funktionieren als Geld, darf nicht zurückfühlbar sein. Ich bin trotzdem, ich bleib der Überzeugung, der Klügste von allen ist Jeff Bezos. Denn wenn wir uns fragen, welche kommende Währung wird oder hat jetzt schon, ich will es mal richtig auf die Spitze treiben, welche Währung hat jetzt schon die reguläre staatliche Werbung verdrängt? Und zwar auch in Deutschland, auf deutschen Schulhöfen, in der Prostitution, da wo man sich Drogen kauft und so weiter. Es ist Überraschung der Amazon-Gutschein, den man nämlich einfach bei Rewe oder wo auch immer am Supermarkt einfach kauft. Man geht zur Kasse und tauscht Bargeld gegen einen Amazon-Gutschein. Dieser Amazon-Gutschein ist nicht trackbar, der hat einfach nur einen Wert. Niemand weiß, wer den gekauft hat, weil er wohl mit Bargeld bezahlt und so weiter. Du hast also in dem Moment, wo du einen Amazon-Gutschein kaufst, Bargeld in der Hand. Aber dieses Bargeld besteht aus einem Strichcode. Der kann genau einmal eingescannt werden. Oder abgetippt, je nachdem. Du kannst also einen 100-Euro-Schein, den du in einen Amazon-Gutschein verwandelt hast, anonymerweise an der Kasse, wie Bargeld verwenden, aber digital. Du kannst den also einfach fotografieren, an irgendwen senden. Der nutzt ihn dann, kriegt sofort bei Amazon 100 Euro Gut geschrieben. Damit ist der Wert übertragen. Und damit ist das größte Problem eines Transfers erledigt. Wir diskutieren in Deutschland gerade die Cannabis-Legalisierung, was im Grunde nur bedeutet, dass man Cannabis wieder mit Geld kaufen kann. Man muss nicht mehr mit Amazon-Gutschein kaufen. Das ist im Grunde das Ding dahinter. Wir haben längst eine Währung, die digital funktioniert, die Anonymität wirklich gewährleistet, die alles bietet, was man braucht, die keine Steuern abführt, weil die 100 Euro bleiben immer 100 Euro. Und du kannst bei Amazon alles dafür kaufen. Also ein Amazon-Gutschein ist allgemein...
Genau, das ist nicht wie früher. Da hat man ein Gut-Ted von irgendwo geschenkt bekommen und dachte, da kaufe ich ja gar nicht, was soll ich damit?
Das ist heute anders. Außer deine Miete kannst du alles mit einem Amazon-Gutschein bezahlen, was du brauchst. In der Ansicht sind diese ganzen Diskussionen über, ach, das Geld, da brauchen wir noch eine Mega-Idee, da brauchen wir eigentlich noch einen Blockchain und so weiter. Also wenn du solchen Texten so, wir müssen jetzt mal ans Morgen denken, weil das muss ganz schnell nach hier. Gleichzeitig hast du auf dem Schulhof schon die ganzen Typen, die sich anonymerweise das Geld einfach zuschieben oder es einfach digital transferieren, indem sie nämlich ein Foto von dem Strichcode machen, der dann einfach auf der Empfängersite abgezippt werden kann und sofort als Geld zur Verfügung steht, ohne Wertverlust, ohne alles, ohne Zeitverzug, alles schon gelöst. Jeff Bezos war es mal wieder.
Dritte These, die Fernwirtschaft hat einen Talentmarkt für Bürger geschaffen. Wir sind also hier am Move-Thema dran. Wir haben einen wettbewerbsorientierten Markt von Rechtsordnungen, schreiben sie, in dem jeder Ort überall sein kann und es gibt keine einzelne Regierung mehr, die so viel Autorität hat, wie jetzt die Menschen momentan glauben. Sie meinen, dass wir also jetzt mit diesem Metaverse eigentlich lauter Nomaden-Visa bekommen werden. Und damit hat die große Migration begonnen. Also wir können ja da dann sagen, so jetzt hier nach Taiwan oder dorthin, wo immer ich möchte. Auch das impliziert natürlich immer, was meint jetzt wirklich Migration hier. Also selbstverständlich ist es ja auch jetzt möglich, dass man von sonst wo aus ins deutsche Internet, im deutschen Internet sich was ansieht. Allerdings müssen wir ja da auch sehen. Es gibt ja entsprechende Firewalls. Es gibt ja entsprechende Dinge. Ich werde gleich noch was zum Thema Indien sagen. Da werden wir nochmal sehen, was das eigentlich bedeutet, dass man sich so frei als Bürger bewegen kann. Also du hast eben hier wieder den starken Start gezeigt. Sie sagen, nee, der Start wird jetzt unterminiert. Und das bedeutet dann auch, dass wir viertens so eine neue Herrschaft der Bits bekommen. Sie erwähnen dann Peter Thiel. Der hat gesagt, also die physischen Technologien, die stagnieren seit vielen Jahren. Da sagen sie, das hat sich jetzt nun geändert. Denken wir nur an die mRNA Impfstoffe. Und was sie jetzt diagnostizieren, ist eine Wiederbelebung der Innovation in der physischen Welt. Und sobald etwas online funktioniert, kann es aber dann überall ausgedruckt und schneller als je skaliert werden. Nun, theoretisch ist das natürlich möglich. Also 3D-Drucker und möglicherweise dann auch noch Impfungen werden uns ausgedruckt. Wir können das dann überall hin versenden. Aber was hier auch wieder ausgeblendet wird, ist natürlich, dass es da staatliche Regulierungen gibt, dass gerade der Staat eine wichtige Stütze ist, um so etwas wie Lizenzen, Patente zu schützen. Und es ist deshalb nicht so ganz frei, wie das hier gezeigt wird. Sie schreiben dann, eine Regierung, die das Digitale nicht versteht, ist möglicherweise nicht in der Lage, das Physische zu kontrollieren. Das glaube ich, das stimmt absolut. Aber die Frage ist dann, inwieweit sich der Staat dann in irgendeiner Weise auflöst, sondern einfach nur noch mal erweitern muss. Fünfte These, cloudbasierte Aufsichtsbehörden machen den staatlichen Aufsichtsbehörden Konkurrenz. Und zwar ist hier die Rede davon, dass wir zwar Regulierungen schon haben, also zum Beispiel US Food and Truck Administration, die waren aber mal gemacht, um zum Beispiel Pfizer zu regulieren. Aber nicht, schreiben die Autoren, um eine Million Bio Hacker zu regulieren. Nur die Frage, es gibt es diese eine Million Bio Hacker, die eine Million vielleicht nicht, aber es gibt schon einige. Und was wird sich dann in Web 3 entwickeln, was vom Staat nicht zu regulieren ist? Sie schreiben Krypto-Protokolle, ermöglichen Millionen aktiver Marktteilnehmer, sowohl Kunden als auch Produzenten, die Entwicklung dezentraler Regulierungsmechanismen, die sowohl die Gefahren staatlicher Regulierungsbehörden, als auch die der Selbstregulierung von Unternehmen vermeiden. Hier frage ich mich tatsächlich, also das ist ja diese Idee, dass wir durch diese Blockchain-Technologie selber kontrollieren, wir so eine Transparenz haben und dann nicht mehr das Unternehmen als Kontrollinstanz brauchen oder die Regierung. Metaverse wird ja, Matthew Ball schreibt das ja auch in seinem Essay ganz klar, von Anfang an extrem dominiert sein durch die Konzerne. Das heißt, hier wird eigentlich noch mal so ein Neuland imaginiert von den Autoren, das doch de facto in Metaverse nie existieren wird, weil da immer schon ganz viel vermachtet ist, um es mal so auszudrücken. Also halte ich auch für eine eigenartige These. Der Staat, so dann die sechste These, sei auch nicht länger der legitime Hüter des Privateigentums. Das finden wir ja bei Locke und Hobbes, solche Ideen und das spinnt sich ja dann vor. Sie zitieren dann Stalin, der fragte, wie viele Divisionen hat der Papst? Aber im Zeitalter der Verschlüsselung geht es nicht mehr darum, wie viele Divisionen ein Staat hat, um sein Eigentum zu verteidigen. Es geht darum, wie viele lange Divisionen er durchführen müsste, um ihr Eigentum zu beschlagnahmen. Ich glaube, was sie hier ansprechen, ist richtig. Nur finden wir, also wir brauchen dafür noch gar nicht, in die Metaverse zu gehen. Wie schwierig ist es denn für den Staat, Eigentum zu verteidigen, beziehungsweise Eigentum, also Anteile von dem Eigentum in Form von Steuern, sich einzuverleiben, wenn immer mehr Offshore passiert? Also was hier eigentlich als Paradies ausgemalt wird, ist ja nur eine Vergrößerung eigentlich dieses Offshore-Gedankens. Da sind wir auch schnell wieder bei Seastead und so weiter. Klar, durch das Digitale und wenn es so unreguliert ist, wie zum Beispiel auch Kryptowährungen, ergeben sich ganz neue Möglichkeiten, wie das Eigentum vor allem vor staatlichem Zugriff geschützt werden kann. Und das ist ja das, was gerade das globale Kapital besonders will, sich vor dem Staat schützen, viel mehr noch als vor irgendwelchen kriminellen Machenschaften.
Also das ist alles Ideologie, man muss es immer wieder ganz deutlich sagen. Vieles von dem, was du jetzt genannt hast, die Cloud, Bitcoin, wie auch immer, das Metaverse hängt davon ab, dass irgendwo ein Strom erzeugendes Kraftwerk arbeitet. Dazu kommt noch die ganze Server-Technologie, die auch nicht im luftleeren Raum, das muss alles angebunden sein. Noch dazu, und das haben wir bei Peter Thiel wieder gesehen, irgendwer braucht ein Militär, das einfach funktionstüchtig ist und irgendwer muss sichern, dass es ein Rechtssystem gibt für den Fall, dass man es braucht. Und die Entscheidungen müssen auch bindend sein, also sie müssen wirklich durchgesetzt werden können. Und dafür braucht man alles den Staat. Das sind kritische Infrastrukturen, das sind grundlegende Infrastrukturen. Das sind nicht nur ideelle Infrastrukturen, sondern das sind einfach wirklich substanzielle, was ein Richter sagt, stimmt. Denn ansonsten, wenn du das nicht akzeptierst, gehst du ins Gefängnis und da wird es kein Internet geben für dich. Also man braucht einfach ganz, ganz, ganz viel von diesem Zeug. Ich glaube, man bereitet hier einfach ein User-Land vor. Man macht so eine Art Landschaftspflege, wie so ein Gärtner. Der soll dich vergessen lassen, dass nur ein Meter unter deinem schönen Garten es gräucht und fleucht von Tieren, mit denen du nichts zu tun haben willst. Aber ohne diese ginge das alles nicht oben. Und so wird auch dieses Metaverse gestaltet. Das ist einfach User-Land. In Hollywood wurde das ja immer mal wieder aufgearbeitet. Ich habe zuletzt diesen einen 5-6 Jahre alten von Steven Spielberg, diesen Computerspiele-Film, wo sie auch alle in so einem Metaverse...
Ready Player geworden.
Richtig, der ist richtig gut. Den kann man sich da mal anschauen. Also ich finde ihn so als Idee, das mal durchzuspielen, richtig gut. Auch sehr unterhaltsam, wo die einfach ganz virtuos hin und her wechseln zwischen, ja ich lebe hier so in so einem Container, der so irgendwie, der hängt da so im fünften Stock, keine Ahnung, ob das noch lange hält, das Metall, aber funktioniert halt. Dann setze ich meine Brille auf und bin aber dann in dieser Metaverse Welt und so. Also wo dieser Wechsel wunderbar hin und her gezeigt wird. Und es gibt doch diesen Böckenförde Spruch, den immer alle bringen, die Demokratie kann ihre Grundlagen nicht selbst gewährleisten, Pi Pa Po. Das kann das Metaverse auch nicht. Das Metaverse ist total abhängig davon, dass in der physischen Welt ganz vieles ganz richtig funktioniert. Und sobald es da nur einen kleinen Getriebeschaden gibt, ist nichts. Also man kann sich nicht in Deutschland, kann man nicht in den Wald gehen. Zum Beispiel, ich lebe hier in Frankfurt am Main. Die größten Internetknoten der Welt sind hier in Frankfurt am Main. Ich kann sie sehen, wenn ich aus dem Fenster schaue. Zwischen hier, wo ich gerade bin, in Frankfurt und dem Flughafen, dem größten Flughafen Deutschlands, der die ganze Welt, du kannst dreimal in der Woche nach Hongkong fliegen. Wenn ich zum Spazieren gehe in den Wald und ich bin auf halber Höhe zwischen mir und dem Flughafen, 2,5 Kilometer im Wald, fällt mein Podcast aus, weil ich mal wieder vergessen habe, ihn vorher runterzuladen, weil ich im Wald kein Netz habe. So, wenn irgendwer anfängt mit Bitcoin, funktioniert immer, ist super geil und so weiter. Nee, ich könnte da keine Bitcoin Transaktion machen, weil ich habe da nämlich kein Internet. Also zwischen Frankfurt City und Frankfurt Flughafen habe ich kein Internet. Und das ist ein 5 Kilometer Streifen Land. Und solange diese Probleme nicht gelöst sind, und selbst in Taiwan geht man noch auf den Berg und es mit 4.000 Meter Höhe und hat dann kein Internet, ist das alles nichts. Bitcoin ist eine Wertanlage für eine Welt, die Gott sei Dank, sagen dann vor allem die Bitcoiner, mit Dollar funktioniert. Ansonsten ist das alles nichts. Und ja, wir haben uns schon gewundert, als wir Move gelesen haben, warum das Buch am Ende so einen komischen Knick hat. Nach der schönen demografischen Aufschlüsselung der Sachlage, wie sie ist, nämlich einfach statistisch festgehalten. Und da kann man sich auch mal Gedanken drüber machen. Zack, jetzt will ich mal spekulieren und nur noch so ein Luftballon, dem man sofort die Luft auslässt. Der würde nicht mal wegfliegen, sondern piks rein, sofort weg.
Ja, sowas schreibt man, um Investoren für irgendwelche Mondprojekte zu suchen, die dann sagen, oh ja, da kann man mal mitmachen. Das wäre ja schön, wenn wir ewig lebten oder sowas. Und hier ist es auch, dass wir alles Mögliche hier versprochen bekommen. These 7, dass das internationale Recht nur noch dezentral über intelligente Verträge laufen soll. Man denkt ja, aber wer handelt die dann aus? Es geht ja nicht einfach darum, dass man diese Verträge selbstverständlich über Krypto-Protokolle verfassen kann und dann auch schauen kann, wo wird dagegen verstoßen. Das kann man alles da machen. Nur es geht ja am Ende darum, wenn man da einfach einen Trump hat oder ein Modi, der sagt, ich mach das jetzt mal so, der schert sich eh nicht um den internationalen Vertrag dann und da wird auch keiner sagen, ja, aber in der Blockchain steht doch, der macht es trotzdem. Also das wird auch immer so ignoriert, einfach welche Kontingenzen die Geschichte hervorbringt. Es geht dann in These 8 darum, dass man das universelle Grundeinkommen einfügen kann. Ich will das nur mal vorlesen, weil es wirklich absurd ist. Also ich finde es als seine Absurdität verrückt. Also Web-Protokolle könnten das wunderbar möglich machen. Wenn die Marktkapitalisierung, schreiben sie, von Alphabet, Meta, Apple, Amazon und Microsoft in Höhe von etwa 5 Billionen Dollar auf eine Milliarde Nutzer aufgeteilt würde, sodass jeder von ihnen etwa 5.000 Dollar bekäme, wäre die Unterstützung viel größer. Und man denkt ja, aber die nur weil jetzt diese Web-3-Protokolle da sind und die nicht primär von Konzernen erschaffen sind, geben die ja nicht jetzt ihre Billionen ab und verteilen das irgendwie in der Gesellschaft. Das ist eine ganz eigenartige Idee, wo einfach die ökonomische Macht wieder ausgeblendet wird, die sich auch bahnbrechen wird im Metaverse. Das ist jetzt ein großer Verteidigungskampf. Stellen wir uns das wirklich als den wilden Westen vor, da ist Neuland und da springen jetzt alle drauf. Und die, die schon von Anfang an mit einer Stärke und einem Vorteil kommen, haben mehr Chancen. Und da mag sein, dass da ein paar Pioniere nochmal sind, die sich mit einer findigen Idee durchsetzen und dann auch eine Marktmacht gewinnen. Aber das wird nicht demokratischer werden. Na ja, dann die Idee. Unternehmen, Städte, Währungen, Gemeinde und Länder werden alle zu alles zu Netzwerken. Positives Beispiel, was sie heranziehen. Rate mal. Natürlich. Naib Bukele, El Salvador, die Bitcoin City. Das finden sie toll. Und dann zehntens, die Macht dezentralisiert sich von den Vereinigten Staaten und China weg. Auch hier nochmal ein Zitat. Etwa 75% der Weltbevölkerung, mehr als 60% des globalen BIP und rund 50% aller Milliardäre sind weder Chinesen noch Amerikaner. Diese beiden Supermächte können sich durchaus streiten. Aber es ist nicht klar, ob der Rest der Welt sich mit einer der beiden Parteien verbünden will. Mit dem Aufkommen dezentraler Protokolle erwarten wir, dass viele Staaten in der Mitte sich dazu entschließen werden. Bitcoin, Ethereum und andere Chains für und Coins für China und US resistente Kommunikations- und Finanztransaktionskanäle zu nutzen. Also ein Ende der Leitwährung wird hier aufgetan. Die lateinamerikanischen Länder würden es vormachen. Ne, das glaube ich tatsächlich nicht. Und wir haben bei Adam Toos ja sehr schön gelernt, welche Rolle der Staat spielt, beziehungsweise die jeweiligen Zentralbanken spielen. Stellen wir uns mal ganz kurz vor, FED und EZB hätten bei Corona einfach nur die Arme in die Luft geworfen und gesagt, ja, kann man irgendwie nichts machen, schade für die Weltwirtschaft. Was dann gewesen wäre, dann wäre auch dieses ganze Kryptosystem, wären all das, wo jetzt Gelder da reinfließen, alles zusammengebrochen. Ohne das ist das nicht denkbar. Insofern ist es interessant, das zu lesen, weil man sehr gut diese libertären Ideen und diese ganzen anderen Ideologien von Silicon Valley und Co. hier nochmal illustriert sieht. Aber ich glaube, dass das Zukunftsmusik ist, die doch eigentlich nur einen schalen Klang hat.
Ich versuche jetzt einen Brückenschlag über meinen eigenen Text, denn ihr wisst ja, ich schreibe gerade einen Rentnerpublik und ich verspreche euch, ich versuche, einen ausschließlich spektakulären Text vorzulegen, in dem ich unter anderem, du hast ja schon Hans Zimmer gespielt, wie er auf Wenn Karl Zwischer ihn fragt und das Metaverse von Mark Zuckerberg, er so und so und ich versuche im Text darzustellen, während Peter Thiel meint, Covid hat uns die Zukunft gebracht. So werden wir leben, wie unter Covid Bedingungen. Wir schaffen das nämlich alles mit Internet und so weiter. Wird mein Argument sein? Nee, man darf nicht einfach die elementaren, wie soll man sagen, Betriebssysteme einhalten, auf denen die Gesellschaft wirklich läuft. Also Metaverse ist ja so die Idee von, auf welchem Betriebssystem läuft eigentlich unsere Gesellschaft? Und dann sagt Mark Zuckerberg, naja, hier, ich hab hier so ein bisschen Code geschrieben in meinem großen Rechenzentrum und da wird die Gesellschaft jetzt verarbeitet. Und ich sag dann, nee, da übersieht man C. Tectile Affarent. So hat vor 20 Jahren die Biowissenschaft das kleine Nervenendum, den Nervenenden benannt, den man da entdeckt hat. Und den kann ich jetzt in Kürze nur so darstellen, dass jeder genau versteht, was ich meine. Auf dem menschlichen Körper sind Nervenenden verteilt, die auf Berührung reagieren. Also wenn wir uns selber berühren, merken wir das. Wenn wir uns selber berühren, blende das Gehirn das aber aus. Wir können uns einfach im Gesicht kratzen und dann fragt uns jemand, was machst du da? Ach ja stimmt, ich kratze mich ja gerade. Warum blende ich das eigentlich aus? Und warum kann ich mich noch Jahrzehnte später erinnern, wie ich damals, was weiß ich, auf einer Parkbank saß und plötzlich kam das eine Mädel, das ich schon immer hübsch fand, vorbei und hat mich ganz zart am Knie berührt, als sie an mir vorüber ging. Sie hat es nicht mal gemerkt, aber ich weiß es heute 20 Jahre später noch. Wie kann eine kleine Berührung so elementar sein für mein eigenes Leben, Denken, Handeln? Wie kann so eine kleine Berührung in mir selber, die Biochemie, die schon in mir steckt, plötzlich so in Drogen verwandeln, dass ich das Jahrzehnte später noch weiß, während ich gleichzeitig mir 30 mal in der Stunde ans Gesicht fasse und davon nichts in meinem sensorischen Register des Gehirns, geschweige denn im Arbeitsregister und erst recht nichts im Langzeitspeicher stecken bleibt. Und die Antwort ist, ja, das wird einfach an diesem Nervenendum direkt verarbeitet. Wenn das im Gehirn ankommt als ist schon zu spät, dann ist die ganze Verarbeitung schon gelaufen, dann ist nur noch erleben sozusagen. Aber die Welt ist dann schon passiert. So und das übersehen wir völlig. Und das haben wir auch jetzt ausgeblendet. In der Corona-Pandemie einfach die Sozialität auf Displays umstellen. Damit kann der Körper arbeiten, denn er ersetzt dann einfach Oxytocin mit Dopamin. Dopamin ist ein Glückshormon für diese ganz kurzfristigen High, High, High, High und jetzt noch mal ein High-Moment. Von einem Piek zum nächsten. Während Oxytocin, dieses ganz langfristig steuernde, dass wir auf dem Sterbe bedenken. Die letzte Berührung hätte ich gerne von dem Menschen, den ich als allererstes berührt habe, nämlich mein eigenes Kind. Diese Verknüpfung, die wird über Oxytocin gesteuert. So und da kommt einfach Dopamin niemals an. Also wenn wir uns fragen, auf welchem Betriebssystem läuft unsere Gesellschaft? Ja, sie wird direkt auf unserer Haut verarbeitet. Es ist nicht ohne Grund, dass unser Rücken am meisten von diesen sensorischen Registern hat, von diesen Nervenenden, wo wir uns fragen, der Rücken, also den berühre ich doch nie. Nein, richtig, den berühren die anderen. Der Rücken ist der Ort, wo wir selber nicht hinkommen. Also brauchen wir eine Biochemie, die uns steuert, dass wir andere dazu verleiten, damit sie uns, die Affen machen es vor, lausen. Wenn wir heute zur Massage gehen, ist völlig klar, selbst eine Massage ist heute eine Hardcore-Dienstleistung. Wir wissen genau, es dauert 30 Minuten, kostet 60 Euro oder wie auch immer. Kann man buchen. Wer massiert dich? Ganz egal. Aber die Massage findet statt. Sie ist ganz fest verankert und sie gilt immer dem Rücken. Wenn man zur Massage geht, fragt niemand, der hat sich die Wade massieren lassen. Das wäre dann, müsste man dazu sagen. Wenn man sonst sagt, ich gehe zur Massage, ja, es ist der Rücken. Weil eben auf dem Rücken diese Nervenenten sind. Darüber wird Gesellschaft hergestellt. Wir wenden uns voneinander ab. In dem Moment aber total zueinander. Wissen genau, wir gehören gerade zusammen. Die anderen sind ja ausgeschlossen und so weiter und so fort. Und an diese elementare Biochemie, mit der wir Gesellschaft gestalten, kommt die digitale Technik nicht ran. Niemals. Alle Technologien, die wir heute sagen, mit visueller Reizung und so weiter. Wenn wir das absetzen, sind wir enttäuscht. Kinder sind tot traurig, wenn sie nach sechs Stunden plötzlich aufhören müssen, Computer zu spielen. Da bleibt nichts kleben. Wenn sie sechs Stunden lang unter Freunden waren, in Geselligkeit, auf Reise, wie auch immer, das wirkt nach. Da ist man auch danach noch fröhlich. Ja, man fällt in so ein, schade, dass es vorbei ist, aber wir wissen und so weiter. Da gibt es elementare Unterschiede. Das ist jenseits des Bewusstseins. Da nützt es auch nicht, eine politische Diskussion darüber zu führen. Mit diesen kleinen Nervenenden lässt sich nicht diskutieren. Genauso wenig wie mit Corona. Das sind einfach unerbittliche Realitäten, mit denen wir zu tun haben. Und da können sie noch so viele Ideen haben. Diese ganzen Vordenker, Mitdenker, wie auch immer, wird nicht aufgehen.
Ja, und ich finde es auch nochmal wichtig zu sagen, denn wir haben ja auch in Deutschland eine Single-Gesellschaft und dass das auch so unberücksichtigt blieb, während Corona, also gerade auch bei jungen Leuten, die in fremde Städte ziehen, niemanden dort kennen und natürlich auch daten wollen, dass das alles so ausgeblendet wird. Nein, nein, also jetzt trifft dich man nicht, bleibt mal zu Hause. Ja, wir hatten den Werbespot auf der Couch liegen, Held sein und so weiter. Das ist ja einfach absurd. Auch wie dann gespottet wurde über Sexarbeiter, die sagten, na ja, aber wir, es geht nicht nur darum uns, dass wir arbeiten müssen, sondern wir erfüllen auch eine gesellschaftliche Funktion unter diesem Blick, wie du den da gerade beschreibst, ist es ja auch noch mal was, also was, was zu bedenken ist. Also das ist ein, ein Riesenthema, das extrem vernachlässigt wurde. Und man kann ja auch immer denken, wenn dies nicht stattfindet, also wenn dieses Glück, das mit der Berührung einhergeht, nicht realisiert werden kann, aufgrund von politischen Bestimmungen, dann verursacht man dadurch natürlich auch ein großes Leid. Und das darf nicht ausgeblendet werden und alles nur totgeschlagen werden mit Inzidenzen. Also das ist nicht der ganze Mensch.
Ja, wir haben alle sehr gelacht, als es plötzlich nach der ersten und der zweiten Welle hieß, Söder stand da vor der Kamera und meinte, der Friseur gehört auch zur Würde des Lebens. Das ist eine körpernahe Dienstleistung, die muss sein und dazu braucht man die ganze Wissenschaft nicht. Man guckt den alten Leuten Ü70 ins Gesicht und fragt sie ihn, was wünscht du dir am meisten? Dann sagen die, ich will zurück zu meinem Friseur. Jemand, der mir am Kopf rumkrawlt.
Ich auch, ich muss da nicht 70 sein und ich liebe es, wenn ich die Haare gewaschen bekomme. Ich finde das ganz großartig.
Jemand, der dir am Kopf rumkrawlt und gleichzeitig ein persönliches Gespräch, in dem es um nichts geht, weil es ist nur sekundär. Das ist das Wichtigste, umso älter man wird. Wenn du das schon in jungen Jahren erfährst, ist das gut, denn man muss sich irgendwann eingestehen, was die wichtigen Dinge des Lebens sind. Und es gibt in der Serie Boston Legal eine ganz wunderbare Szene von Alan Shore, wie er sagt, und das muss man dazu wissen, eigentlich immer nur Frauengeschichten am Laufen die ganze Zeit. Sein ganzes Leben besteht nur aus Frauengeschichten. Er ist ein toller Anwalt, hält tolle Reden, kennt sich aus, pipa po, aber am Ende ist es dann doch immer die Frau des Abends, die ihm dann und so weiter. Und dann sagt er, was ihm wirklich wichtig ist im Leben, ist einen Anzug zu kaufen und noch bevor der Anzug da ist, ausgemessen zu werden. Wenn also eine Frau ohne sexuellen Interesse vor ihm kniet und ihm so um die Teile fasst und dabei zeigt, ich kümmere mich um dich, als wäre es die eigene Mutter. Das ist für ihn das Schönste. Es ist nicht irgendwie der Sex oder so oder sonstiges, sondern es ist dieses, hier geht es um mich. Es geht darum, wie ich später aussehe. Hier gibt es sich jemand Mühe, damit ich gut aussehe. Und dieser Moment, in dem man dann so auf Hüfthöhe umarmt wird, um irgendwie auszumessen, wie soll die Hose jetzt sein, ist sozusagen der Gipfel des Glücks. Und das muss man einfach verinnerlichen. Das ist wichtig. Das muss anerkannt werden. Und das, hoffentlich kommen wir jetzt auch dazu nach Corona, dass wir diese Defizite, die sich da aufgespart haben, dass wir das einfach einarbeiten in so eine Politik. Also, England hat Corona nicht gebraucht, um 2018 ein Einsamkeitsministerium einzuführen, weil das Rote Kreuz dort sagte, 200.000 Menschen leben in Großbritannien und führen pro Monat ein oder weniger Gespräche mit Freunden oder Familie. Das sind einfach dramatische Verhältnisse. Da sind Menschen tot, obwohl sie noch mitten im Leben stehen. Naja, so viel zur Einsamkeit. Kommen wir zu diesem Text aus Über Japan, der in der zweiten Zwischenüberschrift tatsächlich den Titel trägt. Einsamkeit wird richtig teuer, denn es hat natürlich eine ökonomische Dimension, wie jetzt ja auch. Um ein paar Ungeimpfte zu schützen, was bieten wir alles auf? Und so ist das halt in Japan auch. Dort sind es nicht die Ungeimpften, sondern die Alten, um die man sich kümmern muss. Die eigentliche Überschrift ist aber fit am G-Stock von Alina Sara im Freitag. Und da es am Anfang filmisch zugeht, lese ich vor. Setsuko Hara, kennst du sie?
Nein.
Wie weitreich dein Filmverständnis? Okay, also keine Sorge, sie muss man nicht kennen. Denn Setsuko Hara hat sie in den Filmen der 1950er und 60er Jahre verkörpert, wie es sonst kaum eine Schauspielerin konnte. Doppelpunkt. Die aufopferungsvolle, liebenswürdige, stets lächelnde Tochter oder Schwiegertochter, der nichts mehr am Herzen liegt, als sich um ihre alten, alternden Angehörigen zu kümmern. Es geht also hier, man steigt zu einen in Erinnerungen, wo wir alle denken, ja genau, das ist, können wir uns ungefähr vorstellen, wie das in den Filmen sich darstellt. Doch inzwischen passt dieses Bild immer seltener zur Lebenswirklichkeit, japanischer Familien. Die Landflucht trennt die Generation geografisch, die Jungen ziehen in die Städte, die Alten bleiben zurück. Und die Schwiegertöchter gehen immer häufiger in die Lohnarbeit, anstatt zu Hause Care und Pflegearbeit zu übernehmen. Denn man braucht in Japan ein funktionierendes Erwerbspersonenpotenzial. Dazu gehören auch Frauen. Pflege ist also jetzt eine gesellschaftliche Aufgabe und nicht mehr nur eine individuelle. Man hat 80.000 100-jährige oder älter und fast jeder dritte in Japan ist mittlerweile älter als 65. Pflegeversicherung gibt es aber erst seit 2000. Die liefert also nicht allzu viel Geld. Es ist schon weit mit Robotern, aber das ist dann doch mehr ein Klischee. Es sind Menschen gebraucht und die gibt es nicht. Die kommen auch nicht aus dem Ausland. Und jetzt hat man es mit zwei Stigma zu tun. Zum einen, du lässt deine Eltern im Stich, weil das einfach die ökonomische Notwendigkeit des Landes ist. Also die Politik arbeitet darauf hinaus, dass man seine Eltern im Stich lässt. Und Ausländer pflegen, du lässt dich von Ausländern pflegen. Also das Stigma, Ausländer wollen wir hier nicht und lass man nicht deine Eltern im Stich. Mit dem muss man jetzt politisch hantieren. Die jungen Frauen sind weg, kümmern sich nicht mehr um die Alten und sie sind aber trotzdem noch da. So und klar, es gibt so ein paar ausländische Pflegekräfte, die kommen aus Vietnam und müssen dann aber ein japanisches Staatsexamen auf Japanisch bewältigen, um in Japan pflegen zu dürfen. Und jetzt ist halt die Frage, was tut man? Man hat eigentlich die Straße ist zu Ende, auf der man gefahren ist. Man kommt jetzt wirklich nicht mehr weiter. In Japan erlebt man jetzt schon was, in Deutschland sozusagen, dann kommt. Wenn nun also Roboter und Ausländ ausfallen, so bleibt eine weitere Stellschraube über. Und während wir das jetzt lesen, nur diesen Einsatz, fragen wir uns, ist das noch eine Stellschraube oder ist das schon die totale Aufgabe? Hat man hier kapituliert vor der Demografie? Also so bleibt eine weitere Stellschraube dafür, die Herausforderung zu lösen. Man versucht, die Zahl der Pflegebedürftigen zu verringern, indem man ihre Pflegebedürftigkeit möglichst weit hinaus zögert. Die Kernphilosophie der alten Pflege in Japan ist, den Pflegebedarf zu reduzieren. Alte Menschen sollen sich möglichst lange ihre Unabhängigkeit bewahren, geistig und körperlich aktiv und mobil bleiben. Nun würde man so denken, das machen die doch aus intrinsischer Motivation. Sollen wir das hier nochmal politisch sagen? Also ist doch irgendwie Quatsch und ja, es ist tatsächlich Quatsch. Man versucht jetzt nochmal mit so Nachbarschaftsorganisationen, Chonai Kai, so nannte man das damals nach dem Krieg, als der Staat noch nicht richtig wiederhergestellt war und man die Niederlage verarbeiten musste und man dachte, okay, wir brauchen jetzt trotzdem irgendwie Gesellschaft. Also hat man so auch publizistisch so eine Art von Nachbarschaftshilfe als Idee vorgestellt für Katastrophenfälle und Krieg. Die Bedeutung ging dann sehr weg, weil man hatte weder Katastrophen noch Krieg. Und jetzt kommt aber die Demografie zurück wie ein Katastrophenfall oder ein Krieg. Und jetzt muss man das wieder reaktivieren. Nicht so sehr, um das Land verteidigungsfähig oder wirtschaftsfähig zu halten, sondern jetzt geht es darum, Rätselabende und Handarbeitskurse zu organisieren. Aber eben nicht, wir haben kein Geld dafür, dass das irgendwer macht, sondern wir am besten finden wir jemand 65-Jährigen, den wir so gut motivieren und anleiten, dass er dann die 85-Jährigen mitzieht und dann stitzen alle da und häkeln. Also so richtige Freiwilligkeitsarbeit. Oder man hat so Arbeitsagenturen, man kümmert sich jetzt und dann hat man zum Beispiel die Silvall, die Yin-Zai-Centers gegründet. Da sitzt man dann so zusammen und organisiert noch so ein bisschen Hausarbeit, BBSitting, Nachhilfe, Vorlesen, weil man so gesehen hat, naja, wenn man für 65 anfängt, dann in den Kindergarten zu fahren, einmal die Woche vorzulesen, dann ist das vielleicht auch ein Termin, auf dem man sich freut nächste Woche, dann hält man sich mobil, dann weiß man, ich habe auch nächste Woche noch einen Termin. Und dann schleift sich das vielleicht so ein, als dann doch auch staatstragende Struktur, dass nicht alle nur zu Hause sitzen, sondern man versucht jetzt so ganz niederschwellig, es darf nichts kosten, Angebote zu schaffen, damit die Leute da überhaupt noch irgendwas zu tun haben. Und was soll man sagen? Es kann natürlich aufgehen und gut gehen. Wir haben in Deutschland noch immenses Potenzial, indem wir einfach mal den 50-Jährigen sagen, hör mal zu, eine gesunde Ernährung kann im Falle von Corona ähnlich gut wirken wie eine AstraZeneca-Impfung. Du brauchst nur weniger Bauchfett und so weiter. Und dann hätten wir sowas schon eingefangen. Also es hat einen medizinischen Sinn, ein gesundes Leben zu führen. Aber davon sind wir in Deutschland ganz weit weg. Also die Zivilisationskrankheiten angeleitet über falsche Ernährung sind so immens, so krass, dass wir hier in Deutschland auf die Idee kommen könnten, wir bekämen das auch noch hin, die Alten einfach fitter zu halten. Aber irgendwie sehen wir jetzt in Japan schon, wie auch das deutsche Schicksal aussehen wird.
Wir können uns dann japanische Filme ansehen. Und ich stand gerade auf dem Schlauch. Sezuko Hara ist die Schauspielerin von Ozu. Also Ozu, der ganz, ganz große Meisterwerke geschaffen hat. Also fünf, wir sprechen hier von den 50er Jahren. Mir war nicht sofort die Connection klar, aber selbstverständlich. Und sie ist auch eine Legende, deshalb weil sie sich meines Wissens sehr früh zurückgezogen hat aus dem Film. Also eher so Greta Gabo mäßig, Greta Gabo von Japan. Gabo hat ja auch eine Zeit lang nur Filme gemacht, 10, 15 Jahre und sich dann komplett zurückgezogen. Bei ihr war das ähnlich. Und so kann man sich diese japanische Gesellschaft sehr gut vor Augen führen in den Meisterwerken von Ozu.
Sehr gut. Eine Pointe zum Schluss. Die habe ich fast übersehen. Gerade habe ich sie noch gefunden. Ich lese mal. Besonders zu Beginn der Rente sind diese Angebote aber für viele nicht mehr attraktiv. Also dieses ganze länger arbeiten vor allem. Also man versucht jetzt in Japan was Neues. Viele wollen mit 65 noch nicht aufhören zu arbeiten, weil sie da doch ein bisschen fit sind. Dabei ist es nicht für alle attraktiv und man muss dann auch so ein paar Angebote machen. Das Enten Eintrittsalter liegt bei 65. Da sind die meisten noch fit und arbeiten lieber regulär weiter. Die Regierung versucht es deshalb mit Selbstbestimmung. Doppelpunkt und jetzt ganz wichtig auch für Deutschland. Das Alter soll nicht mehr darüber entscheiden, ob jemand als Senior oder Senioren bezeichnet wird. Diese Form der alterslosen Gesellschaft entlastet zudem noch die Rentenkasse. Denn Menschen, die es gibt, auch in Deutschland ganz interessant. Was passiert eigentlich, wenn man 65 ist und weiter arbeitet? Man verdient plötzlich mehr, ohne dass es den Arbeitgeber mehr kostet, weil man führt ja nichts mehr in die Rentenkasse ab. Man hat ja alles getan. Man kriegt also automatisch 15 Prozent oder so mehr Geld, nur weil man länger arbeitet und bleibt dann auf dem Rentenniveau. Man selbst hat also mehr Geld plötzlich und dem Staat, sagt man, im Tausch dafür, dass ich jetzt hier mehr Geld habe, belaste ich ja die Rentenkasse weniger, weil ich arbeite ja als länger, habe also mehr Geld für mein Leben, bin dann aber weniger in der Rente. Also von denen, durch statistisch 20 Jahre in der Rente ist, die man zwei Jahre mehr arbeitet, bezahlt man zwei Jahre lang keine Rentenversicherung, hat also mehr Geld im Alltag. Und gleichzeitig suggeriert man schon dem Staat, aber du musst dann auch zwei Jahre weniger für mich Rente zahlen, weil ich sterbe ja vergleichsweise nicht früher, aber mit kürzerer Zeit als Rentenempfänger. Also da gibt es ganz viele Kalkulationen, die man so machen kann. Und diese Alterslosigkeit der Gesellschaft, das ist hochinteressant, denn ich habe schon mal darauf hingewiesen, dass die Uhren, die wir heute tragen, diese modernen Uhren, uns immer ein biologisches Alter anzeigen, je nach Fitnessgrad. Und wir haben gerade gesehen, dass Corona eigentlich eine richtige Alterskrankheit. Also dieses Covid, was wir haben, das ist eigentlich eine Krankheit, die beim Alter zuschlägt. Wir haben in Deutschland 107.000 Tote und 100.000 davon sind über 60 gewesen. Es sterben aber auch junge Menschen. Und das sind die, deren biologisches Alter, beispielsweise durch Fettleibigkeit, wenig Bewegung und so weiter. Also einfach durch runtergefahrenen Kreislauf und Gebrechlichkeit. Nicht echte Krankheit, sondern Zivilisationskrankheitsgebrechlichkeit, die man sich anfrisst, anfuttert, bewegungslos und so weiter. Das da auch zuschlägt. Und da kann man jetzt so überlegen, wie man es veranschaulichen kann, welche Rolle des Alters spielt. Plus, und das wird in der Rentnerrepublik wieder eine Rolle spielen, dass wir sowieso die Jugend schon aufgehoben haben. Also Jugendleben ist heute was, was 30-Jährige ausleben. Dieses Juwenile, jetzt habe ich Geld, jetzt lebe ich mich auch aus. Mit 20 Jahren war ich nicht mutig genug, denn da war ich abhängig von meinen Eltern, die meine Miete bezahlen. Außerdem wusste ich, ein Studium ein Jahr früher abschließend ist besser als drei Partynächte zu haben. Und man hat sowieso schon keine Jugendkultur mehr. Es reicht nicht mehr über Musik. Also alles, was heute an Popkultur funktioniert. Ariana Grande und so, das hören auch alles die 30-Jährigen und nicht die 15-Jährigen. Die auch, aber das Geld und so. Der Markt wird für die Älteren gemacht, die nämlich auch bereit sind, dafür zu bezahlen. In der Ansicht haben wir jetzt mit diesen Auflösungen von Altersklassen sowieso ein ganz interessantes Phänomen. In Japan ist es auf die Spitze getrieben, in dem man sagt, es gibt im Grunde keine Senioren mehr, sondern Menschen sind entweder fit oder nicht und danach werden die dann eingeteilt. Aber dieses klassische Altersgehortending, das machen wir mal gar nicht mehr, weil dann haben nur zu viele irgendwelche Ansprüche, die uns zu teuer werden. Also das ist eine ganz interessante Bewegung. Ein ganz kurzer Text im Freitag, aber sozusagen der Nadelstich genau richtig platzieren.
Ich finde ja sowieso immer dieses Abziehen aufs Alter so uninteressant. Also Leute schreiben, dass ja immer gerne dabei ist, so und so alt. Also ich finde, ich feiere ja auch keinen Geburtstag. Von daher habe ich mit Alter nichts zu schaffen. Älter werde ich später, heißen Biografien berühmter deutscher Schauspielerinnen. Naja, wir kommen zu Pier Paolo Pasolini, ein Regisseur, der dir vielleicht etwas sagt, italienischer Regisseur, wichtige Filme gedreht.
Soll ich dir sagen, warum er mir was sagt?
Warum?
Mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit ist dieser Paolo dieser Paolo, der damals Menschen so begeistert hat, dass sie ihre Kinder Paolo nannten, die heute auch Filme gucken, aber auch Podcasts hören. Beispielsweise Paolo, der den letzten Fernsehpodcast präsentiert hat, weshalb ich ihn immer noch die ganze Zeit hier sehe, weil er immer noch im Bild drin steht.
Ach so, ah ja, Pier Paolo Pasolini ist ja auch ein sehr schöner Name. Jedenfalls hat er sehr große Filme gemacht, zum Beispiel auch diesen Skandal umwitterten Film, Die 120 Tage von Sodom Salo. Ein Film, der sehr eng verstrickt ist, auch mit Pasolini selbst. Pasolini wurde ermordet. Pasolini ist eine eigenartige solitäre Gestalt in der italienischen Kultur. Er war schwul, er war katholisch, er war Kommunist. Und das war selbstverständlich immer ein sehr widerspenstiges Leben, das er geführt hat und kein leichtes. Er musste nach Rom mit seiner Mutter Ende der 40er, Anfang der 50er Jahre fliehen. Er verdankt der Mutter alles und es ist eine besondere Liebe zu Mutter. Ohnehin teilte Pasolini seine Liebe auf. Da gibt es die Liebe, die tief empfundene, die kann nur zur Mutter für ihn existieren. Da gibt es die Sexualität, die kann nur mit Strichern aus dem Subproletariat gelebt werden. Und dann gibt es noch die Freundschaften, entweder mit den ganz einfachen Leuten, wenn möglich sogar Analphabeten, oder mit den wahren Intellektuellen der italienischen Society. Niemals aber mit dem Bürgertum, das Pasolini verachtet hat. Und der Suche am Verlag hat jetzt dankenswerterweise ganz viele Gedichte von Pasolini herausgegeben. Denn Pasolini war nicht nur Regisseur, sondern auch Schriftsteller und Dichter nach meinem Tod zu veröffentlichen. Heißt dieser umfangreiche Band. Und es ist jetzt sehr schwer, natürlich ein Gedichtband zu besprechen, weil er eine Vielzahl von Pasolinis Phasen zeigt. Weil er auch zeigt, wie sehr sich Pasolini mit der italienischen Dichtkunst auseinandersetzt. Zum Teil muss man dafür Kenner sein, um das wirklich so analysieren zu können. Ich kann manches nur erahnen. Aber es sind doch einige Dinge dabei, die direkt einem verständlich sind. So sein Verhältnis zur Mutter, wo er sagt in einem Gedicht, es ist so schwer in sohles Worten zu beschreiben, was mein Herz wie das meine sonst verschweigen. Du bist die einzige auf Erden, die mein Herz versteht, von Anfang an noch ehe es sich zu anderen lieben regt. Drum sage ich, die Erkenntnis macht mich bang. Deine Gnade ist die Wiege meiner Angst. Und das war etwas, wovor Pasolini tatsächlich immer sich fürchtete. Was, wenn es die Mutter eines Tages nicht mehr gibt? Das ist also ein ganz anderes Lebenskonzept, als das jetzt üblicherweise vorgesehen ist. Abnabelung von den Eltern, eigene Familiengründung oder so. Bei Pasolini natürlich nicht. Wir sind Überlebende, schreibt er dann etwas später in uns, das Labyrinth eines Daseins jenseits der Vernunft. Ach, ich flehe, flehe dich an, geh nicht fort. Ich bin hier, hier mit dir. Ein neuer April steht bevor. Pasolini hat sich auch politisch immer wieder eingemischt. So findet sich ein Gedicht da, das an Rudi Dutschke gerichtet ist, das er für eine deutsche Zeitschrift geschrieben hat. Und da heißt es dann am Ende des Gedichts, die Gründung einer kommunistischen Partei in Deutschland. So viele Hindernisse, so viele Oppositionen, so viele Widrigkeiten, so viele historische Unmöglichkeiten, wo die Dinge ein für allemal feststehen. In Frankfurt wird gehofft, in Heidelberg wird studiert und sich gelangweilt. Das Bürgertum, dessen Eingeweiden du geheimnisvollerweise entsprangst, habe ich mit meinen eigenen Augen gesehen. Es hat Gesichter, weiß wie Grabsteine. Lass dich nicht irre führen von seinem guten Willen, von seiner gequälten Sensibilität, von seiner komischen Befangenheit. Sie sind alle eingeschüchtert, mein Vater, mein Captain. Und deine jungen Freunde benutzen die Hauptstraße, nicht die kleinen Nebenwege. Also auch sowas findet sich hier bei Pasolini. Und immer wieder Lebensbilanz. Späte Einsichten heißt ein Gedicht. Da schreibt er, ich weiß wohl, ich weiß wohl, dass ich am Grund des Grabes liege, dass alles, was ich berühre, bereits von mir berührt worden ist, dass ich Gefangener eines schamlosen Verlangens bin, dass jede Rekonvalenz ein Rückfall ist, dass die Gewässer stocken und das alles abgestanden schmeckt, dass auch der Humor nur Teil des unaufhebbaren Stillstands ist, dass ich nichts anderes tue, als das Neue zum Alten zu erwecken. Und das Neue zum Alten zu erwecken ist vielleicht auch etwas, was stilistisch ganz gut zu seinen Filmen passt, dass er sich immer in der italienischen Tradition verortet hat und dass seine Filme sehr oft, nicht so die Trilogie des Lebens, aber doch viele andere Filme wie Medea, tatsächlich so eine Klassizität haben. Und er ist einer der wenigen Regisseure, die auch einen Teil ihres Werks widerrufen haben. Nämlich die Trilogie des Lebens, das sind drei frivole Filme, Literaturverfilmungen, zum Beispiel De Camaron, wo also sehr ja so soft erotisch einhergeht. Und er wollte damit die Lüste befreien, bis er dann sah, der moderne Kapitalismus tut das ja alles schon. Die alles ist so versext auf eine konsumistische Weise, sodass er dann diese Trilogie des Lebens widerrufen hat und macht dann diesen Film die 120 Tage von Sodom, wo er auch zeigt, wie sexuelle Befreiung auch zugleich eine faschistische Grundierung haben kann. Und er dann auch selbst sein Leben ändert und auch schreibt in diesem Text, dass er nicht mehr zu den Strichern geht, die er zum Teil drei, viermal die Nacht aufsuchte, weil diese Körper nun welche sind, die eigentlich geformt und überformt sind vom Konsum. Also auch ein großer interessanter, origineller Kapitalismuskritiker ist der Pasolini. Das kann man in den Gedichtungen, in den Dichten auch lesen. Ich würde sagen, dieser Band ist etwas für Leute, die sich mit Pasolini intensiver auseinandersetzen wollen. Für Einsteiger würde ich doch sagen, ist der Zugang über die Filme etwas leichter.
Sehr gut. Also es geht auch hier tatsächlich um Pasolini. Bei unserem Paolo, dem lieben Zuhörer, den wir hier haben und den wir an dieser Stelle herzlich grüßen. Und ich wollte dich gerade noch fragen, ob du einhergehst mit der Beurteilung, es sei ein schmuddeliger und exzentrischer Regisseur. Aber das hast du ja gerade schon beantwortet, wenn selbst Pasolini selbst dachte, er sei manchmal zu schmuddelig und exzentrisch. Wer hat das gesagt? Das hat mir Paolo geschrieben, wo sein Name herkommt.
Ach so, ja, ja, es ist ein sehr exzentrischer und, naja, schmuddelig, je nachdem, wie man es möchte.
Ja. Also es fand jedenfalls eine gewisse Revision in Pasolinis eigener Beurteilung seines eigenen Werkes statt, von dem ich jetzt, nachdem ich dir zugehört habe, denke, schmuddelig trifft es ganz gut. Gut, um es hier klug und heiter zu halten, schlage ich mal auch aus Zeitgründen vor, dass ich meine 66 gute Nachrichten aus 2021 Grautreporter-Liste einfach nicht vorlese, denn sie ist albern und die Pointe ist im Grunde schon gemacht worden.
Kannst du denn mal sagen, was ein Etwa ist? Also worüber habe ich vergessen, mich zu freuen?
Also pass auf, Punkt Nummer eins. Vietnam hat seine Solarenergie verdoppelt auf 30.000 Solardächer. Es gibt jetzt wieder mehr Giraffen, Nasenhörner, Löwen, Zebras und Antilopen, wo sie hingehören, in der Freiheit. Und Punkt acht ist dann schon Angel Leon, ein Koch aus Spanien hat jetzt Seegras in Superfood verwandelt. Er hat herausgefunden, wie man es zubereitet. In Hannover wird der Feldhamster geschützt. Frankreich schafft die Plastiktüte ab. Und Tom Brown, der seltene Apfelsorten rettet, züchtet selbst die 700 seltensten, bewahrt also dieses Erbe. Pier Paolo, Platz Nummer 65.
Also das heißt, es sind jetzt nur noch solche fast privatistischen Angelegenheiten. Also ich will jetzt nicht da irgendeinem Koch seine Leidenschaft absprechen oder auch sehen, dass das irgendwie was wichtig ist. Aber wenn man jetzt so die Weltereignisse zusammenträgt und dabei bleibt, dann kann man dann auch sagen, ich habe meine Mandelentzündung überwunden. Also das ist dann auch noch die 67 gute Meldung für die Welt.
Es sind nur noch drei Sagreis umgefallen, nicht mehr zwei.
Ja, meine Güte.
Deswegen komme ich direkt zu meinem letzten Text. Ich will dich aber nicht in die Predo bringen, also stell du uns ruhig noch gerne zwei vor, aber die Krautreporter überspringe ich. Und das ist auch nur eine kleine Rechnung. Leo Ginsburg hat für Business Insider nachgerechnet, wie sich das verhält. Piepapoo. Apple. Also ich lese mal seine Rechnung vor. Unsere Rechnung. Am 9. November, den Tag, als in Deutschland das erste iPhone gekauft werden konnte, war eine Apple Aktie 4,17 Euro wert. Heute kostet diese Aktie 161,50 Euro. Das entspricht einer Erhöhung um rund 3773 Prozent. Hättet ihr damals 399 Euro in Apple investiert, hättet ihr euch rund 95,6 Aktien kaufen können. Diese wären heute demnach rund 15.450 Euro wert. Das zeigt wieder mal, dass es sich manchmal lohnen kann, nicht nur das Produkt zu kaufen, wenn es einen überzeugt, sondern auch in das Unternehmen selbst zu investieren. Das hast du vorhin schon gesagt. Investition, Konsum sind unterschiedliche Sachen. Wenn man sich am 9. November 2007 tatsächlich kein iPhone gekauft hätte, sondern Aktien, hätte man ein gefülltes Depot gehabt, aber man hätte dann kein iPhone. Und ich will mal für mich hier sagen, warum es für mich schon logisch ist, dass es Apple einfach 3 Billionen Dollar wert ist, weil wir von Apple Technologie bekommen, die und da gilt wieder das alte Matthew Theorem, Fernsehen macht die klugen Klüger und die dummen Dümmer. Bücher führen dazu, dass diejenigen, die eh schon Bücher lesen, mehr Bücher lesen, weiß welche gibt, und diejenigen, die keine Bücher lesen, dann noch weniger Bücher lesen, weil sie dann, das ist ein Buch, lehne ich ab. Jetzt haben wir im dritten Sprung digitale Technologie. Und jeder kann für sich aber bitte ehrlich die Rechnung aufmachen. Wenn ich die letzten 15 Jahre kein iPhone benutzt hätte, dafür aber jetzt 15.000 Euro, wäre ich dann reicher oder ärmer. Und ich für mich würde sagen, die 15.000 Euro würden mir gar nichts nützen, wenn ich nicht die 15 Jahre zur rückliegend mit Apples Technologie das gemacht hätte, was ich mit Apples Technologie gemacht habe. Also es ist ein absoluter Gewinn damals in das iPhone und auch in spätere und dann auch von anderen Herstellern Technologie konsumiert zu haben, statt nur zu investieren. Denn dieses Geld alleine als Buchgeld und wenn es einen dann jetzt zur Verfügung stünde, würde das Leben weniger bereichern, als das, was wir mit unseren iPhones, glaube ich, gemacht haben. Im Guten wie im Schlechten. Da muss jetzt jeder für sich überlegen. Hat man Trump gewählt und lehnt die Impfung ab? Oder ist man jemand, dem es gelungen ist, sein analoges Leben in dem Maße zu digitalisieren, dass es einen echten Mehrwert bietet? Also in deren Sicht interessante Rechnung. Ich will eine eigene Rechnung gegenüberstellen. Wenn man beim aktuellen Börsenwert von Apple 0,00004% der Aktien hält, ist man schon Millionär. Ist das nicht eine Sensation? Das ist einfach Wahnsinn. Mit 0,04% ist man schon Milliardär.
Ja.
Das ist einfach unglaublich.
Deine Rechnung ist vollkommen korrekt, denn es ist ja so, mir wurde auch schon immer mal wieder so in der Vergangenheit gesagt, du gibst so viel Geld fürs Kino aus. Irgendwann kommen die Filme doch gratis, dann kannst du die irgendwo streamen. Und dann denke ich mir, ja, das mag ja sein, aber was habe ich dann in der Zwischenzeit gemacht? Also ich kann natürlich immer sagen, ich sitze so zu Hause und gucke, was gibt es irgendwo gratis und gucke mir das an. Aber dass ich vielleicht jedes Mal einen Mehrwert daraus gezogen habe, dass ich acht oder zehn Euro für eine Kinokarte ausgegeben habe, vielleicht auch mit anderen zusammen im Kino gewesen bin, das ist doch das, was mir was hilft. Was nutzt mir das, wenn ich sage, ja, aber dann habe ich das Geld gespart. Ja, schön, aber was soll ich jetzt mit dem gesparten Geld? Also, ich kann ja nicht sagen, und das Glück kommt alles später, wenn ich dann das Geld gespart habe oder so. Das, was das Leben ausmacht, ist nicht so aufzuheben und aufzusparen, sondern man kann sagen, gut, man investiert vielleicht noch in andere Dinge. Das ist aber auch immer halt retrospektiv sehr leicht gesagt. Also, wir könnten jetzt auch mal überlegen, in was kann man jetzt dann auch diese ein, zwei, drei Aktien kaufen, und dann ist man 2030 ziemlich gut dastehend, hat vielleicht hundertmal mehr. Ja, aber wer weiß das schon. Wir haben es bei Warren Buffett gesehen, auch er rätselt ja grundsätzlich stimmt das schon. Klimawandel, grüne Transformation, das bringt so einiges wirtschaftlich ins Rollen. Ich weiß nur halt nicht, welches Unternehmen sich durchsetzen wird. So hat Buffett das gesagt. Ich glaube, das kann man da auch übertragen. Naja, aber ein interessanter Gedanke zumindest einmal, wie man mit dem Geld haushalten soll. Ich würde auch sagen, eher so wie du. Also eher sagen, wo kann ich also Geld einsetzen, dass es mir ein angenehmeres, schöneres Leben verschafft. Das ist eigentlich die Frage. Ich würde noch ein Buch vorstellen über Indien. Ich habe es angekündigt. Arundhati Roy ist eine sehr bekannte Schriftstellerin, schreibt aber auch Essays, politische Essays. Asadi heißt Freiheit, heißt der Band, der politische Essays aus den vergangenen Jahren von ihr versammelt. Ich kann das Buch nicht uneingeschränkt empfehlen, denn es gibt einige Redundanzen. Es ist auch ein bisschen sehr im Tagespolitischen verhaftet, sodass ich dann etwas über 2016, aus 2016 lese, das aber dann nicht noch mal eingeordnet wird, retrospektiv, sondern ich habe da manchmal den Eindruck, ja, ich lese jetzt hier ein bisschen alte Zeitung. Das ist nicht so gut, wenn man ein gebundenes Buch dann herausgibt und man noch den Eindruck hat, das ist ein bisschen altes Zeitungspapier. Das gilt aber nicht für alles so. Und zumindest kann uns Roy auch noch mal den Blick lenken auf Dinge, die wir vielleicht ganz übersehen haben. Wusstest du eigentlich, was mit Kashmir und im Internet geschehen ist?
Gibt es das da nicht mehr? Gab es da hier Internet?
Ja, es ist ganz verrückt, also hier das mal in einer solchen Trastik zu lesen. Heute, am 13. Februar 2020, ist es 193 Tage her, dass die indische Regierung das Internet in Kashmir abgeschaltet hat. Nachdem monatelang kein Zugang zu mobilen Daten oder Breitbandanschlüssen gegeben war, ist es sieben Millionen Kashmiris, die unter der dichtesten militärischen Besatzung der Welt leben, heute möglich, Websites einer sogenannten White List einzusehen, eine Handvoll von der Regierung genehmigter Domänen. Dazu gehören einige ausgewählte Nachrichtenportale, jedoch nicht die sozialen Medien, auf die die Kashmiris angesichts der Feindseligkeit der indischen Medien ihnen gegenüber so angewiesen sind, um ihre Versionen ihres Lebens zu verbreiten. Mit anderen Worten, Kashmir verfügt jetzt über ein offiziell durch eine Firewall geschütztes Internet, was die Zukunft durchaus für viele von uns in der Welt verheißen könnte. Also nicht so hier Parakena Idee, jetzt sind wir alle frei, sondern hier sieht man, der Staat greift durch, der Indische. Die Abschaltung des Internets hat fast jeden Aspekt des täglichen Lebens in Kashmir lahmgelegt. Es ist ein bahnbrechendes Experiment der Massenverletzung von Menschenrechten, abgesehen von der Informationsblockade sind tausende von Kashmiris, darunter Kinderaktivistinnen der Zivilgesellschaft und politische Persönlichkeiten, inhaftiert worden, einige unter dem drakonischen Public Safety Act. Dies ist nur die Spitze des Eisberges einer epischen und sich unaufhörlich entfaltenden Tragödie. Während die Welt wegsieht, ist die Wirtschaft zum Erliegen gekommen. Denn der Tourismusstrom hat sich zu einem Rinnensaal verlangsamt. Kashmir ist zum Schweigen gebracht worden und verschwindet langsam von der Landkarte. Ganz erschütternd hier zu lesen wäre auch mal ein Projekt für die Außenministerin. Also wir müssen nicht nur nach Russland und China blicken, sondern dringend nach Indien. Die EU, wir hatten das auch schon mal in so einer Art Doku aufgerollt. Die EU schmiegt sich an Indien an. Und wenn man das hier gelesen hat, fragt man sich, warum eigentlich, als sei das hier irgendwie eine Alternative. Nee, ist es nicht. Hier können wir nochmal nachvollziehen, wie dieser Aufstieg des Nationalismus gelungen ist. Zwischendurch schimmert mal die Hoffnung durch, dass das Ende von Modi jetzt gekommen ist. Wir wissen, nee, es ist noch weitergegangen. Wer sich also für Indien interessiert, kann das lesen. Aber zum Teil ist diese Tagesaktualität ein Problem, wenn man es dann Jahre später liest, dann hat man es eher so mit einer Dokumentation zu tun. Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, warum man nicht da einfach nochmal dann rangeht. Also wenn man die Sachen verfasst, dann kann man ja das auch nochmal im Update unterziehen. Man muss ja dann nicht einfach nur so eine günstige Zweitverwertung an den Tag legen. Verstehe ich auch nicht, warum Verlage das so mitmachen. Einen letzten Text stimmt, den ich vorstellen will, der stimmt uns auch nicht fröhlich. Es ist absurd. Dänemarks Abschottungspolitik. Der gemietete Knast im Kosovo, ein Text von Reinhard Wolf, erschienen in der Taz. Da heißt es, Dänemark sozialdemokratische Regierung hat ein flüchtlingspolitisches Lieblingsprojekt, null Asylsuchende mehr über die Grenze zu lassen und den gesamten Asylprozess nach Ruanda zu verlegen. Daran arbeitet sie noch. Aber nach einjährigen Verhandlungen mit der Regierung des Kosovo sieht Kopenhagen sich vor einem anderen Erfolg. Abschiebeheftlinge aus nicht europäischen Ländern sollen nicht mehr in Dänemark, sondern im Kosovo inhaftiert werden. Dafür will die dänische Regierung dort einen Knast anmieten.
Warum nicht Grönland? Das ist wenigstens das eigene Land.
Absurd. Der dänische Justizminister Hecke Rupp ist davon überzeugt, findet das ganz groß. Es soll 2023 schon beginnen. Erstmal für die Dauer von zehn Jahren. 300 Haftplätze will man dort anmieten im Kosovo. Was kostet das Dänemark? 210 Millionen Euro. Man könnte sich ja vorstellen, was man damit machen könnte für Asylsuchende. Es ist der reinste Wahnsinn. Es gibt dann hier eine Kriminologie-Professorin. Minke heißt die, die das kritisiert. Die sagt, man betrachtet Gefangene als Güter, die man einfach irgendwo hin transportieren kann. Ein Rechtsanwalt namens Kaya spricht von modernem Kolonialdenken. Aber die Regierung lässt sich nicht beirren. Hinzu kommt, dass es ja so ist, dass Inhaftierte das Besuchsrecht haben. Das heißt, sie dürfen besucht werden. Aber wie ist denn das jetzt, wenn die Gefangenen 2000 Kilometer entfernt sind? Eigentlich müsste dann ein wöchentlicher Flugzeug-Shuttle-Service eingerichtet werden. Der Leute, den führt, also noch mehr Geld kostet das. Hekob Rupp sagt, ja, man sieht da schon das, aber man kann sich darauf verlassen, dass man sich an alles wohl halten will. Es sei ein dänisches Gefängnis im Kosovo unter dänischer Leitung. Denn es gibt gerade im Kosovo sehr viele Menschenrechtsverletzungen. Haftbedingungen sind grauenhaft. Leute werden da in Isolationshaft für 30 Tage gesteckt, ohne dass man so recht weiß, warum. Und man darf es am Übrigen auch nicht. Hekob Rupp sagt, ich bin zuversichtlich, wir schaffen das. Ja, ein ganz, ganz trauriges Kapitel. Ein auch ökonomischer Wahnsinn, das zu tun. Mal von ethischen menschenrechtlichen Problemen ganz abgesehen. Es ist unbegreiflich, aber möglicherweise dann bald Vorbild für andere europäische Länder. Hoffen wir das nicht. Also kommen wir in der Moderne an, kann man eigentlich den Leuten nur zurufen. Also hören wir mit diesem Wahnsinn auf.
Ja, Dänemark ist ja da noch Schizophrener und Paradoxer als Peter Thiels Biografie. Peter Thiel hält ja den New Deal für den größten Fehler, den Amerika je gemacht hat. Dänemark ist ja das idealtypische Land, das nach New Deal regiert wird. Aber dieser Sozialstaat, der für alle da ist, ist eben nur für alle Dänen da. Und da wird eine ganz harte Grenze gezogen. Koste es, was es wolle. Ich fand das damals schon erstaunlich. Also 2015, 16, als es hier hieß, Flüchtlinge und so, mega Problem. Und die Dänen einfach, wieso, wir können die doch alle in Nordafrika, also wir können auch da Asylverfahren machen und so. Was selbst den Hardcore-Osteuropäern ja erst mal so, krass, das haben wir noch nicht nachgedacht. Wir haben erst mal nur hier Grenzen aufgezogen und die kommen dann hier an und so. Nee, wir können die doch direkt da vor Ort. Also die Dänen, die ja durchweg sozialdemokratisch regiert werden und so, fahren da die härteste Linie überhaupt. Also es ist wirklich ganz, wie gesagt, wir haben ja eben schon über das Geld und den Wert des Geldes. In den Dänen ist das viel wert, dass sie für sich das glücklichste Land der Welt sind. Es gab jetzt auch erst wieder diese Woche einen SWR2-Forum oder eine Phoenix-Runde. Ich glaube, es war ein SWR2-Forum über das Glück der Dänen mit Klaus-Ruhe Matzen und Bürgermeister Norstak und so weiter, der ja auch Däner ist und da von Amts wegen erst mal das Du allen verordnet hat. Wenn er angesprochen wird, dann bitte mit Du und Klaus und so. Und naja, so sind sie, die Europäer. Wir auch, wir Deutschen. Wir sind da auch nicht besser dran. Aber so offen zeigen, tun wir es nicht.
Das in der Tat nicht. Wir verabschieden uns für heute und wollen nur noch sagen, wir werden im nächsten Salon dann wieder ein sehr, sehr umfangreiches Buch besprechen, nämlich das von David Graeber. Das Ende des Monatsjahr auf Deutsch erscheint. Sofern ein guter Anlass, um das dann ausführlich zu analysieren.
Richtig, richtig, richtig. Sehr gut. Na dann, bis Ende des Monatsjahr erstmal zur regulären Folge. Haut rein, kommt gut noch in das Arbeitsjahr. Wir sind ja erst im Jahr angekommen. Jetzt kommen wir auch ins Arbeitsjahr. Mal gucken, wie lange uns Corona hier noch in Schach hält. Vielleicht ist ja schon Ende Januar jeder einmal durch.
Bis dann.